the c-span school bus crew learned more
about cable television in texas from
bill arnold oh the association at the
state level we put on a state trade show
really a regional state regional trade
show convention
we do grassroots lobbying in austin
as well as lobbying in austin we do
grassroots lobbying at the
washington level
answer questions provide information we
represent
cable systems and poll attachment
negotiations over rates things of that
nature we end up doing just a little bit
of everything we visit with people like
yourselves who are wanting information
or just curious you'll have just on
people that are not associated with the
industry at all call and want
information and so you're just kind of a
clearing house may be the best way to
describe it
the c-span school bus continues to tour
texas and recently several individuals
active in texas politics came on board
for a roundtable discussion
for the next 40 minutes we'll show you
that conversation among those taking
part former texas agriculture
commissioner jim hightower and molly
ivins a columnist for the fort worth
star telegram
well we're gathered here
in historic shells garden made
historic by a
sequence of
generation after generation of drunks
gathered under these
uh cockadoro trees
there are many people think they're elms
but it's actually the
very exotic species cockadatoro and much
of that has been spread over the years
right here at
good quality picnic tables like this and
we've assembled some of the major drunks
still
available
in austin texas to discuss their own
fond memories
of uh schultz carpenter
molly ivins uh who's
if
you don't know molly ivan's then you're
just not watching enough c-span let me
tell you that because she's on there
about every 45 minutes as far as i can
tell
not only has an electric column in the
newspaper but the the author now not one
but two best-selling uh books the united
states of america we're so proud of her
she's so big around the world these days
of course if you render the bs out of
her should fit in the matchbox
molly you've uh you've been here more
than once i understand i've been working
at chelsea garden since the late 1960s
and i first fell in the habit of
drinking down here uh with a group
called the horses association you don't
tell me the truth i do tell you the
truth the horse's association was a
group of absolutely splendid citizens of
texas almost all of the liberal
persuasion and when i think back on it
now we spent every friday night down
here for year after year after year
and was a group remarkable not only
for their devotional constitution
and their love was sitting around there
in political gossip
but actually remarkable because i think
as a group of friends we were the most
heterogeneous i've ever known
not by race i must admit race in those
days was even here in the liberal part
of texas still pretty much taboo
but
we were as varied in age and is married
in economic status as any group of
friends i've ever had
i think everybody from our carpenter
friend henry holman is now up in his 80s
and still here at schultz gardener right
everybody's children and grandchildren
many a child and it's full-grown today i
first met sat down clunk from the place
of honor in a baby basket in the middle
of the table
now some of them have grown up to be
legislators
no tell them what happened to you if you
come here
well ed edwin
this is a guy who is a poor
liberal campaigner back in the 60s and
the 70s and then he he hit it big became
a major developer
now he's falling down he's gone bankrupt
and he's having to lobby for a living
but what better place than the schultz
garden edward tell us some of what's
going on here with you
well
right now i'm reduced to having to to
unduly influence the government for a
living but
in past in past years i was involved in
the liberal movement and worked hard in
it still do actually as you know
but i remember a lot that happened here
over my lifetime and and indeed i i now
have a daughter that comes here
who works in politics
full-time i have a granddaughter who
comes here regularly and works in
politics full-time so and they're all of
the liberal persuasion as molly says
so this kind of a family place it was a
family place and still is in a lot of
ways
a lot that happened here
it's sort of a
school of public affairs in a way and so
on some public affairs too by the way
[Laughter]
so
but but truly people learned here and
it's serious we laugh about it but
people did learn here
about a philosophy and how to to try to
make that philosophy
cause something actually to happen
and
that's what bread here and the
revolution that's occurred here and
there has been a revolution in our state
it started right here
the people who hold major office
and have held major office lately that
were something new like yourself
they were all writing all of them
richards was a great member of the
association
and our friend bob bullock
and the the founding of the texas
observer was uh right around these
tables too with bob eckhart and many
fisher cunningham and uh a lot of old
heads of ronnie duggar a young head then
now an old hand you know the observer
that this garden has a literary
tradition not only has this been the
right more than what's carved in the
tables more more than the regular
drinking place of all editors of the
texas observer and most texas
journalists
um
most austin journalists
um this book was featured in a texas
classic novel called the gay place by
billy brammer it was in the novel called
the dearly beloved
beer garden
and there are still some old-timers who
when they want to drink here we'll say
let's go down to the dearly beloved
they're truly
well buckwood speaking up there
ed mentioned things happened here
i believe one or two good things
happened while you were around the
tables well first of all when you i came
to college down here in 1964
and i was the
fourth
member of my family to attend college
down here and it was one of the first
things that you were either warned
against depending on whether it was my
parents or whether it was my brothers
and sisters are told it was to make sure
you went there was to come to schultz's
so by the time i was in law school i was
i was a regular here and i i don't know
that i met ed windler here but it was
somewhere close to here and it wasn't
long after we met we came here
but uh not only is this place old not
only has it been
a center of political activity
uh for many many years it was a uh
and still is in the control of the males
family
and
there was a young fellow that i admit
that
he's recently deceased he died just
recently and larry bales who
i got to know and
to love
his at that time his uncle was running
the place he later ran it for years
and
he decided to run for state legislature
and at that point in time we had a major
banking scandal in texas and about half
the legislature got thrown out and
i got hired by common cause to try to
pass a bunch of reform legislation
but they did more
reform legislation but they didn't have
didn't have it all drafted out at that
time this was in the early days of
common cause
and larry bells and a bunch of other
people including ed windler and molly
ivins and a bunch of people sat around
and
talked about what ought to be in these
bills and
some of them were literally hammered out
usually inside instead of the outside
but uh that right down here in the beer
guard
there's been some
great political fights here there's been
some pretty good physical fights here
usually over political matters yourself
including myself
so you got you got uh liquidated here
lubricated in order to be hallucinating
and we know we know historically not
that was in 1973 but if you go back and
talk to people that molly's mentioned
everything
a lot of the major political deals were
cut in schultz and prior to that i mean
bill bremer when he wrote the gay place
was not it was not a
a fictitious
pictorial it was in fact a place where
people met and cut deals you either cut
deals with a lobby down in the citadel
club or you came to schultz's that was
the two places where you where you
worked your group
and
being somewhat of a historian and so
forth i i always enjoyed working out my
political deals here
i can't even remember working one out in
the citadel club which is no longer in
existence because it refused to admit
women and then when we got some women in
the legislature they went out of
business
i always felt that there should be a
sign on the interstate over here uh
saying schultz garden you know four
blocks or whatever they got signs that
say university of texas i mean my god
you can see that thing spreading for 40
miles out before you if you can't find
ut from the interstate then you're not
smart enough to go there anyway it seems
to me so we ought to have one short
garden about four blocks but one thing's
for sure
there's very very few prominent
graduates university of texas haven't
spent some time here
well we got a guy here doug zabo comes
all the way down the interstate from
iowa
the northern suburb of texas uh and uh
it's my understanding this was your very
first stop when you came to austin was
right here at chelsea
sort of a pilgrimage
when i was in school here back in the
age of the dinosaurs i lived across the
street literally in a little frame house
it was right after the peloponnesian
waters
and there was a serious discussion about
running a water hose from the beer tap
you know making sense that didn't work
out
i left shortly thereafter and was gone
to the east coast to learn the yankee
ways like lolly did
and came back here in 1968 uh
very strange combination i came back
here working for robert kennedy's
political campaign
in lyndon johnson state
at which time i think i befriended you
yes because you were working
for ralph yarborough a few other
riff-raffles and other
so
kind of going a lot of circles around
here
and speaking of governor richards
in 1972
we had a fellow come into the state by
the name of clinton
and a woman by the name of hillary
and they were down here working politics
1972 they were registering voters all
over texas all the southwest
and they were a people that came here
and they got acquainted with my boss
currently and gary morrow who's our
state land commissioner
who later became bill clinton's campaign
manager
in fact
i can't show this to the camera but i'll
show it to you
they also met somebody by the name of
richards
and these pictures
are van richards
and bill clinton and barbara jordan and
gary morrow and schultz's beer garden no
kid so there have been some reputable
people here
and the nice thing is this all occurred
shortly before larry bale's back
which i think is a very nice
nice way to go out well that's right
bill clinton who had been
who was a drinker regular drinker here
at shell's garden back in his his uh
young organizing days
came back after he got elected president
and they had a party for him right in
there and in fact one of the last things
larry did was they shook the press out
of that party it was friends only
um
so
larry bales loaned me a shoulder beer
garden waitress costume and i smart with
my little notepad to take drink orders
went in
and took notes one of my last great
undercover assignments is it girl
i love it did you deserve any beer oh
you bet i got several orders
and turned them over to reliable person
well we should we should make mention
the fact that beer is the center part of
schultz garden
has been old germans who in fact this
beer right here shiner just down the
road
150 miles or so but who's counting
was created by german farmers
who emigrated and the very first thing
they did was to set up a still
to make beer
a big copper cattle but they made very
bad beers so the very first thing they
did was to send a delegation back to
germany import them a brewmaster
by the name of spetzel and henceforward
this beer and i guess probably the
equivalent was served here back in the
old days i don't know it was the only
brewery in the country that stayed open
straight through prohibition indeed yeah
well and one of the things you're
mentioning that this choices is still
owned by the sacramento which is which
is a german it's a german singer
society
and uh and they still play that old kind
they still operate 15 cents a game
they hire the irish for them
i don't like kant's comment about this
being a school for public affairs and i
would say not just public
i think some of the greatest discussions
i've ever heard in my life have been
right here at shoulder spearguard
and
our late friend sam whitton who
was a well-read man a professor of
library science at the university and i
once agreed that the best argument we'd
ever heard was right here at the garden
and it was between the late martin
wiggington who was a local political
organizer and radical
and our friend fletcher boone who was
then running an art gallery
and the two of them got into a
discussion
about whether art
or politics was more important whether
beauty or justice whether bread or roses
was more important and i want to tell
you it was such an argument that it was
like
two and three rings of people circled
the table it's like watching a tennis
match and everybody went back and forth
and first fletcher would hold forth and
then martin would hold forth and it was
the most amazing goddamn mark and then
in the history of the beer garden and it
went on for about two and a half hours i
mean they kept the garden open late past
closing time because everybody's so
absorbed in this discussion there was
the two of them and you know them both
fighting for what they really really
believed in it was an extraordinary
evening
and it ended
when
fletcher who had an enormous beer gut
and who by that time had 17 long-necked
empties lined up on this side of the
table
rose for a final repose and his gut
knocked over all the empties
better than german bowling
he could suck down beers faster than bob
wood bob packwood can steal kisses
did you know that martin wigginton at
his own request is buried in potter's
field with no gravestone no i didn't
know he wanted to be buried with the
people
that'd been married
to high school and a lot of fine people
i've followed along behind most of these
people he's a star baseball player you
know oh yeah
yeah yeah pitched at ut before he
decided to
do the other things we know and love him
who's the name of his bar that he had uh
it was uh
no there was an imminent first it was
named after emma
emma goldman yeah and joe hill
it's kind of a little bit of a tip as to
where his pocket is
on the left
well then fletcher went on to the raw
deal you got to remember
he calls it the garden you know it
because it kind of is a
place all of its own this is the garden
and it had its own way of discriminating
as to who could come here and who
couldn't because
i remember one time back in the the
years when frank irwin was chairman of
the border
and uh and was uh loathed by all the the
liberals though in lots of ways we we
liked him very much personally and had
our own
good times with him but this was a place
he wouldn't come he would never come
here and a group of students talked him
into coming one time
and it's the only time i ever knew frank
irwin to come here and he sat right
there
and as he sat there in this garden a
bird did it on him
and nearly on his coat and he looked
[Laughter]
who inhabit these trees
well i hear they're the ghosts of dead
of dead liberals anyway
one of the great ongoing literary
attractions of show speargarden is the
graffiti in the restrooms and i myself
have never frequented the men's room
here no matter how serious because i'll
take it or at least you don't remember
that i do remember uh at exchange this
was back when frank when was chairman of
the ut board of regents he was lyndon
johnson's man and he really was in many
ways a miserable some [ __ ]
and i went into the ladies room one
night and there was a note on the wall
saying do a good deed today give
frankfurt when you clap
underneath which somebody else had
written give it to him hell charge him
[Laughter]
anybody else got any tales of wonderment
i'm trying to remember about mad dog
incorporated bad dogs
a very important corporation and it
brought dedicated profit right
we just never made it
and it was we bought up texas towns and
they've all been well i don't remember
when we almost bought sister dale we
would have bought sisterhood but there
was a misunderstanding about the
placement of a decimal point in the
purchase price
did not happen
because i recall was love
mad dog was
manufacture and distribute barbecue
flavored vaginal gel
in an effort to make money i mean some
great ideas have been born around these
tables it's just that we're bad on
followers we just had somebody with a
little entrepreneurial gumption to take
that
drinker is that you think up these
magnificent things and you leave follow
through to all those people out there
who don't get to spend their lives
drinking beer under this day
i love it well bud shrek was mayor at
one time
all right willie morris
and i can't remember who else was very
distinguished people
and i know that was frank and willie
morgan distinguished people
well
he heard tv was coming sure anyway
important enterprise it was indeed
headquartered here this was the
headquarters of mad dog
i remember once i i'm older than y'all
all i think and i i'm not here
considerably
but
i remember one of the first things
made me think a lot about politics i was
in here
with a group of people
and i and i didn't know many people here
at the time
and a
crowd was here and a man walked in that
gate over there
i didn't know him hispanic man
he walked in and everybody stood
as he walked in the door and clapped and
i thought god why would this man come
here why would they all clap what could
he have done you know it turned you know
what it was was albert pena
first time
he had just
taken him on in san antonio right the
first person to do that hispanic
and all the anglos he's probably the
only hispanic in the place huh molly
everybody stood and clapping okay
a person can
can mean something you know and be
recognized for having done something
that
the rest of the world might not
understand
he's still down there doing it too for
sure yeah he's still still hanging in
there
i do think that
the ties of community among the texas
progressives getting it here i mean
many of the wakes we've had in this
garden think of the 50th wedding
anniversaries think of all the goddamn
political parties we've had here
still having here still having here
maddox had a big one here last night
jim maddox had one here last night ann
richards had one here when she was
elected county commissioner
i remember that over there she walked in
walked out that door
everybody cheered well you know one of
my favorites and richards county
commissioners one of my favorite stories
about annie
was uh at a party here i swear to god i
think charlie wilson was thinking about
running for statewide office i can't
remember
i remember that everybody who was
anybody in texas politics was here alan
shivers came to show the spear garden it
was an amazing night no standards and
everybody's just meeting and greeting at
a furious place and a little group of us
got the tired feet halfway through the
evening went to our butts against the
table at the back wall of shoulder spear
garden right over there
and um hurts kind of like birds in a row
bob bullock
who was then our comptroller and myself
the guy named charlie miles who was the
head of bob's personnel department black
guy the reason why bob always had such a
good record in minority hiring and ms
anne richards well you know bullock he
knows every story no good sumbitch in
the entire state
so some terrible racist judge comes up
clap one another on the back have a big
grief but i said judge i want you to
meet my friends this is molly evans but
the dallas times herald the judge
appeared up at me and said hey you
little lady
and this is charles miles the head of my
personnel department charlie stuck out
his hand and the judge got an expression
on his places that he had just stepped
into a fresh cup
took him a good long minute before he
went out he said hey you boy
and then turning great really to
critically right and richard says and
who is this lovely lady and then beamed
and said i am mrs mine
that's right i was here yeah
i haven't brought that night
that night
my wife came and drank beer and ate
nachos you know you're not supposed to
do that when you're pregnant all this
stuff
she
went into like
flavor that night when we got to the we
got to the hospital they always ask you
you know what if you had anything to eat
yeah a lot of beer hamburgers and nachos
this is gonna be a bad delivery
bring out the rubber shoes
i remember that one very well
yeah
my daddy used to say ty if you just sip
it it doesn't count that's right that's
right be all right
well jim hightower
you're in the radio business i'm in the
radio business i'm on the electric radio
and soon to be more so
well i haven't heard testing out there
to america got to start a weekend show
three hour doses of high tower saturday
and sunday can you stand it are you
gonna have call-ins call-ins
no buckwood
what can happen to you come to shoals
garden then next thing you know your
national radio phenomenon
right all that happens too
they're going into labor
that may be the topic of the story why
didn't everybody bring their kids to the
garden and they still do but
then we used to bring their dogs too
and i am sorry to say that i had for
many years in fact for 15 years a dog
named [ __ ]
and she was a regular chef
down here at the garden
and uh she loved coming to the garden
because people would always give her the
jalapenos off their nachos that was a
purebred texas blacktown and she loved
jalapenos
scarfed them up we all think you all got
courage in bringing people here i
brought ralph nader here
no
iced tea
he's still he's still having some nacho
shock
[Laughter]
doesn't drink doesn't even like his
beard
well you remember jake i did a lot last
time held her deal here
up here you remember that no
oh yeah she held it up here and there
were more people in those fbi suits
she could build a crowd from the police
anti-vietnam war thing
right here
the amount of fbi and the cia and all
those we've had clinton here we had
any presidents here beside the team
bush came once and ordered drum
boulevard
[Laughter]
remember ford didn't come here he went
to san antonio and tried to eat it
he's still got the shotgun
every time i see him
well y'all we just filled with everybody
drinking some beer here
looking real good at the camera
staring in the picture look at the
inspiration holly i believe that's one
of them foreign beers isn't it it is
boring
it's not even a german foreign
used to meet here in the 30s
our texas germans have always been
really liberal
but i was told that there was something
silly wait wait wait we didn't run for
statewide
they were abolitionists in those german
communities
from texas yeah
comfort texas and utopia i believe the
only union monument in the state of
texas is in conflict
[Laughter]
i don't know if they got rich but they
don't think we would call into that area
my folks all came from bernie
they're always living there yeah they're
all very conservative german
and i went up there to discover my past
and it turns out they came to sister
dale first
sister dale was a group of dissidents
from germany who came over here called
themselves free thinkers
in a community communal society and they
wouldn't let a preacher spend the night
uh you know we should think about that
but
yeah i am it didn't last it didn't last
very long
and they spent the night in town and so
i was telling my
present ancestors there that story oh no
yeah don't talk don't talk about that
one
are they a free thinker no not ours
you know there were a lot of atheists
among the early germans
they had all fallen in love with the
french revolution and they believed in
liberty equality and fraternity
well
utopia is not this name they thought
yeah i thought they were going to have
one
unfortunately they were in texas
for a lot of my a lot of my ancestors
were swedes and they were up and around
the room factory
they shared that same political
philosophy
my daddy's side
he had his his father was in the
tennessee legislature in the civil war
and uh
he left tennessee at that time saying
that this is not
a war that's fit to fight in this is a
rich man's war and a poor man's fight
always the case
he left the state
texas populated with people
and the same thing's going on today
people are coming in from mexico
some of them are coming for economic
reasons for political reasons we've got
people from salvador
casa marinella that you have so much to
do with
refuge homes and people from central
america that are suffering well you know
who the patron saint of this beer garden
is is sam houston yeah that's true the
first great texas liberal and also known
by his indian name big
drunk dropped me
that kind of man
[Music]
big johnson
what was that motto he had
what was sam houston's motto you know do
right and ignore consequences
we ought to be over here
sail houston swampland
[Laughter]
i thought that was a real easy thing to
lean in on
geniuses they don't know that
around here
how but you argue
well we'd pour you over here but
do right risk consequences
well there's a world of politicians
doing that today aren't they
[Laughter]
wheat delivered
a guy with a suit yeah the state senator
gonzalo bariento see when you're a state
senator you have to wear things like
this
and gonzo is about to wrap himself in
the texas flag
the guy has no shame whatsoever
what's that you got all your titles
when i was in high school my first
campaign john kennedy's pt boat now
we're talking about it it's gonna stay
there when you don't see the pt boat you
don't see barrientos anymore way out
there so you're another one of them
liberals
well people call me yes say yes say yes
remember where you are here you are
c-span you can say yes
well according to the last poll i took
it's all right
and so yes i am
knows how to pronounce his name now even
that's right everybody can pronounce
marientos
that was tougher than you know when i
started out remember tell about your
first uh campaign ad you ran well
i had a cowboy looking guy and he'd say
marianas yeah then i had a hispanic he'd
say barrientos
then i had a young anglo girl and she
said marianas
and now come on no matter how you
pronounce it it's bariento's best for
travis county
ready
stations
and you always carry a texas flag with
you well actually this is for a
retirement party over there elsewhere
tomorrow for wally pryor great man
talking about the name you know what
they used to call it
they say
burritos
yeah barracuda
[Music]
i was going to offer to pour you
something in the way of a light beer but
i said you have it in your hand already
you brought your own victory of the gods
that's what i'm talking about and the
gods live right here in schultz garden
and that's why c-span has come all this
way
ever tell you that story about uh travis
county farmers union first time i ran
i go out there in my suit and here come
all the farmers call white farmers and
they're in their overalls and muddy
booths they come in
pretty soon the chair gets up and
decides well let's get this here i'm
eating started because we got a lot of
business transactions beside that we got
this old boy who's running for the
legislature don't you know
and uh so right now y'all be sure enough
asking questions cause he's gonna ask
you for your vote so without further ado
i want to present y'all right now mr
caliente
straight up i'll say
well
right probably thought tonight
because i'll tell you one thing
if a lot of people knew that the farmer
provides all the food and fiber for the
world sometimes bound with bare hands
we'd all be better off don't you know
and they started doing these double
tastes and i knew what they were
thinking pretty good
been in the fields i went like that to
the very end and i said now don't y'all
forget neighbors it's barrientos
b-a-r-r-i-e-n-t-o-s god bless
got that endorsement
talking turkey and they didn't vote for
caliente
true story
i still think the best political
advertisement i ever saw in this state
was uh one time when claude hoopland was
running for el paso county commissioner
it came on the top
claude
i didn't know he did that commissioner
his wife mrs hooper and the family dog
and all three of them stand in front of
a large american flag
the family dog had on a kind of red
white and blue tutu and it stood up on
its hind legs and danced around in a
circle while mrs newton said we're
rooting for him
celestial el paso
i first met him i never know
unfortunately that
commercial has lost forever
as far as i know no one's ever said it
for the archives kathleen jameson needs
to know about that
well the best campaign slogan i heard
was old joe hubenak you were in
legislature with that great citizen i
know what you're going to do
once campaign for statewide office on
the basis of not always right but always
trying
[Laughter]
honesty in
oh politics i loved it i used it my next
game
[Laughter]
on the radio now that's right
real real upset about the foreign
problem you remember the
foreign brown it was upset about the
fire well even before reagan brambles
have said john joe you've nash was upset
no didn't feel bragging
he was in favor of nuking the fire
well we won't ever forget that it's not
far from this beer garden where one of
our agricultural commissioners mr brown
decided to demonstrate that fire ants
really were a problem and he
went out on the capitol grounds and
found a mound and
tried to stir them up a little bit so
that the tv cameras could get he had one
of those cameras in front of them yeah
and tried to make sure that they and of
course the problem was the cameras
weren't set up just yet so he held the
hand in there until the cameras got set
up and of course by the time they got
set up he was in
deep trouble
this is this was during his one of his
great campaigns against his uh
bit so
that's when i knew i had him because he
i just knew people were sitting there
you know with the crank back in the
laser board with one of these in her
hand thinking well that dumb son of a
[ __ ]
he's sitting there with his hands
put his hand right
the next morning i was flying from
dallas to los angeles on american
airlines
and i got on the plane that that picture
was in the paper
and i sat down you know how to sit on
the airplane listen everybody else talk
and all these dallas businessmen with
their neckties and so forth were opening
up their paper
and they started this conversation
across the aisles
and they said
look at it
this guy has got to go
and i'm talking about the conservative
dallas man said this guy you don't have
to you know he says pull your hand out
of a fiery man i'm talking about
something and counting it
but then you really get in reagan
browning that campaign
was um he was
speaking to a group of teachers
and um
he was kind of hard to overcome he had a
problem pronouncing the word negro as
many people from these texas did yes
and it often came out negro uh which is
an east texas pronunciation
and um
he was trying to overcome this uh widely
held impression that he was somewhat
racist so he got to bragging on booker t
washington he said that that great black
[ __ ]
and then he
he didn't hear himself but apparently
people in the audience kind of went
and he said oh oh no i beg your pardon i
meant to say that great right [ __ ] and
then he heard it and got all embarrassed
and clustered
and uh the whole thing was uh on the
television tape and um the next day
reagan brown had a press conference
announcing that the reason he had
uh mispronounced that word
was because he had eaten a bad turkey
sandwich the day before
i myself had bad turkey
and that's when craig washington then
the legislature said sounds like he ate
a bad honky sandwich to me
but it's that kind of political
leadership that's made next is what it
is
what about the woodrow bean story oh
lord well courtney woodrow visited the
garden every time he came along um
woodrow
let's say my favorite woody bean story
is
probably so many great woody bank
stories for the time
woodrow had a client the court assigned
him to defend the young man who was not
talented in his chosen field of endeavor
the guy had wanted to be a stick-up
artist and he held up a grocery store
and made it off with a pile of loot but
all i had to put it in was the brown
paper bags from the grocery store well
it was double bagged for safety
but even so not a shrewd move and the
guy was a little clumsy and basically
the police were on his tail from the
beginning it's a high-speed chasing suit
in the desert outside el paso with this
young stick-up artist driving around and
circling some cops screaming after him
and at one point the guy stopped ditched
the loop drove on
they finally caught him they put his ass
in jail
and woodrow is assigned to defend the
guy
and comes and talks to him and says son
what'd you do with the money and the
kids said well uh sir i left you down
the desert by an oil well here there
gave all the directions
after it interviewed the young man and
thought what he could do for his defense
woodrow went out to where the kid had
ditched the loot and hooked himself to a
very generous speech
from the brown paper bags
and as he drove away he said to himself
woodrow wilson bean you are skating on
the thin edge of ethics
he drove a little bit further and said
to himself woodrow wilson
ethics is for young lawyers
i know what he stories but i can't tell
him
we can't tell him remember when he ran
for congress against mark bye
he had forgotten to pay i'm sure he'd
forgotten to pay his federal income
taxes about 40. for several years
and this came out toward the end of the
campaign
and of course woodrow was very fast on
his feet he says you know he's well the
centerpiece of my campaign is to abolish
the income
didn't work
he lost
and martin dyson
led us back into the mccarthy era
take your flag
bye y'all take care see you later
i think we've done this we've done this
have we done this i think we've signs
are getting cold that's right
i think we're
through off the bike everybody's telling
real stories
this debates of 1858
beginning in august on c-span
next the annual convention of the
national organization for women commonly
known as now
the convention began friday in san
antonio texas as now leaders started
planning efforts to address more women's
rights issues
in this session of the conference you'll
hear the keynote address delivered by
the president of now patricia ireland
along with speeches by nationally
syndicated columnist molly ivins and
founder of the national political
congress of black women c dolores tucker
also during this session a kickoff of
the elect women for a change campaign
for the 1994 elections
this program runs just under two hours
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
so
it's okay we can keep doing this for a
while yeah
how beautiful you all look from up here
we're in a beautiful place in a
beautiful state at a
most magnificent feminist organization
in the world
and we're here to do work and have fun
and make
incredible history this is a history
making conference
and it is my pleasure
my great pleasure my great honor
to have the pleasure of introducing
a very historic woman
a woman who has brought to this
organization
great vision
incredible strategy
she'll lift you through the heights i
don't know if she'll bring a tear to
your eye but she certainly will
make you laugh and inspire you on to
greater heights
the greatest feminist in the world our
president patricia ireland
thank you thank you very much
thank you so much
and to you
thank you
[Applause]
what a pleasure to be back in texas and
to be back in texas under much better
circumstances than last time i was here
which was the 5 30 shift of
the operation rescue fight back during
the houston convention
i think it was worth that fight
certainly the election outcome uh made
it worth that fight
i uh i'm here because i have so much
excitement about what we're doing in
1994 and how our strategies are playing
out the great victories that we have
that we celebrate to
reinvigorate ourselves and reinspire
ourselves and also the challenges that
we face with the right wing we know that
we're so much stronger than we were even
a year ago when we met in boston and
we've seen so many images
that carry us through the difficult days
ahead
one of my favorites of course is
thinking of the incredible shift in
terms of women's power in our country
and seeing carol mosley brawn on the
floor of the united states senate
senator mosley braun taking on the u.s
senate on issues of racism forcing them
to rescind the special protection that
they had given to the insignia of the
daughters of the confederacy
and i especially liked her style in
doing that
you know you go to washington as a as a
new
first-year legislator and there's all
kinds of arcane rules and and unwritten
rules and ways that the game is played
and it's been used to keep women and any
newcomers out of positions of power but
carol mosley braun was having none of
that
basically what she did was she said i've
got the mic
you've got the problem
and she refused to give the mic back
until they had scurried around gotten a
floor strategy together figured out how
to undo what they had done
and i will never forget that and i will
never forget the image of senator dianne
feinstein clasping her hand as carol
mosley braun spoke from her heart
about what racism had meant in her life
and how important it was that the senate
undo what they had done
certainly i'll never forget being in the
white house at a reception and seeing
roberta achtenberg there
[Applause]
as you know roberta achtenberg was named
by president clinton actually named
by the secretary of housing and urban
development henry cisneros
just to bring things home here henry
cisneros named roberta achtenberg is the
assistant secretary for civil rights at
housing and urban development she is the
highest ranking out lesbian in our
government and we're so proud of her
[Applause]
now of course in the white house and at
hud she's known as an assistant
secretary
in the united states senate some some
like jessie helms still know her as that
damn lesbian
i guess you know the difference between
a lesbian and a damn lesbian
a damn lesbian is politically active
[Applause]
there's been so much that's been moving
and exciting and funny about um the
women invading washington in such great
numbers um and certainly some of it has
been very moving i will always remember
patty murray on the floor of the senate
speaking about the loss of her friend to
ovarian cancer
and the impact of not having the funding
and the research for women's health
issues
and we will also never forget that the
women in congress in the 103rd congress
got fully
334 million dollars more for breast
cancer and and ovarian cancer to be
researched and treated in this country
it's a very important breakthrough in
fact there have been 30-some pieces of
pro-women legislation out of the 103rd
congress compared to three or four or a
handful in each prior congress we've
been
leaping forward not just stepping
forward in congress
and yet we see that there are um still
so many more gains that we need to be
made while we've won the freedom of
access to clinic entrances act a major
victory in congress
[Applause]
and we have seen the violence against
women act passed by both the senate and
the house but it is now languishing in
the conference committee as part of the
crime bill and we need to keep the
pressure on to blast that bill out of
conference committee and into law
[Music]
you know in the last congress the 102nd
congress when i spoke uh in the in a
prior
year my speech noted that the violence
against women act which was then
languishing in congress as well
had 74 percent of the women across party
lines taking leadership as co-sponsors
of the violence against women act 74 of
the women and only 47 percent of the men
and it became very clear why we needed
more of us there after the 1992
elections and and after all of the work
that you have been doing to raise these
issues and to bring pressure on the
congress members we now have 85 percent
of the women and 51 percent of the men
who are leaders as co-sponsors the
violence against women act so i'm sure
that we are going to get that bill
on the
[Applause]
we don't know
whether that bill would have prevented
the tragedy of nicole brown simpson
we don't know whether o.j simpson killed
her
but we do know that nicole brown simpson
was murdered by someone
and that she was the battered wife of a
big sports hero
and that the system failed both of them
this is only the most
vivid and recent
and highly visible example of why we
need the fully funded violence against
women act
every 12 seconds
a woman is beaten
every four minutes a woman dies from
that kind of violence every three to six
minutes a woman is raped it's thousands
of us
a day
millions of us in our lifetime
and last year in boston when i spoke to
you i asked then can you imagine
what would happen if women were
attacking men in anywhere near those
numbers
well we don't have to imagine any more
we know what happened when one woman
attacked one man
does the name lorena bobbitt ring a bell
[Applause]
have you ever seen so much press about
one body part
so as a nation
we talked openly
during that period of of the infamous
bobbitt case
and the nation listened
to the discussion about
what is known widely as domestic
violence which is a euphemism for wife
battery
and
we listened to a young woman tell the
story of her hopes and her dreams for
her life in this country
and of her fear of abuse and rape at the
hands of her husband
and of the pain of dependence
uh as a legal immigrant
on this abusive husband
for her legal status to live and work in
this country
i guess it shouldn't be a surprise that
a lot of men were far too busy worrying
about john wayne bobbitt's penis to
notice that women had begun this
nationwide dialogue about violence
certainly john wayne bobbitt was not
listening
apparently he wasn't paying attention in
any case since he was arrested two
months
later for abusing his new fiancee only
days before their scheduled wedding
too often men who beat women literally
get away with murder
their words and their actions are
handled with a wink and a nod by the
judicial system by the law enforcement
community and by other men
unfortunately unfortunately
the treatment that o.j simpson received
was
not unusual in the criminal justice
system
when the police were called to the
simpson home after eight prior calls
nicole beaten and bruised
her lip cut her blackened eye
begged them to arrest oj
as is all too often the case o.j simpson
himself the police the judge his
corporate sponsors
all apparently saw his violence as a
family matter
a private concern
and o.j was allowed to plea bargain for
community service a laughable 700 dollar
fine
500 of which went to a battered women's
shelter and yes he did get counseling by
telephone
hertz renewed his contract as a
corporate sports uh corporate
spokesperson after he was a convicted
wife batterer
nbc hired him as a sports broadcaster
after he was convicted as a wife
batterer
but actually that's only one example and
there are so many local less high
profile cases that can be cited
in october our ohio now chapter held
protests over the release of a man who
had been convicted of beating his wife
over the head with a crowbar
judge william matthews of cincinnati
allowed the man to serve a three to five
year sentence but freed him after only
seven months
in april 1992 judge crater of the 17th
district of in idabel oklahoma reduced
the sentence of a man who had killed his
wife to just five years four of them
suspended
but after crediting the time spent
before his trial in jail judge crater
allowed the release of this man in only
three months
citing the fact that he had after all
not used a firearm to bludgeon his wife
to death
two years earlier when another husband
had shot and killed his wife with an
elephant gun
judge crater suspended his sentence and
released him from prison after less than
six months
judge william o'neill of carroll county
superior court in new hampshire
sentenced a man to 28 days served over
weekends for beating his wife from whom
he'd been separated for a year
the husband found the woman in a tent
camping with another man
and beat her in the face with a
flashlight
the judge thought the beating was too
severe
and said to the battered woman to have
slapped you might have been more normal
this past june judge frank eppes of the
10th circuit court in cone county south
carolina
called the case of a man who kidnapped
his ex-wife and mother-in-law bound them
with duct tape and repeatedly shocked
them with a cattle prod a domestic thing
the judge suspended the entire sentence
in favor of five years probation and 60
months house arrest
again these are just a few of the
examples these were reported in red but
red book magazine in february 1994 of
what goes on in courts across the
country every day and why it's long past
time to pass the violence against women
act
[Applause]
so many examples the pennsylvania know
is not enough ruling by their supreme
court on rape
so many examples
as we look at the story of nicole brown
simpson i think that we also have to
recognize that racism as well as
violence against women is a very
disturbing undercurrent in the simpsons
story
as images of o.j and nicole flashed
across the television screen and and
jumped off of the newsstands
at us although more and more nicole
seems to be fading from the picture
it's obvious that we must be more
mindful of our country's
racist history
when a black man is accused of brutally
murdering a white woman and a white man
he is much more likely to die
by lynching or after a trial than if the
races were reversed
and because that tradition is still
reflected in our legi in our criminal
justice system the house passed the race
racial justice act as part of the crime
bill and we must be conscious of the
need to keep that
uh disparity that race and racism in
that history in mind and to recognize
that oj has pleaded not guilty and that
the prosecutors still must prove this
case to a jury
but we can't help wondering
whether the violent deaths of nicole
brown simpson and ron goldman
could have been prevented whether john
bobbitt's battery of lorena and her
maiming of him might have been avoided
if our country and our congress
had prioritized and taken seriously
the violence against women and had
passed the violence against women act
earlier
when passed the violence against women
act will provide training programs for
police judges and administrative court
personnel funding for battered women's
shelters development of a national
hotline and educational programs for
schools about violence
and protection for battered immigrant
women like lorena bobbitt
and for those of you
and i hope there are very few of you in
the audience who are still
laboring under the traditional culture
that says a good woman always puts
someone else first the good wife the
good mother the good woman always puts
someone else first and if you don't
think that you as a woman deserve this
kind of protection let me put it in a
broader context because it is a cultural
problem that pervades our culture
violent juvenile offenders are four
times more likely to have grown up in a
household where they saw violence
they learned that violence is how you
resolve conflicts
the young boys learn that violence is
how you become a man
kids who grow up in violent homes are
five times more likely as adults to
become perpetrators or victims of
violence
women who are battered have two and a
half times the health care costs of
other women as we debate the rising
health care costs can we deal with that
reality can we recognize that women in
major cities it is the leading cause or
a leading cause of women's using
emergency room
emergency rooms
and pregnant women
let me just stop for a minute and
acknowledge that the latest
anti-feminist book of the month club
submission
has said that it is not accurate to say
and i will say it again because it is
accurate
that battery of pregnant women is a
leading cause of birth defects
and if you add into that the
miscarriages the stillborns and the low
birth weight babies whose health will
also be at risk it is the leading cause
of all of those problems that babies
have
and so we must continue to fight and we
will continue to fight we're not going
to back down
the other provision of the violence
against women act that i think is very
important is the civil rights provisions
because far too often as as we've seen
in this episode the the violence against
women is seen as a private matter a
family matter a domestic thing
and yet
while we can see that um that the
anti-abortion violence or the racist
violence is clearly political
and has an impact on the civil rights of
people of color and abortion rights
supporters and providers of services i
think far too often we don't see the
political implications of the violence
against women
and and that
part of if not the heart of the violence
against women act is a recognition that
women who are
experienced violence because of
gender-based hatred must have a right to
bring civil rights charges in federal
district court
and i think especially that that we have
to recognize that any system of
inequality any culture of inequality
ultimately
must rest
must be maintained
by violence or the threat of violence
in other words in a sexist patriarchal
patriarchal culture
male violence is normative
and it's important that we recognize
that as a country and that we move
forward that there's so many other
there's so much political violence going
on right now and some of it we have made
some great gains
against
i guess that i i look back with some
smile on my face
as i remember one of the operation
rescue bosses being quoted in the
washington post acknowledging that
within a few years abortion would still
be legal but predicting gleefully that
there would be no one remaining to
perform abortions
well we're here to tell him that he was
wrong
[Applause]
an anti-abortion terrorist may have
murdered david gunn but he didn't kill
his spirit and he didn't kill the
commitment on the contrary he increased
our commitment to the movement for which
of which david gunn was a part
and so we've been joined
by
all of the branches of our government
now in that commitment we've achieved
the
first significant steps in controlling
the rampant violence and mayhem that's
directed at women and doctors we have
passed the freedom of access to clinic
entrances act
[Applause]
we have seen the supreme court uphold
the right of a judge to give an
injunction prohibiting the anti-abortion
extremists from getting up in the face
of the women and the providers who come
to the clinic with the madison decision
yesterday
and of course we have now seen thanks to
um
shelly shannon who couldn't stop talking
about how proud she was of all that she
had done all across the country and all
of the anti-abortion leaders that she
had worked with all across the country
we now finally see the fbi getting
involved in these cases
[Applause]
no longer will the cries of women who
struggle through a gauntlet of
anti-abortion protesters fall on deaf
ears
the government and individual women can
now take direct legal action against the
anti-abortion terrorists whose lawless
violence whose mob violence has impeded
our constitutional rights there are
stiff federal civil and criminal
penalties against these activities but
the victories that we've had
actually provide us with some danger
because with those victories for for
doctors and women who go to the clinics
i think that there is a danger still
for the doctors and for the women who go
to the clinics not only at the clinic
but at their homes at their schools at
the restaurants and beauty parlors and
churches and in this state even at dr
crisps funeral
the harassment of the anti-abortionists
knows no bounds and we must not take
these victories
and become complacent
we need to continue our vigilance we
need to continue our actions and we need
your help
in doing so because the antis say that
they now have nothing to lose
that working within the system doesn't
get them anywhere and just at this
moment when we are making these
breakthroughs they will become more
violent
and we will have to keep going forward
and that's what we will do
[Applause]
so you'll see tomorrow faye clayton and
dr susan wicklund here and we will be
talking about the now versus scheider
decision that the supreme court allowed
us and allowed the federal government to
use the racketeering laws against this
organized violence this mob like
activity
and we will need your help and we will
ask for your help and i know that you'll
give it
we're equally determined of course
to end another type of use of force and
coercion against women that far too many
women experience as we seek equality in
schools and in education and that of
course is sexual harassment
it's certainly no coincidence that
operation rescue leaders or bosses
have now focused in on sexual harassment
as a way to attack the president but
also to attack the feminist movement
they've lost in congress they've lost in
the court just here in texas recently
they lost a major trial with more than a
million dollars damages and so suddenly
they have gotten religion about sexual
harassment
we know that sexual harassment is a
serious allegation
and we are quite confident that our
strategy and what we're doing has
integrity has consistency and will
ultimately be successful it's a serious
allegation
and we know that that both paula jones
and president clinton deserve their day
in court but we are not going to rise to
the bait that the right wing has put out
for us
[Applause]
now we don't we don't think that paula
jones's credibility is automatically
damaged by her associations but we do
find the involvement of the right wing
leaders certainly disingenuous
where was clinton foe clint jackson
cliff jackson when the u.s senate first
refused to hold a hearing for anita hill
where was operation rescue boss randy
terry when the tail hook whistleblowers
were being blown off by the navy
where was willie horton ad author floyd
brown when we were rallying behind the
dozens of women who were accusing
senator bob packwood of harassment
in short where were these right-wing
leaders on other high-profile harassment
cases and why are they suddenly so
concerned about sexual harassment
they're not known for supporting women's
rights after all
leaders like operation rescue boss randy
terry and the 700 club's pat robertson
are trying both to impeach bill clinton
and to bring down the feminist movement
to discredit the feminist movement and
then as a bonus to portray sexual
harassment charges as something that
women do to bring down powerful men
sexual harassment for us trumps politics
we've proven that with packwood
[Applause]
and we know beyond any shadow of a doubt
that sexual harassers are everywhere in
high public positions in executive
suites even in pulpits in fact powerful
men may be more likely to harass women
to see it as some sort of perk or
privilege of their power
and i think of course in this context of
all of the politicians that we've known
over the years who have used uh
sexuality as a way of proving how macho
how masculine how good old boy they are
think for example just for one example
of edwin edwards who is now the governor
of louisiana
edwin edwards used to call himself the
silver zipper
he
he boasted
this this multi-term incumbent boasted
that the only way he would lose an
election is if he were caught in bed
with a little boy or a live boy or a
dead girl
and even after anita hill he still
thought it was a good joke when he was
running against david duke to say they
were both wizards under the sheets
and i would remind us that even after
not only anita hill but paula jones
president clinton
went before the white house press corps
at an annual dinner and joked about the
astroturf in the back of his pickup
truck get over it boys
[Applause]
and so again we have to deal with this
cultural image of what it takes to be a
real man
and how sexual privilege is used and how
and what kind of an abusive power it is
or an abuse
of the
aphrodisiac effect of power
as henry kissinger identified it it may
not be illegal in all cases
but there's certainly plenty of examples
where it is
uh think of the national institutes of
health
gensfold was told that to keep her job
she had to go to a psychiatrist well
which psychiatrist did they send her to
one of their buddies at nih and what did
he define her problem to be she had
self-defeating personality disorder
now mind you self-defeating personality
disorder is no longer even in the manual
of diagnostic
categories
and as nearly as any of us can figure
out what it meant was that margaret
gensfold was not willing to go along to
get along
but in fact what has happened to so many
of these courageous women who have
really martyred themselves
so that other women would survive and
prosper and make gains forward is that
indeed margaret gensbold
like maureen paulsby has really
basically lost her career now that in
itself
is enough of a problem for women but
think also about the agency we're
talking about the national institutes of
health
nih either conducts or funds 85 percent
of the medical research in this country
and if you think for a minute that their
disdain for women stops at sexual
harassment and sex discrimination on the
job think again is there any question
why we don't have the research that that
would give us the solutions to so many
of the of our health problems as women
think think about margaret gensfold her
research was on the
some of the connections between pms and
the brain i myself would like to know
about some of that research
but it's not just nih it's the whole
alphabet soup recently we've seen
allegations of rampant sexual harassment
at the fbi dea cia afd
and of course there's bob packwood
and let us not forget for a minute about
tail hook
because i think that what we saw with
the outcome of tail hook was that the
navy's zero tolerance policy on sexual
harassment meant zero tolerance for the
women who reported and zero punishment
for the men who committed
[Applause]
so many of the problems in the military
i think are magnifications or
intensified
problems that we also see in the
civilian sector
i would i would remind us of course of
the brave young woman in south carolina
shannon faulkner who is making every
effort to integrate the citadel
this is an institution that is paid for
by public tax dollars
that are then used to discriminate
against women taxpayers and their
daughters
now what is the story with the virginia
military institute uh and the citadel
both of whose all-male policies are
being challenged well they say that they
are training citizen soldiers
excuse me
how many of those young men do you think
really become soldiers what they really
become
is the next generation of leaders
political and business leaders not just
in their states of south carolina and
virginia but in fortune 500 companies
they have an alumni network that won't
quit
and they are keeping women out why
because they don't want the competition
they can't stand the heat
[Applause]
but we've also seen some victories even
in this context can we celebrate
the victory of the order to reinstate
greta camera
[Applause]
an award-winning nurse her commander
fought for her to be able to stay
in the military and cried when they had
to drum her out of the military and i
believe and i hope
with all of my heart that as that
decision goes up on appeal it will be
one that we can win
i think we've seen a lot of of
encouraging signs on issues of lesbians
and gays and bisexuals rights
we saw again in in the state of virginia
there's the overturning of the decision
taking sharon bottom's son away from her
[Applause]
now i thought that was a strange strange
trial court decision anyway it's not
only that i think it's strange that a
judge could look at a good mother and
say only because you're a lesbian you
cannot have custody of your child but i
thought it was particularly peculiar
that this judge looked at sharon bottoms
and said you know sharon i don't like
the way you turned out so i'm going to
give your kid to the mother who raised
you i mean does this make sense to you
well fortunately it didn't make any
sense at all to the appellate court
judge and it has been overturned and so
again we have
we have those encouraging signs that
what we are doing is making a difference
and that uh women like greta kamamer
women like sharon bottoms
because of the movement because of the
efforts that we've made over 20 or 25
years because of the shift in public
opinion that we have accomplished on
these issues
are willing to step forward and take the
risks just as the maureen paulsbys and
the
margaret genswolds are willing to step
forward and take the risks and bravely
break the trails for the rest of us and
i'm so proud of them and yet we know
with all of these victories of course
that um part of what happens is that
the right wing then has to find a new
set of villains
if we go back a few years we know that
of course during the cold war the
right-wing leaders
who were spending our nation into
eternal debt
were holding up communism as the threat
to overwhelm us unless we bought bombs
and tanks and cranks crack down on
dissidents at home
well with the red threat dead they need
to find a new way to prevent our
conversion to a peace economy and to
provide support for the ongoing military
excesses at the expense of desperately
needed social programs so in short they
needed a new set of villains and they
haven't taken long to identify them
certainly the lesbians and gays
especially those in the military who
they claim are destroying family values
but also poor people and immigrants who
they claim are stealing stealing our
hard-earned tax dollars in our jobs
and feminists who of course are also
destroying the fabric of our country
anti-abortion terrorists call health
care providers murderers and their fair
targets of justifiable homicide radical
right types categorize lesbians and gays
and supporters of women's rights as
unchristian abortion rights supporters
as feminazis and the far-right
politicians also label african-american
men as criminals and african-american
women as welfare queens
and so we know that the work ahead of us
is going to be very important and part
of the campaign and part of what we will
strategize to expand this weekend
is the campaign
against the right we must fight the
right and certainly
[Applause]
and certainly i think that we can do it
and continue to broaden our efforts to
fight the symbol the loudest mouth of
the right resh limbaugh
[Applause]
[Applause]
now you and i know that under the guise
of humor rush limbaugh is leading the
strongest backlash against everything we
believe in against all that our movement
has fought for and won
and his hate-mongering now is being
underwritten by state and federal tax
dollars rush limbaugh is getting paid
one million dollars of public money to
advertise florida orange juice on his
radio show
now i frankly can't imagine picking a
twice divorced midwesterner to advertise
family values and and florida orange
juice but i guess that the florida
citrus industry decided they only wanted
narrow-minded straight men to drink
their orange juice
and indeed we have accommodated them
[Applause]
because we know that rush limbaugh is
not as he likes to call himself a
harmless little fuzz ball
if you listen to some of his comments
you know what i'm talking about when the
former president reagan calls him the
number one voice for conservatism in
this country
he is not
overstating the case limbaugh likes to
call women feminazis and i have no doubt
that some of his listeners feel much
more justified inventing their rage on
individual women if they can think we
are nazis and it's not just feminists
and women who are his targets he once
responded to an on-air caller who argued
that the african-american community must
be heard by saying
why do they have to be heard they're
only 12 percent of the population who
the hell cares
now of course rush limbaugh can rant and
rave to his heart's content but we also
can fight back against sexist racist
homophobic bigotry
[Applause]
let me just give you a couple of other
examples of what he says
um for example when we know that the
problem of rape had the rape increased
in the past decade four times faster
than any other felony and then we hear
rush limbaugh say some militant
feminists apparently harbor such
animosity toward the opposite sex they
want to criminalize the process of
courtship what was once considered an
important part of finding a mate
is being mischaracterized as rape
how about this one the native americans
were meaner to themselves than anybody
ever was mean to them these people were
savages columbus saved the indians from
themselves
or again in speaking about the
african-american community what makes
them think they can make civilization in
somalia when they can't even accomplish
that in south central l.a
i don't think there's any question that
we know what must be done we will go
after the stations that carry his
message the advertisers that pay for it
to carry
we will demand fairness and balance
we will demand that we go on the air
if necessary we'll challenge their
license renewals we'll picket the rush
rooms we're going to go after this right
winger we're going gonna stop him from
his hate mongering
and you're the ones who can do it
[Applause]
because we know about real family values
and we know that that's not what he's
promoting
when he's when we're looking at welfare
reform that would cut off
children who are born after their
mothers have already been on afdc from
any further benefits when he would force
mothers who consider raising their
children and keeping them away from
drugs and off the streets and out of
gangs and in school to be important work
and he says oh no two years and you've
got to go to work when was the last time
you heard anybody say oh my wife she
doesn't work she's a homemaker
and yet we're hearing that over and over
again about poor women and we then hear
rush limbaugh saying the poor in this
country are the biggest piglets at the
mother pig in her nipples the poor feed
off the largest of the government and
they give nothing back nothing
and we know how hard this fight is going
to be
we know that the clinton welfare plan
has many good aspects and we want to
support and we need child care we need
job training and placement we could use
some job creation
we need to have the support for our
families all of our families we we know
that child care and early childhood
development should be a right for all of
us
it is like public education
i mean
do we think that kids only begin to
learn at five when they go into
kindergarten or six when they go into
first grade we need that support for all
of our families if it's a poverty
program only it's too easy to cut off
the funding
and so we've we've got our work cut out
for us i think that one of the things
that we can also work for besides
universal child care is child support
assurances
i want us to remember that only 60
percent of the women who are divorced
and have custody of their kids even get
an award of child support and half of
them don't collect it 25 percent of
those women get less than the full
amount and 25 percent get nothing at all
and so i think that the problem that we
see
is not the breakdown of the family but
men no longer supporting their children
it's not women being lazy it's women's
poverty that needs to be combated
and it's the right wings concept of what
a family should be
let us remind ourselves that the
traditional family in this country
was a family that was dominated by the
husband the husband was the head and
master by law he could control his
wife's wages
he could beat his wife and children if
he didn't use a stick bigger than his
thumb that is the origin of the phrase
rule of thumb literally a woman who got
married disappeared for all legal
purposes the husband and wife were one
and that one was the husband and believe
me that is where the right wingers want
to take us back to
and i don't think any of us are willing
to go because we know what real family
values are we know what would be the
best safeguard for
families and that would be a feminist
commitment to equality and mutual
respect between men and women
[Applause]
as we continue to fight the right wing
in so many areas and as we continue
knowing that our strategies are on
target and we have to hold to that
strategy we want to look again at a very
important strategy and that is the
strategy of getting more women into
positions of power i don't think that
there is any question that it works we
have only to look at one example of the
sexual harassment issue for instance and
see that the seven women senators across
party and ideological lines were able to
pull out
a very unexpected 43 votes against
awarding admiral kelso who was accused
of lying to protect himself and other
officers and at the very least was
guilty of a failure of leadership to
prevent him from being awarded with
a four-star retirement that meant an
additional amount of money more than
most women make in a year
on top of his already um high salary and
we know that on the one hand those seven
women were able to pull out 43 votes
were able to give voice
to the the needs of women in this
country but we also know it takes 51 to
win
this clearly is not the year for any of
us to be armed supporters we have strong
women who are giving voice to our issues
but we need to send them reinforcements
if we're going to prevail on our issues
and i want to close with just one story
that i hope will inspire you i flew to
bozeman i flew to bozeman montana to
give a speech at the university there
and um also because i wanted to see dr
susan wicklund
uh
now you have to understand what it takes
to get to bozeman montana
you fly to minneapolis you fly to
billings at which point your plane
breaks down and you get on a bus
and the bus goes for four hours and
halfway through you stop at a gas
station and buy crackers for dinner
and then you get there and try to get
yourself up for a speech
and like all activists all of you all of
us all the folks who are watching on
c-span sometimes you wonder is it worth
it is just this one more trip is this
one more speech is this one more action
or phone call or phone bank worth it and
i'm here to tell you it is
[Applause]
[Music]
i gave my standard rap out there in in
bozeman montana and i closed with an
urgent plea
for women to run for office to consider
themselves as leaders to overcome what
we see as one of the primary obstacles
that keeps women from running for office
and that is they think you have to be
qualified
take a look at the current incumbents
set aside all humility i hereby
pronounce you all qualified
[Applause]
and as i closed my speech in bozeman and
i was saying that what i meant by that
was that we have a gracious good plenty
of lawyers in congress thank you very
much and in the state legislatures and
the city councils what we need is more
of women's experience at the table we
need the school teachers and the social
workers and the psychologists and we
need the child care workers and the and
all of the experience that women bring
from our lives to set public policy and
i guess i must have said something right
because laureen blakely who is 17 years
old and who just graduated from high
school this spring decided to run
she ran for the house of representatives
in the state of montana and she won her
primary
[Applause]
[Applause]
laureen blakely who at 17 is not even
old enough to vote for herself
won the primary against a 40-year
incumbent on a pro-choice platform
if she can do it so can you
thank you very much
a pleasure to
salute and also listen to a real hero of
mine c delores tucker
thank you so very very much kim
[Applause]
you're a shero of mine
i'm really delighted to be here today
and
let's give
our leader here another round of
applause a real champion
for the rights
of all americans particularly
the women we love you and thank you for
your leadership
[Applause]
this is a very
special time
as we approach the dawn of a new century
uh we are four how many years away
i'm losing the the time but
it's six years away
and uh
it sometimes seems we haven't come
too very very far
but women you know we have spent so many
hours and days trying to
the years really trying to wonder why we
do not have those guarantees that were
so brilliantly articulated in that
document called our constitution
i was last here to speak for the naacp
in 1985 and now here for
now
and many times we think that
our exclusion from the powers
of our world
were actually initiated by mere mortal
men
but i want to dispel that
because actually our problems started
with god himself
you know the story goes
that god created the heavens he created
the earth and then he created man
and stopped right there
he looked at the heavens he said i'm
well pleased
he looked at the earth he said i'm well
pleased and then he looked
at man
and nowhere in the good book will you
find where he said he was well pleased
i really think
[Applause]
what he did say
and when gloria steinen tells the story
she said she said
surely i can do better than this
and we're still trying to
tell the world that we can do better
than what our brothers
are doing
[Applause]
but i'm delighted
to be here with my friend pat ireland
i think i saw another former president
here is ellie smiles still here
ellie hi ellie
stand up valley another another
wonderful show of mine
but
i am proud of this organization and i've
been a member for many years
because two of its most prominent
presidents were from
the keystone state of pennsylvania
ellie smile
and molly yard who is still a fighter
steal a fighter
and she said the other day she'll fight
until she dies to make sure that every
little child
will be able to know that they could
walk into that oval office and be called
president
of the united states of america
i'm very honored to be here with you
today
always good to be around
friends who are working
for a more
just society
who are working in the cause to
eliminate hatred
violence and injustice
i congratulate
our organization
for women for its continuous dedication
to serve
as a voice for millions of women
throughout the nation women
who historically have been
disenfranchised
discriminated against and under
represented
i am even more pleased to be here
because for the first time
we as women women of all colors
have begun to work together on common
issues
i say this because whether we want to
admit it or not historically
there has been an unspoken divide
between us
from the slavery period through
abolition
the cause of white women
was different from that of black women
sojourner truth said it very well nobody
give me the best place
anywhere nobody lift me over ditches
and put me into carriages
while one focused on abolition the other
focused on survival
even doing the suffrage movement
while black women were invited into the
movement it was at a cost of separating
from their black men
the suffrage movement would allow the
vote
to women but would not allow the votes
for black men
black women then were caught between
fighting sexism and racism and being
forced to choose
only one cause
that stipulation created one of the most
critical divisions
between black and white women from which
we are still experiencing
the after effects
in 1971 at the 19
at the national
women's political caucus
in austin texas
right here in this state i challenged my
friends then
to be involved in the struggle of
african-american women whose issues
appeared different
from those of the caucus
i was one of the founders of the
national women's political caucus
but it was very difficult to get
african-american women involved and many
of our african-american men were totally
against
women's movements
i also warned that as dr king said that
we are inextricably bound together
and what happens to one of us
will affect
all of us
that warning went unheeded and we saw
its effect
at the 1984 political convention
when geraldine ferrero my good friend
and sister was offered the democratic
nomination
for vice president
at the cost of abandoning the issues
concerning african-american women
we had developed a
joint
whip system where white women and our
sisters and black women would work
together for those issues that affected
us so very dearly
and of course when geraldine ferrer
received the nomination we're very happy
about it and very proud about it but
ellie was in a meeting at midnight and
we decided then
that we would have to
abandon
the
coalition of the whip system we had to
get the issues we cared about in the
platform and so
leaving that convention
we decided that
we needed to organize so that we could
speak directly and not have to really
depend
on anyone to deal with the issues that
were very uniquely related to
african-american women and i don't need
to go into those
so a month later we called together 35
women i called them together
to ensure that our agenda was addressing
that we were at the negotiating table
in the last decade we have been able to
impact on the increasing numbers of
african-american women elected
and appointed to political positions
these achievements have been aided with
the recent partnership
between now
and i want to say that patricia island
whenever we call on her she's there
i have a
book here i want to give you uh
pat it's
a book that we published called vital
issues the journal of african-american
speeches
you were one of the co-chairs
of the 30th anniversary march for peace
and justice
and this book is dedicated to it this
issue
and it is a speech that you talked about
uh carol mosley giving on the senate
floor
but also there is a speech here on
mr nelson mandela and
many of those who participated at that
conference and so i want to
present this to you and we have
subscriptions here which i think all of
you should make yourselves available to
learn about
what are the issues that affecting
african americans started this journal
in 1991 it's the only one of its kind it
chronicles
uh the speeches and the thoughts
of african americans in these
contemporary times so i want to present
this to you
and
i want to present this to you
and tell you that
this lady
was
the
co-chair of that
wonderful march of 200 000 people
when we were fighting for an
african-american woman
on the supreme court
pet ireland was there
when we marched against gangsta rap even
in the rain
she and now was there with us
she has been an integral part
of all of the issues that we care about
and that's why i'm here today
even though it's a very difficult thing
for me to do thank you
and that's what we must do
work together
hand in hand
african-american women
and our community is not a single issue
community nor can we allow anyone
to portray us as such we address many
issues
all of which impact on our women
therefore on our people and these issues
are not merely african-american issues
they are american issues just as our
women issues
are american issues
the reason i give this short history
is to remind us of how far we have come
not only as women in the eyes of our
society but as sisters
in our common cause
that common cause must continue
if we are to ensure long lasting
progress
the reality is that after 400 years or
almost 400 years
we women in america still must demand
our inalienable rights
as citizens we still must demand our
dignity we still must demand equality we
still must demand inclusion
your theme this year
women of courage healing hatred
is both a compelling and exalting one
it is a testament to the courage that
has already been born
by women such as abigail adams susan b
anthony sojourner truth
maria stewart eleanor roosevelt
and dr murray macleod bethune
it was a courage of these women that
challenged the national mindset
of gender exclusion from the founding
documents of this nation
and the process by which government
and society
operated
we can never forget the roots
of the struggle to which we are
dedicated
in spite of its idealism america was
created based on a fundamental
contradiction
the very document of freedom that was
its historical greatness was a very
document that reflected its neglect and
second-class citizenship
status of its largest population is
women
from the unforgettable we hold these
truths to be self-evident that all men
are created equal
to the several specific omissions
or rather deliberate exclusions of women
having the right to vote
the right to own land the right to whole
office the right to be educated the
right to speak in public forms we at the
outset of this nation were not a part of
the great democracy we were not a part
or partner of the great nation of
equality it would take more than three
centuries
for such progress to be made but even
before that was to happen
alexis de tocqueville noted
the invaluable contribution of women in
colonial america
he wrote if i were asked to what
singular
prosperity and growing strength of that
people americans or mainly to be
attributed i should reply to the
superiority
of their women
the battle has been a hard one and it is
not yet over as you've heard
from our president
indeed we have come a long way
but we have a mighty mighty long way to
go
and the consequences of the neglectful
practices have taken a toll that will
take generations to heal
i say generations because what affects
the women of a society affects the
children
and that is the next generation
lest we forget the recent history
of protective or lack of protective laws
we can see clearly the pattern of
relationship
the basic attitude and legal status of
women and children in america
and many countries was that of property
to be dealt with according to the whims
and desires of the man
therefore as property they had no voice
and f8
no choice in their destiny or desires no
recourse for human injustice as our
president also cited a prime example of
the consequences of such a status is
evident in the evolution of social
attitudes toward rape
sexual harassment and domestic violence
whereas once these terms did not even
exist today they have become headlines
in the daily news
and courtrooms are packed with not only
claimants but those who are still
struggling to understand what is wrong
about degrading and denigrating women
our nation is at this moment involved in
one of the most abrupt wake-up calls
regarding protection of its women the
o.j simpson case has turned the light on
the national tragedy of domestic
violence but again this problem is not a
new one
but as with too many issues that are
relegated as women's issues it was not a
priority the question is
will policies change will they be
enforced will social attitudes be
changed how many other women will die
before domestic violence becomes
socially unacceptable and illegal
the sad fact
the sad fact
is right now in america there is more
protective care for abused animals
than there are for abused women
[Applause]
all of this must change
and it must change
but we must make a change
our social attitude and conditioning
toward violence has permeated all areas
of our lives and has blurred a line
between acceptable and unacceptable
violence for women environments for for
violence we cannot continue to allow
violence to be perpetrated on television
in entertainment
even in children's cartoons and not be
prepared for its transference into real
life situations
the violence is physical
verbal and emotional
many of you know about our personal
crusade
against gangster rap music which
promotes violence
toward women as well as degrades and
denigrates them
some of my opponents want to argue that
women choose to be in the videos
and women are making some of these
gangster rap songs
and then it's getting them jobs
my reply is so is prostitution
so is pornography
it is not getting them or any other
woman anything
except increased abuse
increased exploitation and increased
violence
let me just read you
i have some petitions here
with some of the words on here that they
won't even let you say
on television but yet they say that they
are harmless but you better not repeat
it on television so if you sho if you're
at a show
in the front row
imma call you a bee
or a dirty
[ __ ]
you probably get mad like a [ __ ] you're
supposed to so what about the [ __ ] you
got shot
[ __ ] i just want to ask you
and cut
cheat you like a trampy [ __ ]
her body's so beautiful so i'm thinking
rape
shouldn't have had her curtains open
so that's her fate
slit her throat
and watch her shake
because we're like the outlaw striding
while suckers are hiding
jump behind the bush when you see me
driving by
hanging out the window with my magnum
taking out some pluto's
acting kind of loco
i'm just another local kid
from the street getting paid for my
vocals
and we have two-year-old little girls
that are now saying when asked what they
want to be when they grow up they say i
want to be a mf gangster
and they don't say the letters they say
the words
because our young people are being told
that unless
they act like a gangster and use
pornographic and demeaning and
misogynist lyrics they can't get
contracts and so because of our
political power
that now sits in washington we could go
to
cardiff collins and the congress and we
could go to senator carol mosley brown
and say you must have hearings
and bring this to the forefront of our
nation and whether or not the industry
controls itself then legislation will
have to be
what will have to be
because the entertainment industry is
out of control
because a lot of this could never
get into the hands
of our children if it were not for the
distribution network of the big big six
included among them are sony
and um time warner
and their subsidiaries
and we're beginning to buy stock in
these companies and we need you to help
us
we need to go into these corporate board
rooms
and be partners be owners and sit and
face the chairman of the board and all
the members of the board we don't need
to sit in no more we need to buy in and
we will make a change when we do that
one of the things that we have already
done
we have challenged these artists when
they come into our cities
we are blocking the doors where these
records are sold to children where these
albums
are sold to children calling us
everything but what we truly are trying
to make life better for these young
people and teaching them
that regardless of whether they're male
or female we all have the right to
develop to our highest potential but
yesterday around the last week
we were able to stop
a concert in
philadelphia tupac shakur i think it was
this week earlier this week tupac shakur
had a concert at one of our city
uh city uh establishments
and our organization there challenge it
and said if you don't stop it you're
gonna have some crazy women out there
that will tear up the dell and it will
stop
so sometimes we have to use crazy
methods to deal with these folks that
understand normal
language
[Applause]
i am committed
to challenging the corporations
that have put profit before principle
in manufacturing this [ __ ]
and using our people to not only destroy
our community values but also themselves
i've gone to jail in washington in
philadelphia
pat ali marched with us in washington uh
we went to jail with uh on um dr king's
birthday
and the district attorney said to me
while we were standing before the judge
you ought to plead guilty i said why say
we're not going to plead guilty
and he whispered to me you could get
more publicity out of it
[Applause]
and then afterward he told me
that i'm robert kennedy son
maxwell kennedy i will march with you
the next time
and the judge thanked us and said you're
doing a service to our city we applaud
you case dismissed
so don't be afraid to go to jail or this
issue you'll be treated
very very well
why
why because the violence
that they are promoting is saying also
kill the cop
and that's why we have the judge saying
thank you
and dismissing the case
i just saw bobby's brother maxwell's
brother joe kennedy uh yesterday
and i told him that his brother told me
to go to washington and joe kennedy will
march with us so he said he's ready to
do the same
we can look at the serial murder cases
in charlotte and and see to what extent
this mindset of the devaluation of women
has gone
over a three-year period 14 young black
women were murdered
within the same city in the same area
and no one not the police
not the media not the district
attorney's office ever lifted a finger
to look into the possibility that it was
a pattern
a serial killer that these murders were
related young black women all killed and
no one took
action
this violence this degradation is
directly related to the socio-economic
status of women in general
while the united states prided itself in
economic progress what we saw in the
last 20 years was the impoverishation of
women great numbers of women at faster
rates were falling through the social
safety net and plummeting to the death
of poverty and they were not alone so
too did their children whether due to
divorce
single parenting hopelessness lack of
education discontinuation of social
assistance programs abandonment or abuse
the condition of a great number of women
was life-threatening to themselves and
their young dependents the results
according to the census is at
approximately 85 percent of children
living in households headed by women
under the age of 22 live in poverty
the percentage for african-american
women is 90
naturally 19.8 percent of related
children under 18 years old living
families below the poverty line and
42.7 percent of african-american
children are in this economic position
54.4 percent
of children in female-headed families
live below the poverty line
and for african-american women a major
crisis exists
in that 71
of all african-american households are
headed by
women
where there are no educational
opportunities no gateways for entry for
the drop-ins where there is no child
care facility where there is no medical
insurance and service where there is no
conflict
mediation families like these will
continue to fester there's no question
that we are producing cyclical poverty
and pathological violence in our
families you see these tv shows and you
see these young people they're growing
up without parents
people are saying why doesn't the
parents where are the parents well most
of them had children
as parents
and then many of them have no
mother like we know
or home like we know the street is their
home
and the gang is their family
and we have got to do something about a
welfare reform
before there can be welfare reform there
has to be job reform
there has to be job before a job for
everybody that is not a dead-end job
secondly must be training and education
reform
and the third thing they must be child
care reform
sitting in the roosevelt room at the
white house three weeks ago i said here
we are sitting in the roosevelt room
there's president roosevelt's picture
but he used the bully pulpit
of this white house
to dare
to create a wpa program to dare to
create ccc cams training our young
people providing jobs building and
beautifying this nation
and he did it even though there were
those who resisted and fought it and i
said that's what's got to come out of
the oval office today that kind of bold
audacious carriage
unfortunately that is a picture at one
end of the spectrum the history of women
gotta run however
at the other end is a drastically
different picture we have the error of
the woman
for the first time in the history of
this nation you've seen it there i don't
need to talk about what we have gained
certainly these achievements are a
testament to the struggle of the
thousands of women who have gone before
we have achieved in spite of the
obstacles however our sisters at this
end of the spectrum are not safe either
the social safety net does not protect
them
from encountering and losing to the
glass ceiling barriers and the effect of
the political and social backlash nor
does it protect them from covert sexism
that has replaced overt harassment and
discrimination nor does it protect them
from health risk of stress that now are
increasing in women to the point of
becoming life-threatening as they deal
with the balancing act
consequently on both ends of the
spectrum we are yet struggling for
safety safety in the social net that
protects our rights to equal opportunity
healthcare and education we are yet
struggling for safety and knowing that
progress is not merely temporary but a
testimony of our nation's commitment to
the american dream of of equality and in
this ongoing struggle we also have the
task know the responsibility
of bridging the social gap between the
spectrum it is no value to have women in
high achievement positions if they do
not ensure that their presence in those
positions will help uplift and secure
the rights and opportunities of all
women
as i close we must understand we need
women of courage today
who are not afraid
to raise the issues of sexism
of racism
of violence women who are not afraid to
be criticized and challenged because
that's what it's going to take women who
know the meaning of the old negro
spiritual
i've been buked and i've been scorned
but i've kept the faith and fought the
good fight
we need women of courage who are not
afraid to look at history and admit the
racial divide that kept us apart the
racial divide that magnified our
differences in color and causes but
which must now be replaced with racial
diversity in the movement we need more
women who will be the voices of the
disenfranchised protectors of the
unprotected and visionaries for those
blinded by social injustices
we need women ready and able to run for
political office you can do it the 17
year old did it you can do to be
appointed for policy making positions to
ensure that we have protective policies
and legislation to ensure our first
class citizenship we are the foundation
of this nation we are the majority of
this nation and it needs full engine
power in order to achieve
its democratic objectives and we are
more than 54 of the electorate
we are more than 54 of the brain power
and that's what this nation needs
let me just say this
[Applause]
i want to say something because i am a
member and because i am a woman of
courage
and this is something i thought about
whether i should say it but i am
let me speak as a woman of courage
to report to you that i received some
messages that i should not attend this
meeting here
today
uh because of concerns of racial
politics
i was just recently and
wilmington delaware
and we had a similar problem
wasn't race because it just doesn't
happen with race it happens in all
organizations
but i told them we are not going to let
our sisterhood be divided
too much of that has already happened
we are not going to let it happen
whatever problems we have we're going to
work together to solve them
[Applause]
we are going to
take a challenge as we begin
this conference
that there are too many serious matters
to be resolved
your organization was born 27 years ago
i was just privileged to be with the
first lady
on the plane in the presidential
delegation to the inaugural
of nelson mandela who spent 27 years in
prison
the same number of years
that you have existed
and i saw a man of courage there
heal
that land
i saw him able
to bring mr de clark
on one
side
i saw him able to tell his people we
will no longer sing
just the anc african
anthem
that we're going to learn the
africana
anthem
and you're going to
learn theirs
we are going to work together to build a
united and democratic south africa
i even saw this man of courage
invite his three jailers
to come and be at that inaugural
now if he could do
that a man
of courage
[Applause]
then we can do it too
and i'm saying this
i'm saying this to my black sisters
that we
know what we have gone through
and yet we were always taught
that we were to love our enemies
and to do good to them
that do good to us
do unto others
as we would have others do unto us
and that's why we were able to march
with dr king down into the bowels of the
of the southern
hate
that we endured
but we were able to sit down
at the table and negotiate and i would
implore you
there's no person that i know
that would sit down with you and work
out whatever problems you have than fat
island
and i know that for a fact
and i would say
to my white sisters
some of you have come from the south
some from the north east and west
but we've got to recognize that we're
all one and i know you do
but whatever there's heartache wherever
there is pain wherever there is
uh uh
disappointment or
or where there's lack of communication
let's heal whatever it is
we must
be united
and you are the
leader
of our women's organizations you're the
largest
whatever the problems are
you will resolve them
i want to close with the words
from mandela's inaugural
for those of you who have that pain
and i'd like to sit and work with you
talk with you while i'm here
because whatever the problem is it can
be resolved
we are
a sisterhood
we are sisterhood
and this is what he said
in his inaugural address
the time for the healing of the wounds
has come
the moment to bridge the chasm that
divides us has come
the time to build is upon us
we can
and we have at last achieve our
political emancipation
he said
it will not be easy we understand that
we know it well that none of us acting
alone can achieve success
but we must therefore act together
as a united people and i say we must
work together
as a united sisterhood
for national reconciliation
for nation building
for the birth of a new world
let there be justice for all let there
be peace for all that there be work
bread water and soil for us
and the sun then
shall never set
on so glorious
a human achievement
god bless you
all right
well it's clear to me after i listened
to the two previous speakers that i was
invited here to bring down the tenor of
the evening
i sometimes think it's my function in
life to um
cheer up people around the country um
with the consoling thought that no
matter how rotten things are where they
are at least they don't have to do this
[ __ ] in texas
and do that in i thought i would tell
you a story uh from our last session of
the texas legislature a very
distinguished body
uh we had reached a critical point here
in texas with the uh reform of the penal
code we have some serious problems with
this we have people in
prison doing terminal stretches for
aggravated mopery and loitering with
intent so
there was some agreement it's high time
something was done about the penal code
needed to rewrite and um
i want you to know texas has always been
in the forefront on this uh
why in
1898
uh
it was the texas legislature raised the
age of consent for women from seven to
ten
so
we're always out there on the cutting
edge and um
they hauled in a bunch of law professors
and distinguished jerseys and stuff like
that to
rewrite the old penal code and one of
the things they were doing while they
were throwing out old laws was they
threw out homosexual sodomy against the
law in this state
and um
this revised penal code went first to
the texas senate which had a rare moment
of courage and gutted it up and uh the
guys voted right and passed it out took
homosexual side of me right out of the
law
uh
don't clap yet
because the next that poor old bill went
over the house and uh one of the members
we have in the house is state
representative warren chisholm from
pampa he's a bible thumping dwarf
first thing old warren did when he saw
the revised penal code was he leaped to
his feet and he moved to reinstate
homosexual sodomy in the penal code
all the guys in the house was afraid
everybody thinks they was queer if they
didn't vote for it so they did
and then some scholar explained to
warren that unless he voted to reinstate
heterosexual asylum because they took
that out too
uh a holiday was going to be declared
unconstitutional
whereupon an interesting debate ensued
and some of our more avant-garde members
got up at the back mike and they said
well uh warren
suppose i'm in bed with my lovely wedded
spouse and i like kind of slip and wind
up in the wrong hole you want to send me
prison for that too
[Laughter]
and warren at the front mike said yes i
do it's against nature in the bible
so in the end all the all the guys in
the house was afraid i would think
that's perverts if they didn't vote for
it so they did
reinstated both of them and um
after this big double victory old uh
warren chisholm was up there at the
front mike and his big christian ally
tommy chaplin was having a big uh
congratulations and slapping each other
on the back and half avenue and such and
uh the press box called over the
sergeant arms and said sergeant you have
to go over and reprimand both those men
because under the provisions of the
amendments just passed by representative
chisholm it is now illegal for a prick
to touch an [ __ ] in this state
[Applause]
put that on c-span um
actually i'm here to talk to y'all about
something serious um
and that's having fun
uh i want to talk to y'all real
seriously about this because um as you
all know from reading american history
this is not one long broad smooth path
of progress ever onward and upward
toward liberty and justice for all in
this country god damn it sucker he's got
potholes in it and twists and turns
a lot of times in fact freedom does lose
and it does get rolled back
and
uh
always are the good guys who win and
that's why i'm a great believer in uh
having fun
and uh the man who first taught me about
that was a great old texan named johnny
falk
and i'll just tell you one story about
what it was like to go freedom fighting
with mr falk
um
we have in austin texas had several
years ago a fundamentalist divine the
reverend mark weaver by name
now weaver is hell-bent on driving sin
out of austin texas
think he has his life's work cut out for
him
he heads up an organization called
citizens against pornography
and i was marching around outside the
dirty bookstores and movie theaters of
our town were signed saying honk if you
hate pornography
well i always honk because they do hate
pornography and besides i think they add
a certain genocide quoi to our municipal
life
say that in
texas and um
one day i get this frank telephone call
from the director of the central texas
chapter of the american civil liberties
union which is not a real powerful
organization
being a state of high excitement she
informed me i had to report that very
evening to the meeting of the austin
city planned commission on account of
they was about to destroy the first
amendment
i said damn
the first amendment is under fairly
steady fire here in the great state but
i had not previously counted the city
plan commission among the forces of jack
booted fascism and
came as an unwelcome surprise to me well
after she explained the deal which is
that
uh reverend weaver and his group had
come up with proposed news on an
ordinance under the provisions which
could not have a dirty bookstore a movie
theater within so many feet of a home or
school or church
upshot would be to drive all dirty
bookstores and movie theaters out of
boston texas to the general cultural
deprivation of the citizenry
well matter of fact i do hate
pornography but i did not think it was a
real good idea to have reverend weaver
deciding what books we could read and
what movies we could see
so i reported for duty that breathed
into the city planned commission and
found there are 500 citizens against
pornography and four of us from the
civil liberties union
about normal odds here in texas
and uh
am here to tell you there is nothing
like sitting in the midst of a sea of
citizens against pornography
to make you notice that your friends
look like perverts
um reverend weaver was first up to talk
about his amendment a verifying preacher
of a certain old-fashioned cat and he
began by saying that that very day that
very day
he had received a telephone call from a
lady who lives behind the dirty movie
theater on south congress avenue
well i perked right up is my
neighborhood dirty movie theater
and as a matter of fact driving up the
uh meeting that night i noticed had a
new feature attraction called the nuns
bad habit
sorry i missed that one um
yes said weaver that lady alerted it was
right behind that dirty movie theater
and she reported to him that after the
five o'clock show on the previous day a
man had come out of that movie theater
gone in the alley behind the movie
theater which is also directed behind
that lady's house and that man there
masturbated
500 people went
which made an odd sound and uh
yes said redwood weaver that meant
masturbating that lady has two little
girls two little girls might have seen
that man do that terrible thing except
praise jesus she has a large wooden
fence around her backyard
well with that we all praised jesus and
um
he was off and running cussing sent up
one side down the other by the time he
got through it looked bad for the first
amendment
and what to do well we huddled and
decided to send up johnny farke our
oldest living member john henry shuffled
up to the microphone doing his
well-known impersonation of an in-feeble
senior citizen
johnny was always very quarterly he
began by saying members of the planned
commission
reverend weaver citizens against ladies
and gentlemen my name is john henry
faulk i am 75 years old
i was born and raised in south austin
texas not a quarter of a mile from where
the dirty movie theater stands today on
south congress avenue
i think you should all know
that there was
a great deal of masturbation in south
austin before there was ever a dirty
movie created
[Applause]
[Applause]
now not many people know this but john
henry faulk at one time had a career in
law enforcement in fact he was in the
texas rangers
actually he was a captain in the texas
rangers he was seven at the time and his
um
his friend boots cooper who was six was
the sheriff
and the two of them used to a whole lot
of serious law enforcement out behind
the folk family place in south austin
and one day misspoke johnny's mama
having two such fine law enforcement
officers right there on the property
said boys i want you to go down the hen
house and i want you to get that chicken
snake out of the hen house
so they were all excited get up down
there on their brooms tethered their
brooms went in looked through all the
hinge nests on the bottom row
could not find a chicken snake and they
were of an agent of a size where they
had to stand on tip toe to see onto the
second shelf to see if the snake was
there
and it was
and i myself have never been
nose-to-nose with a chicken steak but i
always took johnny's word for it that it
will just scare the living [ __ ] out of
you
and it scared both those boys so bad
that they both try to get out of
handhouse at the same time doing
considerable damage to themselves and
the hen house don't worry in the process
best fault watching this report's kind
of amused and
they came trailing back all shaved faces
and she said boys boys what is wrong
with you you know perfectly well a
chicken snake
cannot hurt you will not hurt you
as from boots cooper made this semi
immortal observation he said yes ma'am
but there are some things that'll scare
you so bad you'll hurt yourself
and i think that's what we do in this
country i think that's what we do again
and again in this country we get so
scared of some terrible minutes so
scared of communism or
illegal aliens or crime or pornography
some dread thing that we hurt ourselves
and i would suggest to you all that
right now the scariest people in this
country are christian fundamentalists
and i think not without cause i think
anybody who looks at the wilder shores
of american culture as delores has
uh probably and and feel no alarm
probably don't have a lick of common
sense
uh
but what happens
uh there's a fellow named william martin
who's a professor down at rice
university
uh he's a sociologist of religion and he
explains this as well as anybody i know
i know he says as a society becomes more
modern and secular those who cling to
conservative fundamental beliefs cling
ever more fiercely
so that what has been a gap between the
two groups becomes a chasm
and that's what we're watching happen
now
um
and i think part of the sense of
alienation and fear felt by christian
fundamentalists
and i should explain to you all that i
do not regard christian fundamentalists
as other
i happen to have been born and raised
right in the middle of a oh master foot
washing baptist
i got saved three times myself before i
was 12.
did not take in the long run but
don't think it did me any great harm
his people are not some alien other
uh
uh
these are my neighbors and my friends
and my kin folk
uh and one of the things that puzzles me
is that and i issue this is a challenge
to anyone here who can name me a single
movie book play television program of
recent vintage of which
the protagonist is a sympathetically
portrayed fundamentalist
the only one i know of is a lovely
little novel called rainey by clyde
edgerton now the carolina
and i think that those of us who pride
ourselves on our compassion and our
empathy
perhaps have more of an obligation to
reach out and try to understand the
fears of our fellow citizens
than those who make no such pretense
now having said all that let me also say
that i think there is no reason on earth
to let these blue bellied nincompoops
mess with the first amendment
uh many times when you are talking
christian fundamentalists you will hear
them say no we're in the constitution
are the words separation churches state
written and that is entirely true they
are not
um
but the purpose of the establishment
clause of the first amendment
is clear i think to the meanest
intelligence and if it is not one
need merely quote
one of its authors jamie madison
who in 1803
wrote in that
beautiful
18th century english which we can no
longer replicate
the purpose of separation of church and
state is to keep forever from these
shores to cease this strife that has
soaked the soil of europe in blood for
centuries
and still does
you pick up any newspaper and read about
the soil of bosnia soaked in blood part
of it apparently from muslim virgins
being raped as a matter of policy by
their christian neighbors
don't say it can't happen here sarajevo
was one of the most civilized
cosmopolitan cities in europe
beirut before it was pulled apart by
religious strife was one of the most
civilized cosmopolitan
comfortably multi-religious
cities in the middle east
to keep forever from these shores
this ceaseless strife that has soaked
the soil of europe and blood for
centuries
and i think that that is a principle
worth making oneself unpopular over
which of course is what we always do
every christmas there we are like the
goddamn grinch that sold christmas
stole christmas they're suing somebody
over an excess of christmas spirit i
always say to these guys god couldn't
you wait until after new
year's just such bad sense of public
relations i just hate it but no they
always bring soup
uh one time some food put up a crush in
our state capitol and i was calling
around to get reaction from elected
officials ann richards was then state
treasurer i said annie what do you think
she said damn i hate to see him take
that crush out of the capitol it could
be the only chance we'll ever have to
get three wise men in that building
[Applause]
i just want to suggest to you all that
um having fun while fighting for freedom
uh is a real important part of the whole
deal and all it takes is a little
imagination i happen to know for a fact
that patricia ireland once uh
won a very significant political point
by threatening to appear in a bikini
dna for the era
all right
um
one of the perennial problems that
freedom fighters face is what to do when
the goddamn ku klux klan comes to town i
think it probably only happens in the
south anymore but there you are
um
the clan was coming to austin
uh year before last they're all upset
because the state of texas now
recognizes the birthday of dr martin
luther king
as a state holiday
and um
you know it's always so goddamn piercy
you know
clan comes to town the black
black citizens get upset the jewish
citizens get upset
the skinheads turn out to cheer them on
fist fights break out i mean everybody's
pissed off at everybody for a good six
months about the whole deal and of
course there you are standing up for the
right of these full-blooded fools to
march
uh
so uh after some cogitation several
great minds decided on the proper course
there are not enough cluckers around
austin to get up a decent demonstration
so they bust them in from waco inviter
and um got off the bus wearing those
cute hoods and sheets and um
proceeded to march up congress avenue
about 40 of them they were greeted by 5
000 citizens of austin who mooned to
them as they marched
[Applause]
it made a real nice effect kind of like
a wave in a baseball stadium
and uh we had gone to our local district
attorney before planning this
demonstration and he said it was clear
to him it was constitutionally protected
political speech and he had any
objection
um
years just uh a year ago uh joe rowell
whose great freedom patent lawyer died
uh i remember a few years before that
the aclu was fixing to lay some heavy
hitter lifetime freedom fighter awards
on some folk and joe rowell was one of
them and he was sick in hospital at the
time
and so he asked a friend of you to go to
philadelphia to pick up this award for
him his friend went to see him in
hospital said joe what do you want me to
tell these folks when i pick up the
award for you
well he said you can see old rally in
there as sick as a dog
and ralph's biggest fight was back
during the mccarthy era which was one of
those times when
people were so frightened
that um
they behaved with great cowardice and it
was it was an ugly time
and a
time of defeat
for the great ideals of this country
people's lives were ruined people's
careers were destroyed
and rao was one of the few who stood up
and fought and he was also there in the
early days of the civil rights movement
when
the going was not all that much fun
and uh
lying there thinking back over it all
and finally looked at his friend and
said tell them how much fun it was
tell them how much fun it was
now i don't know about you all but when
i get down toward the end of my road i
want to be able to look at our daughters
and our granddaughters
and talk to them about the feminist
movement
and i want to be able to tell them how
much fun it was
and i hope you all do too thank you
the annual conference of the national
organization for women held in san
antonio texas began friday and ended
sunday
this year's theme is women of courage
healing hatred
now was founded in 1966 and claims a
membership of about a quarter of a
million and 60 nationwide chapters
today on c-span
american profile interviews with two
journals
[Music]
molly ivins in austin texas the front
page of the washington post today as a
headline young bush hunts up like-minded
texans in a lackluster race
are there any like like-minded texans
down there on the george w bush's side
oh this race is tighter than a tick
there's no question about it um they are
just neck and neck and
what can i tell you texas politics the
big issue was the opening day of dove
season when um you know texas political
tradition calls upon the candidate who
is seeking public office to go out and
slaughter the symbol of peace that's
mandatory here
and
both candidates uh george w shrub bush
and ann richards went out to kill doves
and georgia accidentally killed a kilty
which is a protected species and had to
pay a big fine to the fish and game
people
pretty embarrassing
um anne's comment was
guns don't kill kill thee people kill
kilty
and you know for issues that's almost
been it
mr buchanan you have any of you uh from
this vantage point on that race in texas
no i guess uh i would defer to molly as
to how close it is i've heard the same
thing there's no doubt that
that the governor ann richards is
extraordinarily popular or has been and
she's a very authentic texan
and it's and i don't know that george
bush unlike his brother jeb incidentally
down there in florida who is running a
very very conservative race
i don't know exactly how george bush is
working his cutting issues
there is a
baltimore sun piece and this is in most
papers it's uh quoting tony cuello
saying um we're going to end up doing
uh very well the the election is now
turning uh do you have that same sense
molly ivins the texas race anywhere
oh well across the country
i'm like everybody else who's been out
and looked at it i'm mostly impressed by
how sour people are and
i must say even for somebody who's
covered texas politics for a long time
the weirdness of this political year is
just amazing to me
i was in california last week and
they're setting new intergalactic
records for weirdness
it's just astonishing why why is this
going on
well
i think
i've been i was writing about how mad
and angry everybody's been i've been
doing that since the 92 race
i'm trying to convince folks that voters
are genuinely upset that the level of
cynicism and discussed with politics is
just horrendously high
and now that everybody's jumped on that
same june bug
i'm sort of running around trying to be
cheerful about things
that's my natural contrary and impulse i
guess i listen to people sit around
ringing their hands about how terrible
and awful everything is and government
can't do anything right and everybody in
washington it's a crook and on and on
and on
and i'm kind of going well you know
one reason to be cheerful is because
things could always get worse in fact
they have a tendency to do so so what
happens if now turns out to be the good
old days and your kids said you hey dad
what'd you do in the good old days and
you're sitting there having to say well
you know i just call rush limbaugh and
gritch about how terrible everything was
you'll feel like a fool you might as
well be cheerful
i think there is a firming up for the
democrats brian
there's a number of reasons one the
democrats have left congress gone home
reacquainted themselves with the voters
and started to answer some of the attack
ads secondly cuello's own strategy which
is
go negative
i think is beginning to work in some
areas i think democrats have given up on
issues
and really the spirit of houston rules
the land if you will everybody's running
as a conservative sasser in tennessee is
running against illegal aliens and in
favor of school prayer
uh third reason is bill clinton on haiti
and iraq is perceived to have done well
and i think firmed up his support and
risen a bit and since he was issue
number one in the campaign
i think that has a tendency to help some
democrats i mean take kennedy in
massachusetts my guess is
he's better off this week than he was a
week ago i think that's true of
feinstein in california
so i think cuello's got a point i also
think the contract on america
with america excuse me newt gingrich
i think that was the despite the fact
that i liked the particulars i think uh
as a political gambit it was a failure
because it gave the democrats a target
to shoot at all the democrats had gone
for him was defense of bill clinton and
the republicans were on the attack it
was a referendum on clinton and now
you've introduced a new element and
republicans are having to explain and
defend something which is not their
strongest issue molly ivan's in the new
yorker this week
newt gingrich will newt gingrich's
contract with america save bill clinton
and that's on the cover flap and it's a
piece by
michael kelly and inside mr kelly states
the following the compact itself is a
silly
obvious gimmick
it binds the republicans who signed it
to nothing they are promising only to
consider such steps as passing a
balanced budget amendment not to
actually vote one way or the other
um
well i do think that whole contract with
america raises the always timely
question
how dumb do they think we are
um
i mean here we go again they're going to
a balance the budget b cut taxes and see
increased spending on the military
the extent to which our political
seasons go through these cycles without
anybody addressing
what's really going on is just amazing
to me
you know at the root of all this
sourness and cynicism and disgust with
politics is the fact that the middle
class has been getting shafted for years
now the real income of the middle class
is going down and all these companies
going through downsizing and
right-sizing and all these charming
little euphemisms they have for it now
people look around it and they they
really are frightened they're confused
we're at a time of transition both
geopolitically from 50 years of cold war
into whatever wild blue yonder we're
about to take off into and obviously the
time of transition in the economy
and
here are people really upset and
frightened and some of that is being
deliberately milked by
a particularly ugly kind of demagogic
politics
and nobody is sitting around talking
about
that
just that people say well it's all
because of illegal mexican immigrants
i'm just sitting here going do what
well i think molly's touched on
something here there's no doubt there's
an increase in poverty in last year
and uh and poverty has not gone down
despite these two giant tax increases
we've had in the last three years
also and i think one of the factors
explaining the kind of stress and anger
and rage and hostility to the political
class
is the fact that the median income of
the american worker has gone down
something like 20 percent in 20 years
and went down one percent again last
year and then i read in the uh usa today
where goldman sachs made 58 new partners
young fellows in their 30s mostly and
each of them got a bonus last year that
averaged 5 million dollars so there's a
financial class in this country that's
doing extraordinarily well in the free
trade environment and i think there's a
middle class that feels more and more
stretched and we've got a lower class or
an underclass
in poverty lower class economically
which is is isn't getting any better off
at all and i think this makes for social
instability i disagree with molly to
this extent i think a flood of of both
legal and illegal immigration running to
one to two million people a year is
clearly a depressant on the labor market
and it's on that labor market which
works with its hands and with tools and
machines and these are the people that
are falling behind well those of us who
brian who are talk show hosts you might
say are doing very very well
that's true but
the fact is
that that border our border with mexico
has always been porous because we wanted
it that way it actually works very well
that whole porous border system when our
economy is booming and we want cheap
labor
that border gets more open and people
come over
and
you know employers can hire them at real
low wages and exploit the hell out of
them and everybody gets maids and cooks
and gardeners and dishwashers and we're
all happy campers then the economy goes
into a fit of contraction
and
of course you try and shut it down but
to say you know keep in mind no illegal
mexican immigrant ever ran an snl that's
not the real problem but they are 20 of
the
prisoners in california's prisons and i
think they are something like that as a
percentage of federal prisons molly you
go to california
illegal immigration much longer border
and we have many more mexicans here in
texas than they do in california i know
but they're getting what they have in
california is a lot of politicians
demagoguing the issue but you say
demagoguing it but the point is i think
what politicians are doing is finally
responding to the people it was not
politicians who put together proposition
187 to cut off all social welfare
benefits except emergency health to
illegal immigrants that was the people
and they were responding to gross
inaction by presidents bush and
president clinton in closing the border
and by sacramento in doing anything
about it now pete wilson and dianne
feinstein to a lesser degree are riding
this issue pete wilson is going to ride
it to a minor landslide i mean
a year ago or six months ago pete wilson
was in intensive care you know and they
were calling the rectory and this fella
is going to make a comeback i think on
this issue alone molly when you got 2
million people coming across your border
every year it is not illegitimate to
debate it
no it is not illegitimate to debate it
but i do think that
the whole idea of blaming your problems
on
mexican immigrants is just ridiculous
look california's economy went to the
toilet that's not the fault of the
illegal mexican immigrants
that you know it's because the economy
is in the toilet that the issue is once
more come up and once more we say okay
let's get tough and shut down on illegal
immigration that's fine but to think
you're going to solve your problems by
blaming blaming them on on
but you know
california's economy went in the toilet
for a variety of reasons one of them was
the
cut back in defense spending and a lot
of jobs were lost another was
california's huge
tax increases and spending increases
which are driving businesses and
individuals out of the state but molly
other folks are leaving the state
because they don't want to live there
anymore they don't think the quality of
life is what they want and especially
out of southern california and the fact
that you had a the worst race riot or
the worst ride in american history in
1992 the la riot and that according to
the u s attorney general one third of
those arrested early in that riot were
illegal immigrants illegal aliens who
had come across our border to help burn
down our largest city
that is the fact that's got to be taken
into consideration why people taxpayers
and others are getting out you know
psychiatrists are always talking about
the phenomenon of displaced anger
how there's there's some cause of
friction something that makes us very
angry and instead of blaming the cause
we find it easier to shift it and blame
something else
we're trying to we're trying to tack it
on to clinton but it's hard to keep
focused molly
we get distracted by contracts with
america i've never seen anything silly
first of all illegal immigrants are not
eligible for welfare in california or
anywhere else well i understand it from
republicans out there
because in the state a fraction of one
percent of the total health budget the
only point where cost really does come
in and that's both texas and california
is in educating the school children and
what could be crazier than saying oh
here's a good idea let's let a whole
class of people grow up illiterate in
our midst the idea is
first if it's uh if they're not getting
any social welfare
then ain't going to hurt him any if it's
cut off but secondly with regard to the
school kids molly the purpose of that is
to be able to identify who is here
illegally who broke the law who walked
into the united states ahead of legal
immigrants who have been waiting in line
and who is taking up and using benefits
paid for by hard-pressed taxpayers of
california so we can send those folks
back where they came from and tell them
to get back in line just just think this
through pat all right the way that thing
is written
um as you know most children of illegal
immigrants are actually legally born u.s
citizens they're going off to public
school the way this law works is you
have the school is then forces them to
track down and find out that mama is
here illegally so good what do we do we
take her out of her job as a dishwasher
where she's paying taxes
and we put her in jail so that all the
kids wind up on welfare and they have to
pay 23k a year to put her in prison they
don't put her
kids to school it just makes no sense we
don't put illegal immigrants or illegal
aliens in jail you take them down to the
border and put them on a bus and send
them back to the community where they
came from and leave their kids here on
no no i mean presumably these are good
parents who send them to school they
will take them home and put them in
school in mexico or
the answer to the problem of illegal
immigration from mexico is anybody who's
ever looked at it for more than 10
minutes knows is long-term economic
development of northern mexico and what
you're saying is you're going to lose
your country because you got mexico even
in places like the hermeseo ford plant
where they make six dollars
about six dollars an hour compared to
forty dollars in wayne michigan the wage
structure in mexico is about one-eighth
that of the united states and if you're
going to wait for equilibrium you can
kiss the southwest
it's not the comparison between a border
town and some
some place in in
michigan that's been lucky enough to
have good auto unions fighting for them
for years it's the comparison with just
the other side of the texas border where
i assure you wages are not that high oh
yeah and there's there is i think um
well well y'all go ahead all right now i
just want to ask you a question that's a
little bit off the subject the front
page of the new york times by the way
molly island you used to work for the
new york times yeah i did do you
miss living well you were out in denver
i guess were you ever in new york for
the time yes
why did you ever decide to head back
down to texas was it abe rosenthal molly
famously i
suffered from congenital irreverence and
um that would be a problem there that
didn't go down well
all right let me go back to the times
front page today the lead story is
cole's slate slips as german's vote
keeps small edge i don't want to ask you
about this election as much as to ask
you both
79.1 percent of the germans voted
yesterday
this off year election we might get 36
percent of the electoral voting what's
wrong
it's well there's a go ahead molly okay
um some in fact i would say much of the
cynicism and discussed about politics in
this country is merited and there's this
whole litany of reasons that everybody
who studies it goes through people are
turned off by negative campaigning
people's are tired of politicians who
make promises and don't follow through
on and on and on
and of course people think that their
vote doesn't make a difference but
i want to point out that there is an
important reason to vote that not many
people know about is in the constitution
if you don't vote you can't [ __ ]
that's in section 22.
i think
one of the reasons it's historically low
i think our highest election in recent
time it might have been the last
election because perot was in but was
nixon versus kennedy i think one reason
is brian is voters perceive it doesn't
really make a difference which of them
gets in now in one sense it's not a bad
thing because in europe of course
in in the past votes can mean whether or
not you got hitler or someone else in
the united states it's democrat versus
republican and a lot of people feel it's
not all that important it's not going to
affect their lives that greatly so why
bother
i don't think that's altogether a bad
thing
but
i think the the cynicism out there and
the distrust of politicians and the
the war really that's going on against
the political class as part of it i want
to read you a quote from the washington
times this morning this is tom andrews a
democrat running for the senate
in maine he says while i won't be able
to change washington washington will
never change me
i can talk to that there's no doubt
about that because andrews is going down
the tubes brian i mean he is really
behind
uh and olympia snow's going to win that
race but it makes a point that
washington kevin phillips has a new book
out called arrogant capital which is uh
which focuses on the tremendous
hostility to a city where in 1950 50
when i was growing up brian there were
about 1 000 lawyers registered with the
dc bar and they're now something like 60
thousand i think there's some 90 000
lobbyists if you include the fellows
working for embassies uh washington has
become a hated town and a hated city
because it's very far away from
americans not only geographically but
economically and socially and
politically molly is you're in austin
right now
yeah do the texans say
you can go ahead and just say i just
wanted the texans outside of austin say
the same thing about austin
sure
and and and oh work
austin is considered the berkeley of
texas the people's republic of travis
county it's actually known to have
liberals
um because the university is here most
vanishing breed molly we where
i think not um
let me let me say though that it seems
to me once again we are getting into
what's wrong with this whole political
year let's sit around and talk about how
terrible washington is let's batch
washington let's bash the congress let's
bash clinton let's everybody get mad at
somebody and blame everything on
somebody let's talk about how to fix it
i mean i'm if i
it seems to me that if you get a
politician who's talking seriously it's
got some ideas about how to fix things
that's the person you need to listen to
not somebody who runs around saying i'm
more mad at washington than you are can
i read another quote to you sure uh this
is in the same piece this is bob carey
running for senate
i don't mean to say that government is
bad but boy
it's not if it's not watched carefully
it can shut you down in a hurry it may
be the thing you have to watch the most
in washington you know the significance
of that quote by bob carey is that he's
a good centrist democrat
and if his point is
that washington can and government the
federal government can be a threat to
your job and a threat to your business
and a potential interference with your
life
brian that is the heart of the
democratic philosophy is based on that
government can do wonderful and good
things
and it is that philosophy that's being
repudiated even by democrats now when i
mentioned sasser
uh running against illegal immigration
and running uh you know for the for the
right to school prayer if democrats have
given up their basic beliefs and are
running sort of as quasi-conservatives
whether it's phony or not what it says
is that the liberal philosophy is being
repudiated and abandoned by its own
people if that's the case in the long
run
you are going to have a populist
conservative revolution in this country
okay but there's there's a again this
unreal extent why is the debate
government is good or government is bad
reagan used to run around saying
government is not the solution
government is the problem it's neither
one government is a tool it's like a
hammer you can use a hammer to build
with or you can use a hammer to destroy
with there is nothing intrinsically good
or evil about a hammer it's the purposes
to which you put it and the purpose is
to which you put it were laid out pretty
clearly by the founders in order to form
a more perfect union establish justice
ensure domestic tranquility provide for
the common defense promote the general
welfare and secure the blessings of
liberty to ourselves and our posterity
that's why we have government i grant
you it's very easy to argue over the
details but the fact is government is
not some evil foreign thing right this
is a self-governing country people this
is our deal this is our deal but molly
women know you've got to look at the con
the the democrats considered great by
members of their own party fdr
greatly expanded government power and
authority and programs and was
considered considered a smashing success
as did lyndon johnson in the great
society bill clinton came in and sought
to increase government authority and
power presumably to do good things take
over health care reduce costs provide
benefits to everyone that program was
very popular a year ago and it was
utterly repudiated and people are
running away from it now if that idea
that we can pull
government can harness all these forces
and all this power and all this money
and do wonderful things if that idea is
being repudiated even by liberals and
even by democrats in a tight race it
says that the philosophy of the
democratic party upon which it rode to
power for years and years and years is
being rejected by its own people it's
like the excuse me it's like the soviets
losing faith in communism it's all over
when that happens that's so silly that's
once again we're involved in one of
these phony debates where your opponent
defines what you think well we never get
anywhere when we do that bill clinton
never ran for president united states
saying i want to make government bigger
and have it run your life more than it
does already bill clinton came in and
said look we are moving into a global
economy and i've got some we're going to
have to get ready and fix and change a
whole lot of things and here's some
ideas about how to do it he was a guy
talking about how to fix things
and you know he started by he didn't fix
the deficit but he sort of got it headed
in the right direction then he tries his
next big one which is health care reform
this gets piled up in a tangle of
partisan politics and special interest
lobbying that is the most unbelievable
mountain of spaghetti i have ever seen
but molly let me concede that point that
it was piled up and there was
partisanship and the lobbyists got a
hold of it nobody is out running on
national health care nobody is out
running right now on if you will the
social liberalism they're not saying we
did a great thing for human rights we
brought homosexuals into the military
openly or joycelyn elders was a
tremendous choice or look what we did at
the cairo conference social liberalism
and big government activism are being
repudiated by default by the democrats
who are supposed to believe in them now
if all those ideas are going out the
window and we're going to talk about how
to deal with crime and building up
national defense and school prayer
amendments and dealing with illegal
immigration on the southern borders we
are talking the conservative agenda and
i think the democratic party has
repudiated its own philosophy i don't
care whether it saves a cup i mean teddy
kennedy will come back to congress if he
wins having fought as being tough on
crime
look pat this is again you defining what
the democrats think you defining what
social liberalism is you don't get to do
that
we get to do that
you can define you have philosophy
um again
it's not the idea
one of the ways that health care was
defeated was this constant crying yes
but do you want the government to take
over health care right
who you know automatically government is
bad government is bad but look it just
depends on how well it does but what
molly wanted to do why did the argument
when if conservatives and republicans
raise the argument do you really want
government to run your health care if
that is a killer for health care what
does it say about the chances and
opportunities of the party of government
the party of government is the
democratic party the party of the
private sector is the republican party
that if you say okay my response to a
proposal on how to fix the health care
system is government is bad i'm telling
you you haven't addressed the question
the question is how to fix the health
care system
that's what keeps happening to political
debate in this country we keep not
focusing on what the problem is and how
to fix it no molly it's it's the
difference is
who decides what the problem is that
needs to be fixed and it is now the
conservatives and the republicans who
are defining the problems who have begun
to at least they didn't do it at 92
they're beginning to now and the
democrats and liberals who are
addressing their issues well again as
far as i'm concerned what the
republicans and the conservatives are
doing is misdefining what the problem is
right again we get caught in all this
nonsense where we think that okay
there's politics is a like a spectrum of
ideas from right to left
and i don't think it is i think what
politics is really about is
a scale
from top to bottom and the only real
questions are who's getting screwed and
who's doing the screwing and those are
the questions that politicians no matter
what their political philosophies are
keep trying to avoid answering in this
morning's uh roll call
which is the county real newspaper john
pitney of the claremont mckenna uh
college out in california has a piece
about something we've been doing here
the lincoln douglas debates and he says
he complained of petty malicious attacks
from critics
uh who substituted slander for a
positive agenda he concluded that uh he
had been exposed perhaps to more
assaults
and abuse than any man living of my age
or that ever did live bill clinton in
1994 know stephen douglas in 1858 and
the uh the main critic was not rush
limbaugh but abraham lincoln and we have
the paper here from alton illinois from
our final debate day on uh saturday no
no debating it was a great day i just
asked both of you before we i love stuff
like that before we go to phones uh how
much of what's going on today uh is new
to to this country i mean the the
debates that we're hearing and
that's that really is a tough question
to answer of course it's wonderfully
delicious to bring up examples like the
lincoln douglas debate
and of course politics has never been a
genteel and refined affair
our great sam houston was a great one
for cuss and his opponents utah negative
campaign and he was a champ
but i think and maybe i'm wrong maybe
it's a partisan thing it seems to me
that there is a level of pettiness and
nastiness
um that is genuinely offensive and is
part of what is making people so sour
and negative about government
i think that the
the negativism is pervasive in all the
media and the difference today is that
there are so many institutions of media
and so many ways it can get into your
home and
not only newspapers television talk
radio and the rest of it and the fact
that
negative ads are successful and the
effect of negative ads brian is to tear
down your opponent
and also to bring yourself down and the
hope is you bring him down more
and i think the the the strength and
power and negativism of the media since
around 19 for the last 30 years is the
reason why all of america's institutions
congress the media itself the churches
have fallen and declined in public
approval and esteem and support some of
them are getting close to single digits
congress and journalists for example
and i don't know where it's all headed
but i do know the whole country is uh is
turned off on its entire establishment
today yeah
wow um you know i love those single
theories of what's wrong it's the media
as a television if it doesn't play both
television and ronald reagan where do we
learn a lot of good theory tell me where
we learn
about the congress of the united states
if not through c-span
uh the national press ap
networks yeah talk shows through the
media we don't all go up there and watch
them specifically is the rise of gotcha
journalism
if you look at almost every question
bill clinton got asked in this last
press conference every one of them was
an effort to get him and prove that you
know there was something you could show
that there was wrong or hypocrisy or
something i'm kind of going well i don't
know whatever happened just getting
information here about
here's the facts from lydia and
i believe
josh sands
we stopped watching c-span during the
week because it became nothing more than
republican propaganda we still watch
sunday journal until today as a family
we had sunday journal on as we get ready
for church today when you decided to
give jerry falwell a forum to spread his
lies which had been proven totally false
that was the last straw how sad that
your network has decided to join the
hate mongers that are destroying this
country if you are wondering why people
stop watching and hate each other here's
your clue goodbye and may god forgive
you
then there's this one from jay eric of
waco texas i've always felt that i can
turn to c-span for unbiased coverage of
political events lately my opinion has
been changing a perfect example was this
morning's edition of sunday journal i
did not feel this morning's program was
an objective look at the issues rather i
felt it was a pep rally for president
clinton your panel of experts was
anything but objective the white house
communications director an nbc reporter
who covers the white house and via phone
the editor of the new york times
magazine are not examples of people who
would critically question anything the
president does time for the phones molly
ivins is in austin texas she's
originally from houston she works for
the fort worth star telegram writes a
column can be read nationally and pat
buchanan the native of washington dc is
here in our studios with us and you can
see him on crossfire almost every
evening indianapolis go ahead please oh
thank you very much uh thank you c-span
uh for book notes and for the lincoln
debates and for the fairness that you
have
and then molly i love you my whole
family loves you i hope my papa's
watching right now he's in portland
oregon and he loves you
i have a question about middle class um
i think i get confused about when it's
being used and think it's
seems to be a euphemism for upper class
most of the time and just want your
thoughts on it thank you very much
i know that that is one of the odd
things you find people um
making a hundred thousand dollars a year
who somehow think they're middle
class still sitting there laughing
um brian maybe can help me with this
isn't median income now 23 or 27
thousand dollars a year i think it's
closer to 31 31 yeah i think low 30s
yeah median is much more significant
than average that's that figure that
means you know half of us are below that
um
and
that's the one that i find most useful
when i'm trying to deal with how people
are doing and what they can afford in
terms of of a decent life in this
country
um and i when i hear people you know
seventy thousand dollars a year still
seems to me an enormous amount of money
i do have to tell you a great moment
though pat i was watching mr brinkley's
sunday chat show one one sunday and
all the reporters mr will and ms roberts
and mr uh donald just above the median
income uh solemnly agreed that one of
the reasons bill clinton was so
unpopular was because he had increased
taxes we
increased taxes on the wealthiest one
percent of americans but on 100 percent
of the people sitting there discussing
him on mr brinkley's program next call
victoria texas go ahead please hello
brian first time caller from victoria
texas
brian no one can ever accuse you of not
having liberal journal journalists on
your program again
about the most liberal journalists texas
has to offer
you don't like molly items i mean you
sound like you have an edge to you there
what what
are there any conservative journalists
down there in texas oh yes
a lot of journalists and uh pat buchanan
is one of our
our favorites
i
want to make another point uh
molly ivins doesn't speak for the legal
texans about the illegal
texans
uh also like make another point if you
let me
uh
molly ivan's viciously attacked
donald wildman and the american family
association in a newspaper article in
our local paper a few months back
and the
subscribers complained and wrote to the
editor and called in enough to get her
removed as one of the editorial writers
in that paper all right thanks molly
evans what do you think of that well i
think that's an example of the profound
understanding of the first amendment
represented by reverend wildman and his
crusade if you don't like what people
are saying make them shut up that'll fix
them
let me talk a little bit because donald
wildman's a good friend of mine and i
think he
he exercises his first amendment rights
not only that i think his movement
to clean up media of pornography and
filth and do it through the same type of
consumer boycotts that
blacks use during the civil rights
revolution is not only perfectly
legitimate but commendable and i think
he's a very brave fellow and he gets
nothing but abuse from the eastern press
and i think he's far more representative
donald wildman of middle america than a
lot of his critics are uh i think though
pat what you see when you look at what
mr wildman objects to is not filth and
pornography and some kind of disgusting
degrading portrayal of sex it's actually
ideas um to to attack programs like
murphy brown or like the pbs programs
which are probably among the most
intelligent on the air the pbs stuff he
attacked
is not giving us any is not giving us
any help against pornography but let me
ask you molly would you not commend
donald wildman i think he and his folks
called i think all these southland
shopping whatever it was dixie
store some 17 000 of them
and as a consequence of their calls they
removed all the penthouse magazines
which even feminists claim i think are
deeply pornographic and see me that's a
commendable act it's done by a citizen
action
and the whole purpose is simply to clean
up the corner drugstore so it looks like
it used to look like when you and i were
growing up in the 50s molly uh well i'm
again i'm very suspicious of the idea
that there was ever a good old days
i recall these will become the good old
days just your way
but yes i think that's what should
ultimately be done about pornography
that you have social pressure that makes
it socially unacceptable you don't try
to pass laws against it
and um
you know
i don't think wildman understands the
first amendment i really don't and i
think that's sad and dangerous but
fine i'm you know you can't outlaw
pornography i like what it is
but molly the supreme court already says
that it's not uh that pornography is not
in obscenity or not protected by the
first amendment against you can you can
have this this sort of thing the endless
question is you know what is obscenity
what is pornography then mr wildman
insisted that an extremely intelligent
program be taken off pbs and they
finally caved into the pressure both
molly ivins and pat buchanan got a
master's degree from columbia university
in new york city school of journalism
molly ivins got her undergraduate degree
at smith college in northampton
massachusetts i believe that's isn't
north hampton all right
and pat buchanan went to georgetown
let's go to springfield utah next go
ahead please
hello springfield utah you're on the air
hello hi
hi yes i have a question isn't the
immigration problem being inflamed to
provide one of the pretext for a
national identification card and all it
entails
well i think i don't think see much too
much support on on either side of this
issue for the national identity card i
think there is support for barbara
jordan's idea
of a computer-based
system whereby those who
mean can qualify to work such as you
have in social security are in the
computer and you a simple phone call can
identify them in the united states and i
think she recommended that and from what
i saw it got tremendous support but
that's only one of a number of steps i
think i think they're coming
incidentally when when
when governor wilson's re-elected in a
minor landslide i think this whole issue
of illegal immigration illegal aliens
goes to the top of the national agenda
and you'll see the politicians running
you bet when the issue is being inflamed
so politicians can win races and ignore
the real problems you know let me tell
you something when jimmy carter got all
excited about this one time uh back in
the 70s he announced that this problem
was so serious he was going to put up a
17-foot
fence stand on the texas mexican border
with barbed wire on top of it well i was
a judge that year at the turling with
chili cook-off which is a major cultural
event here in texas
and we had in addition to the usual
usual chili cook-off the first ever over
under or through mexican fence climbing
contest erected a very fine cyclone
fence 17 feet tall with barbed wire on
top and first guy over under through won
a case of lone star beer
17 seconds was the winning time
brentwood
tennessee you're next
go ahead go ahead good morning you've
really done it
just to show you how messed up the
american public is i love both of your
guests
no this is thrilling to have you both on
there i um
i'm a middle of the road i'm i'm not a
republican i'm not a democrat i'm not a
conservative i'm not a liberal i have
pieces of all of them
and i'm very cynical and i want someone
to tell the american people
what they can do to help government fix
this
i i am tired of watching our country go
down the tubes i've studied the gas wto
issue and i know that
one side is lying to us
and
it's the other side man parts the other
side
it's not your side
but
i just someone needs to tell us how to
get rid of the citizen cynicism i work
with united we stand america
and and you may be cynical about them
but i'm a very sincere deeply motivated
person and i want to fix this but i
can't get people to understand issues i
can't get them to roll up their sleeves
and get get busy tell us something well
let me uh talk on
the gat issue in the wto is very very
complex
and it has been very very hard to get
the country and even the congress
focused on the whole question of
america's sovereignty and its surrender
to these secret panels in geneva
authority that the founding fathers gave
to the congress right in the
constitution it's a very difficult issue
and uh it's one of the problems behind
the complexity of it and trying to get
the media to focus on it and get the
message out to the country so we get the
kind of national debate we did get on
nafta
and uh ma'am i you know i don't know
what to say other than we will keep
trying on that
and it's very hard to get out and i go a
lot of places and they say what is this
wto
that you're so excited about let me jump
molly i'm just going to get to you we've
got a fax here from trish and falls
church understand she's already gotten
through on the call so she's got a two
for this morning a fax and a call she
says senator ernest hollings is having a
hearing today on gat which we're
covering and the world trade
organization which congress will vote on
at the end of november uh previous
hearing
could you say a few words about the
world trade organization will jeopardize
u.s national sovereignty do you have an
opinion on this molly evans
um no oddly enough buchanan and i wound
up on the same side of the nafta debate
on gat i'm
i don't know enough about it no that
man's false church wasn't there church
you're on the line now go ahead hi there
how are you hi good morning hi trisha
good hi pat hi molly hi brian um well
pat you've already sort of gotten into
this issue a little bit and
i guess uh
malia if you're concerned about the
middle class in this country
i would think that you would really take
a look at the world trade organization
and get
and see how it's going to undermine
representative government in this
country
and we're going to lose jobs and the
standard of living is going to go down
this country
so i just wish you all would discuss
that a little bit more let me ask molly
a question if i could molly
one of the reasons uh that i was
bothered by nafta is that suddenly
through american workers let's say they
average in textile mills eight or ten
dollars an hour in pay and benefits
into head-to-head competition with folks
who make a buck an hour if you take gat
and sweep out all the tariffs and all
the barriers it puts americans making 10
bucks an hour into competition with
chinese
who get 25 cents an hour or vietnamese
who get 25 cents an hour it frees
american corporations to simply pick up
their factories and technology move them
over there
use that quasi-slave labor
produce their products and bring them
back into the united states and sell
them here and that's going to benefit
the corporation no doubt about it but
what's it going to do for the americans
who work with their hands and 2000
machines okay that's that's why um
i sided with you with you and others i
mean you must admit it was the world's
oddest collection of people who were on
the other side of the nasta thing
but i don't think that okay let's assume
that um every all the big corporations
are telling us world trade is a good
deal i am of course immediately
suspicious
but i don't think that because we're
coming becoming part of a world economy
that means that we are automatically in
competition with starving bangladeshis
who will work for two cents a day that's
not the way the deal works in fact if
you look at the countries who are doing
better than we are economically
in germany
japan they are actually
germany pays it has a higher average
wage than we do uh japan is very close
to earth moving up rapidly there are a
lot of countries that actually pay their
workers more now the people have really
thought about this um have said okay
it's not it doesn't necessarily mean
that we're in competition with
you know starving people everywhere who
willing to work for low wages i will
tell you somebody who believes that
there should be attention and a balance
between labor and capital
that labor's been getting the short end
for an awful long time now what i think
is more specific in this country is that
we go through a period where a certain
class of folks get shafted by things
like nafta and possibly gap although i'm
not well enough informed on that
um
and they're basically
the guys we call bubba in texas and
it's my opinion that they've been
getting chafted for so long the reason i
was against nafta was it just weighed
unfairly on a certain class of people
who have been getting the short end
already for far too long
it may all work out happily and will
dance into a golden future further on
down the pike but there's some real pain
involved for specific groups of folks
right now and i think that's what needs
to be addressed concord california
you're next
good morning i wanted to question the
assertion that the economy is doing just
fine
pat mentioned earlier that
the typical american household saw its
income decline in 1993
and more than a million americans fell
into poverty according to the census
bureau
but what's also apparently true is that
we've got a falling labor force falling
productivity falling savings capital
flight soaring imports speculative
inventory hoarding to beat inflation on
top of that we've got long-term interest
rates rising from under five and a half
percent a year ago september to close to
eight percent now and what that means is
that when people say the economy is
doing just fine we don't believe it
well i think you're exactly right and
you've cited a number of uh of
statistics which point to real trouble
down the low road and also this idea of
this median income constantly falling
now i think there's no doubt some people
are doing well the market i think at
last count was up close to 3 900 which
is near its peak and people who invest
there probably in the last 10 years have
done extraordinarily well but if you
take these folks
let's take one example and it refers to
what molly said i just saw in the paper
where mexico post nafta
honda has built its next plant there gm
chrysler ford are expanding so is nissan
and by the end of the century mexico is
going to be building two to three
million cars a year now there's no doubt
that americans who make six times or
eight times as much auto workers as
mexican auto workers are not going to be
able to compete with that low wage and
with the lack of regulation down there
so i think more and more auto production
is going to be moved out of this country
and gat is going to increase the problem
it seems to me undeniable by the way the
current but the good news is it will cut
down on your illegal immigrants the
cover of time magazine says
boom for what question mark america's
economy is back on top but americans are
still in the slump very quickly molly
ivins this fax uh mike fleming of
college station texas geraldine ferraro
arrives in austin today to campaign for
ann richards carol mosley braun will be
in austin wednesday can bill and hillary
be uh clinton b no they don't say
clinton bill and hillary be far behind
why doesn't ms richard attach herself to
the president by the way molly how about
them horns
[Laughter]
um those aggies they are just such a
barrel of fun
um
as far as i know um
ms richards is
has very cordial relationships with bill
and hillary clinton let me
washington north carolina go ahead
please
brian i want to thank you very much for
c-span and i've got a question for pat
after i give you the answer for all the
problems
uh i'm recently retired
veteran of world war ii
um
i think the best pro best answer that we
could have would be to have a joint
session of congress
and uh everybody that could possibly get
their attendant and drop a small clean
atomic bomb right in the middle of the
whole works
you ought to read tom clancy's it's
embarrassing
just the last couple of pages
[Laughter]
may i filibuster for a moment brian
there was a lady earlier who had asked
what can we do about the cynicism what
can we do about the country
um
in fact i think it's people like that
who are the answer and i'm i like those
united we stand folks who have kept
studying issues on their own
um and i really do think i'm
this is amazing to me look
when people talk about government as
though it's the enemy it really is us
this is our deal
the dream of a self-governing nation is
200 years old and it still resonates
around the world with such impact
that people die for it at tiananmen
square in south africa in myanmar and in
this country out of boredom synonymism
cynicism and inhibition people are just
ready to say oh well let's flush that
all down the toilet that i don't think
we're really ready to let go we just
don't understand that there it is our
deal it we can do something about it
it's not them in washington it's not
some
you know
something that we have no impact on it
it is our country by the way to the
caller i raised my eyebrows last friday
when the caller called up and said that
nora ephron had written an article in
reason magazine
thanks to our facts here from ellen
holmes of connecticut to straighten it
all out it's edith ephron
which
anybody that follows you remember we
bought a lot of her books one time a
long time ago if you recall brian
chuck coulson's purchase plan as i
recall montgomery alabama go ahead
please you're on the air
good morning
mommy you make a lot of sense keep it up
thank you
maybe i'm mistaken but it seems to me
that following world war ii we had what
i would call a false prosperity because
the rest of the world was devastated and
we were the only ones who could
manufacture and serve them when they got
to the point that they could compete
with us
it does affect our economy and rightly
so
right so
when you say pat that it's going to ship
all the jobs overseas
american business has been shot with
shipping jobs overseas since world war
ii you know my friend let me let me stop
you right there you're exactly right
after world war ii because europe and
japan were devastated
the united states not only sent them
foreign aid to rebuild their steel mills
and factories we opened our markets
and while theirs remained by and large
closed or in many cases closed and let
them dump their products in the united
states to export american capital and
get it over into these countries
it was a very magnanimous and generous
thing to do but it should have stopped
around 1960 and we should have said now
that you're on your own feet as
eisenhower had said you got to take
responsibility for your own defense and
there are no more special deals for you
you're all big boys now we brought you
up to be teenagers now you're on your
own and if we had done that and started
looking out for the united states of
america instead of continuing this
policy and expanding it to the entire
world you wouldn't have seen the rotting
out of the core of america let me make
one point my mother grew up in a town
called shawroy pennsylvania it's on the
monongahela river
and it's up in western pennsylvania and
i used to visit it as a boy
you go up through there now and those
are ghost towns all the way through that
area
and it's a direct consequence of the
fact after we won world war ii we opened
our markets and the steel and coal and
all the rest of it came in
the steel primarily and shut down those
plants and factories because they dated
to the 1890s and the new german mills
dated to 1945 and 46.
the mag the magnanimity and the
generosity has got to stop and we got to
start looking out for our own people and
that's what these statistics that are
being discussed in that magazine i think
are telling us let's grab a call uh
seattle washington next go ahead please
ah yes lou i'd like to address um to
both the lady and the gentleman um
for one thing it's wonderful to see the
two pitbulls of the left and the right
being so civil with each other
congratulations guys
um i would like to volunteer perhaps an
explanation for the general
quote-unquote malaise that's out there
and perhaps if you guys could comment on
it
um tamale uh the policies of your party
for the last 35 or 40 years through
regulation through taxation etc have
essentially caused a capital flight out
of the country uh you squeeze the
balloon the balloon pops out the other
end sooner or later we will all go
bankrupt and the model to look forward
to there would be something along the
lines of a cuba
on the other hand pat
an awful lot of us out here i'm a small
businessman feel that the republican
party over the years more and more and
more
seems to be also abandoning the country
essentially attending to the interests
of the very largest corporations but
those of us who are in the middle class
out here
are saying hey wait a minute what about
us exactly
between the two of you
most thinking americans are looking out
and saying neither party
molly islands
um i'm i'm sorry i'm not here to defend
the democratic party that's not what i
do
uh let me show you both uh facts this is
from the yellow dog journal
uh from cleo rosebud zoots not sure
that's his real name he's from rainbow
california i'm not sure that's his real
town
anyway
anyway so the reverend newt thinks
democrats are quote the enemies of
normal americans
he wants to avenge tax increase on 1.2
percent of taxpayers issue subpoenas
january the 22nd 1995 to investigate the
administration
when will the rev and his onward
christian soldiers of the monolithic
god's own party gop i'm sure you got
that molly evans i can't see this start
dragging us from our homes caning us in
the public square loading us on trucks
to take us to the re-education camps
echoes of the 92
neo-fascist texas convention that's mr
buchanan fears manipulated issues turned
into symbols people and ideas demonized
remember hitler was elected too tell him
i
love it tell my friend down there
that the democrats running this year are
running in the spirit of houston they're
all for school prayer none of them is
talking about gays in the military
they're all against big government and
all the rest of it i think newt did make
a uh i i wasn't in town i was out there
in oklahoma in california
when uh the reports of his meeting with
all these lobbyists and others came
through i think that's clearly a mistake
i think some republicans have been
anticipating their victories and
celebrating a little too soon
but my friend uh it's not going to be
all that bad but it is coming you're
right i haven't commented
i think one of the problems we have uh
god is in real big trouble y'all uh i
was out in california last week and he
has been dragged into the senate race
out there
and you know that if god starts hanging
around with politicians sooner or later
they're just going to ruin his
reputation
uh and i'm i'm just distressed about it
well i'll tell you it wasn't god that's
the problem some fellow named john roger
and i'm not sure exactly who that uh who
that is but he's the one they've dragged
into that race in california which is
which
virginia alone accepted is one of the
most brutal and roughest in america
michael kinsella of california has a fax
here mr buchanan how can you republicans
hold democrats to one standard and
republicans to a different one you treat
hillary clinton with contempt yet ariana
huffington with kid gloves
listen they are dragging ariana on the
way to salem right now
are you kidding have you read vanity
fair molly
i am enjoying watching vanity fair
criticize ariana huffington for being a
social climber outside now it startles
them terribly at that magazine
flesh their hearts in politics full of
wonder and joy greenwood south carolina
next go ahead please
greenwood you're on the air
yes sir hi
i have a question from mr buchanan yes
sir
we have state laws
that says that an employer
can fire anyone
for no reason at all
now
a couple of months
before i was fired from my job
i was injured right i have i have a
serious backdrop
i couldn't i couldn't straighten up my
back
and
they began to harass me
i tried to get them to send me to
another doctor
and they refused
well
after i was terminated
they decided they'd send me to one
well they sent me to their doctor
and their doctor
he took a couple of x-rays and said
there's nothing wrong with
i go to another doctor
and he finds out
that i have a real serious injury
what i want to know what can you do
when the company doctors lie
and say there's nothing wrong with you
thanks well i
i don't know
under the americans with disabilities
acts i don't think
uh in other other federal laws and i'm
sure state laws i don't think if you're
injured on the job i think there's a
certain measure of responsibility
companies got for you
i just don't know your situation my
friend but it doesn't sound like you
have a very nice employer or had a very
nice employer located on route 1 up on
the coast brunswick maine you're next
uh hello
i have a i guess a rather unoriginal yet
uh cynical comment about cynicism
oscar wilde did say that
ascenic is a man who knows the price of
everything and the value of nothing
and it seems to me that a lot of times
right now we're getting
we're getting
bogged down in details of
uh of of questions especially with with
uh health care uh i think i think that
there are a lot of details but i think
we could do some very simple major
uh reforms
that that would change the situation for
most americans and i and i don't and and
i right right now i guess if i had to
say the most important thing for me is a
mandate right now every employer
responsible
employer should offer health insurance
and at least some subsidy not maybe not
100 percent but some subsidy for it all
right molly evans um i really like what
that fellow has to say and there again
you're talking about somebody who's
talking about fixing things and
understands that cynicism
is not only of no use but it actually is
corrosive there's a real difference that
journalists keep forgetting between
cynicism and skepticism
and it seems to me that too many
journalists fall
fail to make that distinction could you
would you i mean what is what does the
word cynicism mean
one who i think is is um
just says that everything's rotten and
people are bad and there's
i'm sitting around sneering and
everything it's a total negativity do
you have any of that in your blood at
all i've been moving at politics
and politicians i mean i do that all the
time but
in fact
i'm i'm genuinely troubled by the
by the by the nastiness of the tenor of
debate i mean i make fun of texas
politicians but i think it is clear to
the
meanest intelligence that i have
enormous affection for them let me talk
to that fellow's point about health care
if i could briefly sure you know i we i
got off the plane in dallas on saturday
and was driven up into southern oklahoma
where we went and
appeared for for jim inhofe and just
before we got to the oklahoma line i
went into this little ref get some
coffee and cokes it's about two hour
trip and the fellow was seen he was an
arab american
and he recognized me
and so he starts asking me questions i
didn't know where he stood so he says
what do you what do you think about
health care
and i said well i'll tell you i didn't
like the plan the bill and hillary plan
he said you know i employ 30 people here
i can't afford health care if that had
passed i'm out of business
now that's one of the the realities down
there
and that this fellow i think that called
doesn't recognize is somebody got to pay
for that and these fellows got little
businesses and and and they're going to
go under and there's just big fellows up
there with all these ideas here in dc
and they don't recognize what's going on
yeah but the fellows who call it
specifically recognized the need for
subsidies of some kind and that was part
of the package that was part of the
whole debate i mean why would you even
say okay
a small businessman can't afford to buy
health insurance for 30 employees when
that's not what he's going to have to do
under the plan here's the cover of
newsweek magazine a continuance of the
discussion we start here on friday from
the new republic it's the charles murray
book that's got everybody talking at
least in the media iq a hard look at a
controversial new book and race class
and success paris california you're next
yeah um
molly i'd like uh well first of all i'd
like to make three quick points number
one molly i wish you could
come over here to california
and maybe move into one of these
neighborhoods that has been taken down
the tubes over the last 10 15 years with
this illegal immigration if you could
live amongst our neighborhoods that have
been just totally destroyed by it maybe
you would change your mind well i spend
a lot of time in south texas
well
um i've i've lived in california all my
life and i never thought i'd see the day
that i would want to leave this state
but i am strongly thinking about doing
so that's number one
number two
we have a gat
uh and world trade organization that's
getting ready to totally
wipe out the united states
number our founding fathers
set up trade
with tariffs on the incoming products to
protect
our businesses here and also that money
that was raised from the tariffs was
used to run our government when you take
down the tariffs you then have to tax
the people of america to make up for
that amount of money that they no longer
get from the tariffs
and with the lowering of the tariffs our
taxes are going to have to go up because
government cannot maintain itself and
continue to grow as it has over the many
years
when they're taking down the tariffs you
know the illuminati better known today
as the council on foreign relations has
had this plan for many many years and i
have watched it incrementally tear down
the united states and it's continuing to
do so and their plan
is to take us
take the wealth out of this nation and
distribute it elsewhere thanks yeah i
would just say as a general rule that
among the things that i think all of us
should be very very skeptical about are
conspiracy theories
as somebody who's read a lot of history
and i know there are others who've read
more it seems to me that history is
very seldom influenced by conspiracy
more frequently influenced by stupidity
well but this lady has an excellent
grasp of real history and uh all the way
from the civil war and the mural tariff
up through the mckinley tariff even up
through coolidge 4d mccumber
especially in the 19th century this the
entire government of the united states
was virtually run
on revenues from tariffs
are traditionally what you need when you
have a developing economy which is not a
description of the united states no the
point the point molly is there is no
nation in history which has ever become
a great and mighty industrial and
manufacturing power
that did it with free trade everyone did
it with protectionism the most recent
example being post-war japan and the
lady is right that republicans were the
majority party in this country up until
the depression
because they protected the income of the
average american and made sure it rose
every single year that was the key and
tariffs were a vital element of that
policy that made them the majority party
again i don't pretend to be competent to
argue macroeconomics but as i understand
it
the
it is um
it is you can stay the people who study
economics say that every time you expand
free trade
the economy expands and you you get more
but jobs let me tell you historically
historically the british practice free
trade in the second half of the 19th
century germany and the united states
practice protectionism we closed our
market of say 70 million germany closed
its market of 60 million and all three
of us competed for britain's market of
43 million britain began that period
number one far and away as a
manufacturing power it ended it behind
germany and about one half of what the
united states had molly is a quick facts
from america online let me ask you this
what is the female equivalent of the
term bubba just curious charles
finstermarker los alamos new mexico babe
miami florida you're next go ahead
please yeah good morning
saturday's miami herald had an
interesting article
immigration costs florida over 3 billion
dollars per year most of it here in the
miami area
226 000 floridians were displaced from
jobs by cubans and haitians because
mostly of affirmative action where they
get preferential treatment
education supplemental social security
government services medicaid and
criminal justice is where the money goes
the u.s doesn't pay we pay the locals
pay 60 minutes did an excellent uh
program on that last night about warsaw
wisconsin i hope you all saw it
no but i read the article on which it
was based i'm sure yeah chain migration
is the cause of most of this is
60 minutes pointed out just one last
point
uh here in florida we're losing our
language we're losing the english
language we're losing our culture and
our country by stupid government policy
and pat you've been ahead of the curve
on this we're finally catching up with
you in this country and keep on going
thanks a lot well thank you my friend
the main problem is i think government
paralysis
because government in washington dc and
the politicians are here are terrified
of the washington post calling them
xenophobes or or bigots or racist all
this terminology they dump on anyone
that wants to do something about illegal
immigration take proposition 187 in
california this year friend
take it back to florida two years from
now and then in california in 1996 this
whole idea of reverse discrimination is
going to be put on the ballot in
something called the california civil
rights initiative which would outlaw
quotas racial set-asides and all this
odious paraphernalia of reverse
discrimination in all state institutions
and the people will vote on it the only
way to change things is the people going
to have to take back power themselves
because you can't rely on this crowd up
here miley ivins cometh
um
you know it's
bashing immigrants and blaming
immigrants for our problems been going
on for 200 years in this country why
don't you all understand that that's not
the point but molly why we have always
benefited from immigration and we still
do we can have a debate people come here
to work they they do work that most
americans won't take for low pay it's a
good deal for us then when our economy
gets bad we all we blame them for our
problems it's nonsense we're not talking
about legal immigration the united
states still takes half of all the
world's legal immigrants we're talking
about people breaking the law
walking into the united states a few of
them committing a disproportionate share
of crimes taking a lot of social welfare
that hard-pressed taxpayers
can can commit as many crimes as anybody
i myself would not blame that problem
tulsa oklahoma
yes hello hi my first time in and uh
great show thanks on the
two comments on the gentleman to call
about his bad back get a lawyer
there are a lot of them up here
mr clinton's foreign policy is what i'm
really interested in this business in
haiti we all know was a as far as i'm
concerned a flop
for power
and in kuwaiti
if i'm not mistaken when
the bush administration left
everything was set in place
mr clinton's secretary could have called
and said let's invoke rule number two
and everything would fall into place now
tell me if i'm not correct that uh
he didn't have any worry over in kuwait
well i'm totally puzzled by the second
part of the question i don't know what
he means by mr bush left things in place
or put in rule two i'm i'm lost there on
the haiti thing
i you know what can you do but say folks
good news it's amazing to me how many
people in the media have trouble
reporting good news and just accepting
that in a situation where there not only
were no good choices there were nothing
but horrible choices the only question
the only choice you had there was to
figure out which was the least horrible
have we have amazingly enough managed to
get aristide back home unharmed in power
with very little loss of life i mean
will somebody please give the man some
thanks well i haven't quite joined the
celebration for padre aristide's return
but we could have done something else
molly ivan that is great believer not
doing anything well exactly you should
have left those people alone instead of
strangling that little island north
island nation for three years choking
them to death people dominated
malnutritions babies suffering all
because the united states was ticked off
about a coup which is a common
occurrence south of our border we should
have left those people alone and the
problems are going to begin i i you know
i'm a normally i'm i'm a great believer
in in not doing anything my favorite
political option is let's wait and see
what develops but in in the case of
haiti doing nothing was not an option
either it was yet another horrible altar
well well now we got father aristide in
there i'll tell you when there's going
to be a whole lot of shaking going on
down there when the crowds that have
been celebrating and suddenly decide
it's time to get some tires and gasoline
and start up the hill and burn up the
tonto makuta
well look what are the american troops
going to do when they go after the
middle class in the upper class what's
going on down there is an angry bitter
social revolution with bloodshed on both
sides and the americans are right in the
middle earlier we had a call from route
1 on the east coast now the other side
of the country big sur there on the
pacific coast highway go ahead please
good morning brian good morning
molly how are you all doing how are you
how are you watching us in the big sur
uh
very leisurely okay
see it's about ten minutes after five in
the morning that's ten ten ten minutes
after six okay
are you right on the coast yes looking
out over the ocean we're trying to paint
a picture here for us
well
if you've ever been to big sur you know
what i'm talking about it's hard to
describe to somebody that hadn't ever
been here it's uh
to me it's probably the most beautiful
place i've ever been
and
you have to get up early in the morning
to get on c-span so
[Laughter]
how does the world of cynicism look to
you at big sur
well not quite as bad it hasn't changed
in years and uh
but i wanted to get my uh
two cents in
uh being here at the center of
of peace and serenity
uh
for one thing molly on immigration
um
i'm from texas originally in south texas
isn't southern california
uh
california is a is a paradise and uh
you know south texas is nice but it's
not
nobody ever called a paradise
well looking at it from where i'm i'm at
now it is um
now
one thing that you never hear about the
immigration debate is that
i'm doing a study of
just my own personal um
aggrandizement i guess where we're going
to be in 20 years demographically
and
you all know as well as i do that
when the baby boomers are starting to
retire social security is
more likely to go bankrupt than ever and
what i see is the government actually
wants young immigrants to come across
the border because who's going to
support
us when we start to retire since we're
not having kids we're going to need the
young immigrants not that i'm totally in
favor of immigration but
i think we need to focus more in the
media
on real issues i mean you've heard this
this drum beat for for months
uh and less on you know o.j simpson
i'd like pat to discuss uh
callahan's book called setting limits
he's the head of the hastings institute
where
essentially we're going to have to have
health care reform eventually because
again of the demographics
and
my interpretation of what callahan's
saying is that
they're going to deny health care to
people because of either disease or age
in 20 years and as perot says we need to
start thinking 20 years in the future
not 10 years 10 minutes in the future
well you got a very broad agenda there
on the health thing i do think you're
seeing i think there's a proposal up in
oregon to
allow
voluntary suicide
or allow people who are terminally ill
with six months to live
to take lethal drugs and i think it's on
the ballot and and doing well and
there's no doubt
that this uh and i'm firmly opposed to
that sort of thing and uh but there's no
doubt that this is where the debate is
headed molly evans oh well i thought he
had had a number of um
interesting ideas and i'm i just wanted
to say that until you get health care
reform in place that's why clinton is
really stuck now he can't do welfare
reform you can't get people off welfare
until you've taken care of the
healthcare problem and the one sort of
claim to fame that clinton has which is
that he's got the deficit headed in the
right direction that too is going to
reverse if we don't do anything about
health care because the costs keep going
up well but you know no matter what
happens in this direction yeah and if
you're really interested in fixing
things that has to be the next logical
thing
no matter whose numbers you use the tony
cuello says three in the senate and 20
some in the house possibly uh and if you
take the other end of it will this
president ever get a health care reform
bill it really is less likely but i will
tell you um from having watched clinton
in arkansas
um the guy is like one of those little
broad bottom children's toys you dump
him over and he pops back up you chump
him over and he pops back up again
i think he's going to pop back up with a
capital gains tax cut brian a
middle-class tax cut if he wants to
survive at 96 my guess is he will move
to the center if the country moves to
the right dixon tennessee
oh yes good morning all right okay uh i
have a a comment about illegal
immigration and i have two questions for
mr mccann sure okay first on uh
immigration is that i understand that uh
italians from europe coming in through
through new york are the number one
illegal aliens coming into this country
and my two questions for mr buchanan is
is it true that when you were younger
that you uh you stole a car
and then on on the drive i mean on
military
service molly's smiling right now by the
way stole a car okay wait did you did
you dodge the draft no and and if you
did how did you avoid military service
well let's see let's deal with the
italian immigrants first
they have not they are not the major
problem in america the major problem is
coming across the southwest border and
it's coming into
california the primary problem but is
also in texas on the draft no when i was
17 years old i was in army rotc at
georgetown spent three and a half years
there until they severed me from it it
was their call steal a car
uh the statute's brought on most of that
stuff
no i haven't stolen any cars
virginia go ahead please hi good morning
to uh speak to what you were talking
about
go ahead um as far as government and
business in the island the ideology of
the two parties
because i i sense a little bit of
hypocrisy
or at least a double standard in terms
of the republican right-wing
conservative movement on the one hand uh
the government does some things well
like the build-up of military etcetera
and then on the other hand
uh they're vilified as being too big and
destroying in our lives
and then business on the one hand and
private industry is our savior then on
the other hand when it comes to the
passing of gap mr buchanan fierce things
like those very same businesses that are
going to save us running off to other
countries let me see if i can answer
your questions first
i don't i'm not hostile to the idea of
government but i do think if we get back
to constitutionalism where government is
responsible for things that we can't do
for example defending the united states
protecting america's borders even i
would think if you got a social security
system it's got to be run at the federal
level there are other things education
where the federal government can get out
completely because people can do that
better as for big business once you get
these multinational corporations
jefferson said really merchants have no
country the very ground they stand on
does not constitute so strong in
attachment as that from which they draw
their gains ibm places like that i think
there are allegiances to the bottom line
ms ivins
i agree
that was easy uh sacramento california
go ahead please
uh yes i have a comment about um
our governor pete wilson and mr buchanan
seems to think that he's going to win in
a minor landslide well maybe if anybody
had been paying attention they would
have found out that a few years ago pete
wilson as a senator was really
encouraging
you know the rules to be lifted on
illegal immigration because they were
helping in the
in the farms and in the
you know san joaquin valley because he
knew it was helping the economy if we
stop all these people and do what he's
doing now which is rather hypocritical
people are going to be surprised at how
much their grocery bill rises and a
whole lot of other things and then
they're not going to know where it came
from
let me tell you man if
i mean you want questions you want to
save your country and see me that's
what's at stake here and i think pete
wilson was in favor of certain like the
bracero program which you have guest
workers and a lot of americans are for
that if they come in temporarily to do a
job others aren't doing and go home i
think americans will be interested in
that it's just when they come here to
stay illegally
pat
i mean he starts by saying well the
question is do you want to save your
country look again you're talking about
a very very old phenomenon a porous
border where it's fine with us in good
times we bring these people in we do
exploit them
rather cruelly and many and horribly in
many instances and then when times are
bad we want to shut them out we all
stand up and have this big who how about
let's crack down on illegal immigration
as long as everybody understands that
this is part of an ebb and flow that
works to our advantage it works and
always has
but again you want to cut you want the
ebb
definitely when the economy is down as
it is in california now i understand
that what you don't do if you're an
intelligent citizen of this country is
let some politician exploit this as
though it were the the answer to all the
prayers as though it were anything other
than the part of the economic cycle two
more calls and some faxes huntington
tennessee go ahead please uh good
morning brian
molly
uh
my comment is
is to your guests both your guests
uh i don't understand how our federal
government thinks
and let me explain this
i'm a victim's father
the crime bill sucks
the crime bill to meet an
insult
how does how does anyone in in
washington think that the american
public is going to believe big
government can fix our problems or do
anything when they're going to spend 31
billion dollars throw money at the
problem and that's all they're doing
they're nothing
why don't they ask some of the victims
or victims family what we want i want
big government out of my life i live in
tennessee i want tennessee's
laws to prosecute convict and if
necessary execute these people
committing these crimes when you commit
a violent crime you should pay for it
right my friend
50 years ago my guess is tennessee knew
exactly how to take care of its criminal
class
as we did all down through history
there's no problem in societies knowing
how to deal with criminals our problem
is i think we've got
the whole process has been encumbered
and enlarged and made complicated by
court decisions and civil liberties
lawyers and all the rest of it to the
point where it becomes takes 16 years
from the time an individual murders
someone or rapes and kills some little
girl and he pays the maximum price molly
evans
um
but i i think what the fellow from
tennessee misunderstands is
it's not the federal government coming
into tennessee's business here the
federal government addresses federal
crimes those are crimes that cross state
borders
ocala florida last call
good morning brian hi
a call for pat
on immigration
everybody in this country is immigrant
right and we have filed up the
native americans from day one right when
are we going to start taking care of
them instead of abusing them every day
oh come on cut it out my friend the
united states government in terms of
payments to
native americans it has been
extraordinary and i think probably
foolish in many ways because the huge
social welfare state you've created on
some of these reservations i think has
been as socially destructive there as
it's been in the inner cities
let's uh go over some faxes here let's
see here uh
this is from
evelyn 10. brinkley at the end of his
show yesterday said he wished he had
asked dr frist he's running against jim
sasser in tennessee if he had ever
transplanted republican heart into a
democrat and if so
was it rejected no did the democrat
change his party affiliation after the
transplant best laugh i've had in a real
long time
where would dr frist have found a
republican heart
[Laughter]
final paragraph you're an exception pat
i thought you reacted like a human being
when you were running against george
bush molly i love you
that's from evelyn
the guy who's running on the slogan was
it was it the death penalty for career
criminals and term limits for career
politicians
uh facts just tuned in so someone may
have already made this comment do you
know what i like about these two you
can't take either one of them seriously
listen you gotta laugh a lot of people
feel that way i'm afraid
will you please ask pat buchanan to
assess ali nars respect for the law this
is from america online
ali north is an old friend of mine i
work with him in the white house and i
recall the occasion when he went up
there and he came back and said that
led us to believe he had misled that
group and i think what ollie was faced
with was the moral dilemma whether
molly ivan's whatever happened to the
term sleaze factor we heard that term a
lot in the previous administration but
it does not seem to be operative at the
current time why not charles thomas west
pittston pennsylvania
oh it seems to me there's sufficient
focus on sleeves i never saw such a to
do as there has been over this alleged
whitewater scandal which i think is
utterly non-existent
i will find out about that i saw that we
got a good republican prosecutor go
ahead this is uh saw the first half of
the show good guess but why blow off the
question of voter turnout this is a
fundamental problem of our society it
spans the spectrum from the failure of
public education to our nationwide
spiritual void to government ineptness
it almost uh criminal a lot to vote take
a look at arlington national cemetery
and then tell me you care not to vote
does not bode well for our country
either one of you bless your heart there
are specific things you can do to
increase voter turnout and one i'd like
to see is simply give people a day off
to vote
well if it's you know they have to have
a day off to vote
that's not going to address the problem
which is uh real apathy and ignorance
combined a parker annapolis maryland to
uh molly ivins and pat buchanan what do
you mean no one is out there talking
about the important issue ross perot is
doing his best to be that grain of sand
in the oyster uh ross pro has come into
the
wto battle i think he's doing a great
job i think his united we people
or united we stand group is one of the
two or three healthiest movements in
american politics yeah it's not
necessarily perot's
movement though i mean it's been taken
in a lot of places have been taken over
by the people themselves you're closer
to him down there than we are what do
you think of him at this point in 1994
will he run in 96 um i think he
definitely wants to be a player he
really likes the intention
i don't know if he's going to run or not
but he really be a force if he did in
the republican primary are you going to
run i had no call on that
uh justin harrison virginia beach
virginia i am a 19 year old male who
foresees a social security problem that
will not exist when i reach old age why
should i continue to pay high fica tax
when social security will supposedly be
insolvent in the year 2010 i asked this
of both your guests thank you it's got a
very good question and unless there are
some reforms made they're very simple
but they're politically difficult
unless there are some of these reforms
made by both parties uh the gentleman is
dead right the till will be empty when
he gets there molly island
um i don't think it's quite that serious
uh jake pickle uh texas congressman
who knows as much about social security
as anybody
feels that the last fix is going to last
quite a while and it's true pat's right
we need to do some fixing but it's not
dire and
it's amazing to me how many questions
we've had this morning are based on
scare assumptions fear isn't that
interesting uh asked pat buchanan why we
cannot receive his radio show in orange
county california he's not heard in l.a
that's what this says here it's tough
very tough to break into the la market
um i don't i think it's there's there's
big counties down there it's in there
somewhere it's a very very tiny station
you get to need the fingers of a safe
cracker to get it on the dial i think my
friend but some places out there you can
get it give us a call over at mutual
we'll tell you where it is molly ivan do
you ever think about doing a talk show
of your own radio talk show no i never
have i i'm a writer uh you gotta stick
to what you're good at here's uh here's
the fact who's that aimed at molly
here's a fact from dick backer of uh
norcross georgia uh i knew your dad
commissar ivan ivans back in the ukraine
you just commented that we open and
close the border to suit our needs for
cheap later labor isn't it true that
these mexicans flock here to take
advantage of the cheap wages which to
them look like a fortune
well again that border has always been
uh open and porous because it's a good
deal for us look it's american employers
who like the cheap labor that comes over
but there's no doubt i mean the minimum
wage here is by the way ivan's is welch
named
uh have you seen this piece in this week
it's a book peter goldman and thomas de
frank gunning for quail it's uh his
place on the gop ticket and his future
in politics came close to ending in 92.
you know i've not seen it i know pete
goldman and both those fellas but i have
not seen the book i saw the quote that
uh who they didn't source it someone was
said that the president was about to
dump him from the ticket i would be
astonished if that's true because i
think it would have been very damaging
to the republican ticket for him to do
that right there at the convention uh
hey molly this is a uh i didn't say that
molly this is from uh a fax thank god
for contract on america at last a
promise for what they will do and not
like clinton for change and will do and
not like clinton for change bs from
liberals like ivins needs a shovel to
clean up yo pat and c-span i don't know
why we're good anyway molly ivan's
comment on our glad i've given him
indigestion this early in the morning
do you normally get up this early molly
islands
how does it feel
i am here i am as bright out as i can be
it's 8 30 there and what are you going
to do for the rest of the day
mr buchanan do you still have a radio
show this afternoon we got a radio show
12-3 we're going to do a crossfire this
evening and i filed my column at uh
three this morning do you have any idea
what the topic is tonight
uh no you know we try to keep right on
the day's news i don't know what it
would be uh headline you could probably
guess as well as i could originally from
houston molly ivins is sitting in a
studio in austin she writes for the fort
worth star telegram and her column can
be seen around the united states she's a
graduate of smith and also columbia
university and we thank you for coming
in this early
and pat buchanan a native of washington
a graduate of georgetown a masters from
columbia
a member of the mclaughlin group in
those early days and often ran for
president 92 host of crossfire as he
just said and we thank you for coming in
good to see you again have a good week
[Music]
this discussion of some of the weekends
and the day's headlines can be seen
every monday morning at 8 a.m eastern
time 5 pacific
for 90 minutes we invite columnists and
commentators to other issues of the past
half century
see the program tonight at 9 30 pm
eastern time 6 30 pacific
[Music]
next molly ivins a columnist for the
fort worth star telegram
earlier this week ms ivan spoke to
students and faculty at the university
of california at davis about politics
and other current affairs
her speech lasts about an hour and 20
minutes
good evening everyone it's a pleasure to
see so many of you here my name is bob
gray i'm the provost and executive vice
chancellor at uc davis and i'm pleased
to welcome you on behalf of the campus
to tonight's lecture by columnist molly
ivins tonight's event is
sold out as you will detect this is the
third lecture in our 1994 95 uc davis
presents distinguished speakers series
the uc davis presents
series offers the capital region a
lively look at the issues and the
individuals that shape our times
and this year's series features
prominent individuals in literature
politics and the media
as part of our public service mission at
uc davis this
series of lectures strives to offer the
region
access to the people and the information
the events that shape our world
our final lecture on april 13
features james carville and mary matlin
this lecture has
also been sold out so this is not a
pitch for it but i hope many of you have
tickets and will return
and as you may have heard the lecture
will have an interesting twist
since
mary martin is now a mother-to-be and
will be participating
in the presentation live via satellite
from washington d.c
uh i want to make a special
acknowledgement tonight to the sponsors
of this evening's lectures which is
sponsor of this evening's lecture which
is the avid reader here in davis we
greatly appreciate
their sponsorship of this event
[Applause]
now a sport tonight uh following ms
ivan's remarks she will take questions
from the audience and i might mention
that this evening's lecture is being
taped by c-span
so you can
find yourself together with miss ivins
if you ask a question
and the microphones are located on the
the left and right sides the auditorium
and we'd ask that after
the
lecture and when the questions begin
that you please line up single file
behind the microphone and we also please
ask that you limit your questions your
remarks or to a single succinct question
so that she has the opportunity to
answer as many questions as possible i'm
also happy to announce that ms ivins
will be signing books
after the lecture in the front lobby
now to introduce our featured guest
it is my pleasure to welcome the editor
and chief of the california aggie our
student newspaper here at uc davis a
senior
a psychology major in her fourth year
with the aggie
and another molly molly marshall
thank you
[Music]
it is my honor tonight to welcome not
only a famed and best-selling author and
three-time finalist for the pulitzer
prize but also a fellow female
journalist with a wonderful first name i
might add
in 1976 she joined the new york times as
a political reporter
first at city hall then at the state
house in albany
in 1977 she was named rocky mountain
bureau chief
her work has appeared in esquire
atlantic the nation harper's tv guide
and numerous other publications
she also does occasional commentary for
national public radio and the mcneil
lehrer program
in addition she is a nationally
syndicated columnist for the fort worth
star telegram where she writes about
texas politics and other bizarre
happenings
and these are only a few of her many
accomplishments
it is my esteemed pleasure this evening
to introduce political humorist molly
ivins
[Applause]
[Music]
well i thank you also kindly it's so
nice to be here in the buckle on the
bicycle belt
um
let's uh i have a lot of things i want
to talk with you all about and uh we're
gonna take some time to answer questions
but uh let me start by warning you about
uh yet another vile and
pernicious plot
about to be foisted upon our innocent
heads by the
collection of morons we call congress in
washington um
they're all excited about a grand new
scheme called devolution
now there's not evolution in my home
state we're still fighting about
evolution no no
this is a different deal evolution it
sounds real good when they explain it
they say they want to give more power
and responsibility back to the states
and the government governs best that's
closest to the people and that all
sounds so sensible
do you realize they are talking about
the texas legislature
this is the goddamn worst idea i've
heard in years
idea of giving that collection of dorks
sweebs fools crooks
and then come boops more powers the most
repellent thing i ever heard
and the only reason your guys look good
is just by comparison
the evolution they say is going to make
it all better we give more power and
responsibility back to the states well
um i realize the california legislature
has held a somewhat preeminent
reputation over the years but you can't
tell me that there is not corruption and
stupidity in your legislature i know
damn well there it is
now i should point out that um there is
not
corruption in my legislature uh our guys
are not corrupt they are ethically
challenged
and tend on the whole to have uh an
overdeveloped sense of the extenuating
circumstance
they'll say winning things like
well y'all make some money on this bill
but just a little bit of money not a
whole lot
remember the time kilmer corbin got
elected out of lubbock he and uh
bill moore the bull of the browsers were
holed up in the driscoll hotel in
downtown austin drinking whiskey and
interviewing secretaries
knock knock knock on the door came the
chiropractor lobbyist every session in
texas we have the always hopeless
chiropractor bill and the chiropractor
lobbyist offered a meech 200 to vote for
the bill and kilmer took the money
and when the bill came up first week of
the session he voted against it
pissed off the chiropractor lobbyist
who came over to object and and so
kilmer explained well the doctors
offered me 400 to vote against you
really upset the lobbyists who cussed
kilmer up one side and down the other
and uh finally killer got kind of
offended his own self he said well you
knew i was weak when i took the 200.
it is those extenuating circumstances
that um
mark the actions of our guys and i'm
on the stupidity factor
carl parker always says if you took all
the foods out of the legislature it
would no longer be a representative body
and i
think that's quite right but when i
am as i sometimes am called upon to name
my all-time favorite texas legislator
i have to say that even the dumbest of
them have had a certain genesee quoi as
we often say in
lubbock um
and one who had a lot more of that naqua
than most was um
a fellow named mike martin he was an
early harbinger the moral majority got
elected out of longview texas
mike ran on a platform of being
pro-family and pro-american it was real
controversial but he got elected anyway
sent to austin but he turned out to be
legislatively impaired
could not get a single bill passed not
even memorial resolutions for people in
his district who had died i mean it was
real pathetic so when he came up for
reelection of course it's real hard to
get re-elected if you have not done dog
[ __ ]
and um
it looked to look bad for mike's
re-election but here is where the
genesee quoi comes in
mike showed an unsuspected streak of
imagination and decided that what he
needed to do to get himself re-elected
was to pay his cousin charlie to shoot
him in the arm
with a shotgun a touch i especially like
paid his cousin to shoot him in the arm
with a shotgun and then claim that it
had been done by a satanic and
communistic cult on account of he mike
martin was so pro-family and
pro-american
well you can imagine the excitement i
mean headlines in all the state papers
all the laws are running around all over
central texas trying to find a satanic
communist cult they're actually in
fairly short supply there and
big excitement and um
but as often happens in these cases the
plot came unraveled charlie got drunk in
a honky tonk and spilled the beans
now here i want to point something out
to you um
i always on behalf of my legislature as
compared to yours that
ours at least had the foresight to make
it illegal to pay someone to shoot you
y'alls probably haven't even done that
yet but
it is illegal so don't you come down to
texas looking for somebody to do that
for you
um
and with that world representative
martin became a wanted man and instead
of facing up to his legal diffulties uh
mike
took a funk he went into hiding he went
on the ground he took it on the lamb
and we had to send the texas rangers out
after him well they hunted him high and
hunted him low and at last after two
weeks they tracked him to earth at his
mama's house near longview
mike was found hiding in the stereo
cabinet at his mama's house
many people have wondered why my theory
is that he always did want to be speaker
[Applause]
okay now let me tell you the kind of
good work done by uh
the people in our state legislatures
um last session the big issue in texas
was we had to reform the penal code uh
we have uh much like california a whole
bunch of times people are stacked up in
our state prisons doing terminal
stretches for aggravated mopery and
loitering with intent
the result prison's terrible that
overcrowded and we can't keep the
violent criminals so we have to let them
go and everybody gets pissed off so
quite a bad situation so we were having
to reform the penal code and throw out a
lot of these useless old laws and uh
one of the laws that the district
attorneys of the state said they didn't
need they never used it uh is law
against
being gay it's illegal to be gay in
texas that it as we know it never
stopped anybody but
there it is and um
so they threw that one out and they sent
this revised penal code over the state
senate where
the guys in the senate had a rare moment
of courage and got it up and voted the
damn thing through but then it arrived
at the house the more conservative of
the two bodies than we have in the house
of representatives in texas so
state representative warren chisholm who
is a bible clumping dwarf from pampa
texas
one immediately leaped to his feet and
moved to reinstate homosexual sodomy
into the penal code
and all the guys in the house was afraid
that everybody would think they was
queer if they didn't vote for it so they
did
and uh
then some constitutional scholar
explains to a warren that unless he also
moves to reinstate heterosexual sodomy
this deal is going to be held
unconstitutional
so one nothing loath leaps to his feet
again who's reinstate heterosexual
sodomy
and an interesting debate ensued
some of our more avant-garde members got
up at the back mike and they said well
uh warren suppose i'm in bed with my
lawfully wedded spouse and i like kind
of slip and wind up in the wrong hole
you don't want to send me to prison for
that don't you
warned at the front right said yes i do
it's against nature and the bible um
so in the end all the guys in the house
is afraid everybody would think they was
perverts if they didn't vote for this
and they did and reinstated heterosexual
side of men warren was at the front mike
with his uh great ally tell mcheffern
the two of them high-fiving and slapping
each other on the back having a big
celebration and the press box called
over the sergeant-at-arms and said
sergeant you have to go over and
reprimand both those men because under
the provisions of the amendments just
passed by representative chisholm and
it's now illegal for a prick to touch an
[ __ ] in this
state put that on c-span
[Applause]
now before we go on telling more uh
glorious and hilarious true tales of
politics in my state and some that i
know about politics and yours um
let's just stop for a minute to consider
the state of the union
probably a c-minus um
my old friend john henry faulk or some
of you uh older citizens may recall john
henry probably nobody else does johnny
died about five years ago but he was in
his well-done in his day a well-known uh
texas
humorist
and not many people know that john henry
also had a career in law enforcement uh
in fact he was in the texas rangers
he was a captain in the texas rangers he
was six at the time
and his friend boots cooper who was
seven was the sheriff
and the two of them used to do a lot of
very serious law enforcement out behind
the fault family house in south austin
texas
and one day johnny's mama having two
such fine law enforcement officers right
there on the property
uh said to him always i want you all to
go down the hen house and root that
chicken snake out of the hen house so
johnny and boots were all excited and
they galloped into the hen house on
their brooms and tethered their brooms
we're looking through all the nests on
the bottom row of hen house looking for
a chicken snake and did not find it
and they were of an age and of a size
where to see up on the second shelf they
had to stand on tiptoe to see the snake
was there
and it was
i myself have never been nose to nose
with a chicken snake but i always took
johnny's word for it that it will just
scare the living [ __ ] out of it
scared johnny in boots so bad they both
tried to get out of the hen house at the
same time
doing considerable damage to both
themselves and the hen house door in the
process
mr spark watching this from the porch
was kind of amused by it it came
trailing back up all shane's face and
she said boys boys what is wrong with
you you know perfectly well that a
chicken snake will not hurt you
and that's when boots cooper made this
semi immortal observation
he said yes ma'am
but there are some things that scare you
so bad you'll hurt yourself
and i think that's what we do in this
country over and over again we get so
scared of some terrible menace
we get so scared of communism or crime
or illegal aliens pornography
that we
hurt ourselves
we think that we can make ourselves
safer if we make ourselves less free
now and
make any sense logically but it's a
consistent reaction in our history there
must be some comfort in the thought that
crime wouldn't be so terrible if we had
fewer rights
give up some of the rights and then
we'll make ourselves safer
um and it never does work i mean you
know it's it's just a silly idea but
it's one that recurs again and again
and i would suggest to you all that
maybe the most frightened people in
america
right now are christian fundamentalists
and not without cars i think anyone who
looks at the wilder shores of american
culture these days and does not feel at
least a twinge of alarm probably doesn't
have a lick of common sense
but
i should explain that i
speak of fundamentalists um
not
i think there's a very has been
traditionally very large gap between
american intellectuals and
fundamentalists and
in my case it um
overcome by an accident of birth
i was born and raised amongst foot
washing baptists they are my friends my
neighbors and my relatives
and
they make wonderful neighbors
um i don't regard them as strange or
other or different uh i know many of
them to be wonderfully generous hearted
people
and it does seem to me that their sense
of alienation from
the
cultural mainstream in this country has
been badly aggravated by the media
in fact i would challenge any one of you
to name a single book play film or
television program of recent vintage
in which the protagonist is a
sympathetically portrayed fundamentalist
the only one i know of is a lovely
little novel called a rainy by clyde
edgerton out of north carolina
there's a professor of the sociology of
religion down at rice university in
houston uh bill martin and i i do
disservice to his ideas by
oversimplifying but one of the things
that martin says is that as a society
becomes
more modern and more secular
those who cling to traditional and
conservative beliefs cling ever more
fiercely
so that what has been a gap between the
two groups then becomes a chasm
and i think that is what is happening to
christian fundamentalists in this
country
they are retreating into
a separate world of their own
in a time of mass communication they
have their own mass communication
and it is really extraordinary the
extent to which they are
uninfluenced and unaware of um common
currents in american life
and it seems to me that there is a
greater burden while while a dialogue
between
those who
pride themselves on
logic
and reason
and those whose primary value is
simple absolute faith
that's a very difficult dialogue
nevertheless i think
we need to start it and those of us who
pride ourselves on our empathy and
compassion
and ability to see the world from
somebody else's point of view have
perhaps a larger obligation to reach out
and start that dialogue
than do those who make no such claims
um having said all that let me also say
that i see no reason whatever to let
these blue bellied and income poops
screw up the first amendment
[Applause]
which they are in the process of doing
um
i don't know how many of you
spend much time talking to christian
fundamentalists but one of the
discussions one of the phrases that
invariably comes up is they will inform
you that nowhere in the constitution of
the united states do the word separation
of church and state appear
which is quite true of course
what we call separation of church and
state stems from the establishment
clause the first two parts of the first
amendment and i think that
when you read the bill of rights you
will realize that the founders wrote it
very carefully indeed
the very very first
part of the first amendment establishes
freedom of conscience and freedom of
religion
and also forbids the state to establish
religion and it is that that is
generally referred to as separation of
church and state
should there be any question in your
mind as to what the founders meant
by the establishment clause uh it is
very easy to refer to their own words in
1803 jamie madison wrote a letter
in that wonderful
18th century prose none of us can
replicate anymore
he said the purpose of separation of
church and state is to keep forever from
these shores the ceaseless strife that
has soaked the soil of europe in blood
for
centuries and still does today you pick
up any newspaper read about the soil of
bosnia
soaked with blood some of it apparently
from muslim virgins being raped is a
matter of policy by their christian
neighbors
you can read about sarajevo easily the
most cosmopolitan sophisticated city in
eastern europe
absolutely destroyed and ripped apart in
a matter of months by religious passions
people who had lived and worked and
intermarried
together for generations
suddenly killing one another
over religious passions the same thing
happened in beirut once the jewel of the
middle east now a city absolutely
destroyed
by religious fashions to keep forever
from these shores
the ceaseless strife that has soaked the
soil of europe in blood for centuries
and it seems to me that that principle
is so important
that it is worth being a bit of a pain
in the ass about
and that in fact is the sad
lot that falls to those of us who
insists on both the letter and the
spirit of separation of church and state
the
typical problem of separation in church
and state comes up every christmas when
someone in an excess of christmas spirit
and seasonal goodwill puts up some
religiously symbolic
uh piece of art on public property and
of course the goddamn civil liberties
union gets out there and sues their ass
thus making themselves about as popular
as this when we're trying to get in the
smu school of theology
every year they are right there at
christmas time bringing lawsuits just
like the grinch that stole christmas
every year to i say to him god damn
couldn't you people wait until after new
year's but no
every year they sue
um
i remember one year some folks put up a
crush at our state capitol and
the aclu of course threatened to sue and
i was calling on our state officials to
get their reaction i called ann richards
who was then the state treasurer said
and what do you think does the crash
have to go
she said oh i hate to see him take the
crash out of the capitol it could be the
only chance we'll ever get to have three
wise men in that building
[Applause]
now
this brings me to you may have wondered
if i knew where i was going but i did um
what i really want to talk to you all
about tonight um which is the importance
of having fun while fighting for freedom
[Music]
you got to have fun while you fighting
for freedom for one thing you don't
always win and that might get to be all
the fun you ever have
um there is a dreadful tendency toward
earnestness
you may have noticed on behalf of many
of our fellow citizens and i for one
think it needs to be combated with all
the strength and imagination at our
disposal
so that when we are confronted with the
problems of freedom as we always are and
every generation has to face them anew
it's not as though you know you get the
american heritage and there it is it's
all yours and you don't have to do
anything about it for the rest of your
life never has been a deal like that
it's never been one long broad smooth
path of progress ever onward and upward
toward greater liberty and justice for
all
god damn that road has been rocky and
full of potholes and sometimes it just
takes a hairpin turn and we roll right
back down the hill
and it is
up to every generation of americans to
make sure that that legacy remains
intact because what we are all of us i
think is the heirs we are heirs
to the most magnificent political legacy
any people has ever received
um i don't know about y'all but i really
do believe in all of it i do believe
that all men and women are created equal
i believe that we are endowed by our
creator with certain inalienable rights
and that among these are life liberty
and the pursuit of happiness
i believe that governments are
instituted among men to secure those
rights and that whenever any government
becomes destructive of those ends it is
the right of the people to alter or
abolish it
and that dream which is now 200 years
old the dream that just people not kings
and princes and nobles
high officials of the church
just people can govern themselves
is still so resonant that it echoes all
over the world people are willing to die
for it
they died for it at tiananmen square
they died for it in south africa they're
dying for it today in myanmar
and in this country out of boredom and
cynicism
selfishness and
hear more and inaudible is people
talking about government
as them as they back in washington them
those people they do things to us no
they don't this is our deal
this is our country
and government is what we do together
what we decide together needs to be done
for all of us
and it is a terrific responsibility
but while it's a great responsibility
and it does fall on each of us
i think
that one of the things that's wrong with
this country is that we just gotten too
damn serious about the ordeal and that
is why i'm here to urge you all to think
creatively about your responsibility as
citizens
now look at the kind of deal you come up
with um
a couple years ago in austin uh the ku
klux klan was coming to hold a march and
rally in austin they had uh the cluckers
had gotten all upset because the
state legislature passed a law uh
observing the birthday of dr martin
luther king as state holiday
and actually was compromised deal we
kept confederate heroes day
um
and the klan was undertaken and they
announced they're coming and they have a
big protest now
of course obviously here in in
the center of political correction where
people are not even allowed to smoke
outdoors um
y'all don't have to worry about these
tacky manifestations of wrong thinking
but uh in much of the country we do and
when the clan shows up it's always a
pain in the butt um
you know the black citizens get upset
the jewish citizens get upset the
skinheads turn out to cheer them on
people get into fist fights on the
sidewalk and and
you know everybody's playing at
everybody for a good six months there
never a lot of fun and of course if
you're a civil libertarian there you are
upstairs you know saying well the ninja
poops have a right to march
making yourself real popular once again
um so uh
we decided that
something different was called for by
way of response and um
there are not enough cluckers to ride
around austin to have a good
demonstration they had to bust them in
from waco inviter
and they got off the bus wearing their
little pointy hoods on their little pony
heads and
proceeded to march up congress avenue
they were greeted by five thousand
citizens of austin who lined both the
sidewalks as they marched and uh mooned
them as they marched
[Applause]
this made a real nice effect it's kind
of like a wave in a baseball stadium
and i think that uh creativity and and
humor are
incredibly important in our public lives
um
in fact i'm working with a group now
just trying to put together a new civic
celebration this would be a fundraising
deal of course for the bill of rights
and
what we have in mind is a festival
patterned after one in pamplona spain
we're going to call ours the running of
the lawyers
and of course they'll be led through the
streets by an ambulance
and sightseers and tourists can come and
run and touch them and then run away
again
uh and we think this is gonna be real
good fundraiser
um
there was a great freedom fighter named
joe rowe who uh died a year or so ago
and um
one time one of us uh
freedom fighting organizations were
specialized some
lifetime achievement awards on a bunch
of heavy hitters and one of them was joe
who was sick in hospital at the time and
asked a friend of his to go down to
philadelphia and collect this award for
him
and what happens if you spend a lifetime
freedom fighting is that in the end you
get a lot of plaques
which are make very nice trivets you can
put hot dishes right on them
um
and joe went to see him in her his
friend went to see joe in hospital said
well you want me to tell these folks
when i go to philadelphia and he said
you could see joe lying there just sick
as a dog thinking about it all and you
know ralph first became a hero back in
the mccarthy era um
time of such
cowardice
and spinelessness
no one almost no one would speak up
people were too frightened
um
and it really was a sorry bad ugly angry
time people's lives were destroyed and
their careers were ruined
and then joe was active in the early
civil rights movement uh which was also
not a hell of a lot of fun
a lot of people getting beat up and
pushed around my
southern segregated law system
um
and he said you could see joe lying
there thinking about it and finally he
looked up and said
tell him how much fun it was
tell him how much fun he was
now that's my ambition
and i think it should be you all's too
when i get down toward the end of my
road i not only
want to pass our political heritage
along to our posterity
a great phrase from the constitution
to the kids the students sitting in the
audience tonight
i want to be able to pass it along
intact i don't want to be able to look
them each in the eye and tell them how
much fun we had
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
gosh i kind of hurried through my speech
because i thought i was taking too long
and now i've got lots of time to do
questions which has been just my
favorite thing
i hope you all will sing out and ask
about politicians and and
politics and gossip and all kinds of
good stuff
leap right up head for those microphones
sure just stick your hand in there and
sing out and i'll repeat the question
we got a question over here
molly i grew up in texas and it's so
good to hear you talk bless your heart
any night here someone speak normally
you didn't say anything about your new
governor oh a shrub bust little george
um
well you know he's not that bad um
as uh as the little bushes go i think we
got the flower of the family he's
not as right-wing as jeb he's not as
dumb as neal he's um
you know perfectly amiable he's made a
lovely manners oh just like his daddy
lovely manners he he lacks big george's
uh
wonderful daffy streak
you know you'd always count on big
george bush to achieve this transcendent
level of dorkiness at least once a day
little george doesn't seem to have that
but there's hope and um
he's doing all right so far um
his big deal is tort reform which i'm uh
not wildly enthusiastic about but that's
another argument um
i don't know you get elected to public
office and all you want to do is save
big corporations from being sued seems
to me you might work on a higher
ambition if you really tried um
but no he's a perfectly amiable fellow
i'm it he's got a hard act to follow he
was um
the other day uh was at a shindig with
uh our comptroller john sharp and and uh
he said yep do i call you controller or
comptroller and john said
i don't want them easy
george said well what did the last
governor call you and john said darling
molly a couple years ago you folks sent
me sent us a terrible export michael
huffington who just spent
he just spent 27 million of his own
dollars running for senate if we give
you that 27 million will you take them
back
do we look like fool
yeah that really was an exciting
campaign god almighty that was
i mean if we were going to have total
disaster with republicans taking over
both houses of congress y'all really
should have sent us huffington to have
fun with i mean you know ollie north
what the hell as long as they're in the
majority let's just get the real good
ones
um
i was privileged to be out here during
mr huffington's campaign and uh
enjoyed hearing him make the one uh live
speech he made during that campaign
explaining about how god told him to run
um
oh you really should have
it would have been so much fun
uh i'm using as my hometown where the
huffington family is from i
uh i believe it's been said of michael
for quite some time that boy's not right
you could have had him for senator and
you blew it
thank you molly for your entertainment
and education my question is
what's your take on newt
you speak of the
draft dodging dope-smoking deadbeat dad
who divorced his dying wife
[Music]
that's
a characterization that meets every
standard for accuracy set by rush
limbaugh
i'm so proud of it
um
i noticed one thing
that has been consistent throughout
gingrich's public life
um he consistently accuses other people
of that of which he himself is guilty
i believe the strengths call it
projection um
and i just point that out to you because
it has been such a consistent pattern
with him that you want to listen very
carefully when he attacks other people
um i am
i've been around the texas legislature
in texas politics for a long time and um
i certainly have never pretended or
thought that politics was a terribly
genteel occupation
in fact i must say i relish its
rowdiness
but there is a level of
mean-spiritedness in the current
political debate that i find very
terrible and troubling
and i particularly uh blame newt
gingrich for that
i'm sure he is not single-handedly
responsible
uh on the other hand i think that it one
can make a very convincing case that um
he has all by himself done a great deal
to encourage and disseminate that
mean-spiritedness when in 1990 he um
through gopac his political action
committee
sent out an infamous list of words which
he recommended all republican candidates
used to describe all of their democratic
opponents
the words included a sick bizarre
pathetic traitor
and it seems to me to blindly
and blanketly recommend that that kind
of
language be used in normal course of
political debate uh does signal
disservice to all of us
and for that uh i hold the man in
considerable disesteem
however i i am also on the other hand uh
forced to acknowledge my gratitude uh to
him i had not until i listened to his
lecture series realized that men were
genetically programmed to hunt giraffes
this evening on national public radio
there's a piece of news from your home
base or city of the home-based newspaper
fort worth um that
might reflect on the seriousness of
america an organization called dead
serious yes
what are your feelings about it dead
serious is a vigilante organization in
fort worth texas
it is the actual brainchild of an
interesting convicted felon
and the deal is that you join dead
serious for a fee of ten dollars and if
there after you kill a criminal in the
commission of a crime uh they will award
you five thousand dollars it's kind of
like a big insurance society on the
crook killing front
and you've got to admit it's original
goddamn idea and um
novel i'd say it's novel
i might even say fresh
um
and the inspiration is that uh in texas
we are about to pass a concealed handgun
law making it legal uh for jacksons to
carry concealed handguns as they go
about their daily business it has always
been legal to own guns but it's
extraordinarily simple to buy a gun in
texas the only state laws are that you
have to be 18 years old and sober
and you can keep your gun in your
home but you've not been permitted here
too for to tow around the streets
hidden away somewhere
and my legislature and its wisdom
is going to vote that through and shrug
bush has already announced that he will
sign it and richards vetoed it two years
ago
they tried to convince her that uh women
in texas would feel safer if they could
carry handguns in their purses
and ann said
you know i am not a sexist but there is
not a woman in this country who could
find a gun in her handbag
[Applause]
i myself am supporting the concealed
weapons bill i think that's just what
texas needs is a lot more total uh blue
belly and income poops running around
with guns
we don't have enough of them already
uh i just want to add one little
amendment the perfecting amendment as
they say in the legislature i think
anybody who wants to should be allowed
to carry a concealed weapon but you
should also have to wear one of those
beanies with a propeller on top
i think this would make it a lot better
i should explain uh because i hate
getting those death threats
that i do when i speak out on this issue
i am not anti-gun
i am pro-knife
[Applause]
there's a lot to be said for the knife
knives encourage physical fitness you
have to catch someone before you can
stab him
knives don't ricochet
you almost never hear of a person killed
while cleaning his knife
over here
molly have you read the book strange
justice the selling of clarence thomas
and if so would you please comment on it
uh yes i have read strange justice the
book by two women reporters for the wall
street journal i'm sorry i cannot recall
their names right now
and
just as we all suspected
um
it is a very nice piece of reporting and
uh
i was uh
so astonished by the
dreadful
book called the real anita hill
which just as a journalist i found
offensive it was such bad reporting that
i'm i'm just feeling relieved on behalf
of the honor of my trade that somebody
has finally written a good book
[Music]
i suspect
that
history will judge that
the single most shameful act of george
bush's presidency was putting clarence
thomas on the supreme court
why were you banned from
a
um that's one of those deals where the
punch line is better than the story
i just to tell you real fast i was text
observer editor back in the early 70s
and poor old a m you know they're always
still fighting the battles of the 50s
still are today and they had a rule on
campus that you could not have a
political speaker on campus now they'd
already had barry goldwater and john
tara that year but
the administration explained that they
did not make political speeches
so um there's an organization there on
campus called the concerned students of
a m there's five of them their total
membership
and they wanted to test this rule and
and they had gone through every liberal
progressive person in the whole state of
texas had been turned down by all of
them and i was the 99th and last person
on their list and they begged and
pleaded so i said oh [ __ ] i'll do it
and they put up posters saying molly
evans well-known radical editor of the
texas observers coming to speak on
campus and them if the administration
didn't bite uh they threatened to take
out an injunction to prevent them from
speaking on campus which of course would
have been a fabulous first amendment
case
um
but somebody uh snapped two in time and
realized that that was not the right way
to go so what they did instead was they
threatened to yank the student charter
of the concerned students at texas a m
and my guys chickened out is what they
did and uh instead of speaking on campus
i spoke across the street at the
methodist student center
i did my dead level best to incite a
riot but i had no success
after it was over all eight people who
turned out to hear me clap politely and
we all went out for beer
[Music]
any question over there
yeah i'd just like to hear your comments
on our own uh speaker of the assembly
willie brown
the real slick willie
um mr willie brown i'm a willy brown fan
i have to tell you that i mean ever
since
ever since to give me my delegation
speech god
i like people with fire and energy and
politics um you know interestingly
enough i see you spoken out on this um
boy y'all really have such amazing
issues in this state
um they're going to put affirmative
action on the ballot and uh willie brown
had a fit the other day and said well
that's just racism and let's not uh you
know let's not be
uh calling you know calling it anything
with gloves on
um
i think that would be a really
interesting debate and the question is
whether
people understand that affirmative
action is not
reverse discrimination
there is a difference both between
anti-discrimination laws and affirmative
action and between affirmative action
and reverse discrimination
and
i know some people think that that is a
too subtle a point for the great public
but it is my opinion that one of the
mistakes made most consistently by
people both in the media and in politics
is underestimating
the intelligence of the american people
and i know a million cynical lines all
the reasons why we can look around and
say god damn what a bunch of dumb clocks
in fact i think it's one of our more
charming cultural
uh traits
um
you know how often we study ourselves to
find out how stupid we are
and you almost every week if you read
your paper carefully you will find a
report
that once again somebody has studied us
and found out that we don't know dogs
yet about math or history or our own
constitution
we think that you know egg foo young is
is the vice premier of china we're just
that um
alexis de tocqueville never should have
divorced that guy and the
soap opera
and every time we do one of these
studies finding it proving how dumb we
are we all sit around oh god we're so
dumb oh this is terrible
[Applause]
i just think it's a charming part of our
culture that i relish every time i see
it we have once again studied ourselves
and found out we don't we're dumb
um
i don't think we're dumb i think we're
selectively ignorant
and i think we're all selectively
ignorant i mean i know a lot about
politics uh but i could no more open the
engine of my car and fix something that
was wrong with it then i could fly
and the guy down at joe bob's texaco who
knows how to fix my pickup uh probably
not know a whole lot about the texas
legislature so you know
not
stupid just
selectively ignorant
and uh i am convinced that you can you
can have reasonable uh
political debate in this country and one
of them even on a touchy subject like
affirmative action as long as you make
sure that the person you're discussing
that issue with
knows how to define it
and that's one of the problems we have
in this country but except i always hate
those arguments you get into where right
in the middle of a good argument someone
says well define your terms
um
okay yeah hi molly
um
there's another upstart texan who would
be president
and his name is phil graham
and we don't know too much about him and
i for one think that uh he has uh
said a lot of the right things to uh get
himself hurt in a lot of places so i
wonder if you might comment on him
um
i am willing to lay pretty good money uh
at really fairly good odds if anyone
will take the vet um
that if
you were to conduct an entirely secret
poll of the members of the united states
senate as to which member they most
disliked there would be 99 votes for
phil graham
this is a man that people who know don't
care for
and that's been true of him throughout
his public life
phil graham is mean um
and normally i don't think americans
vote for mean candidates
richard nixon was was the last sort of
observably mean president we had
but he was elected in a time of great
national crisis in the country appeared
to be coming apart at the seams when he
was elected
i think what you will of ronald reagan
he was certainly an amiable doofus
bless his heart
never saw anything mean about ronald
reagan
beamed cheerfully on us all
and thought he was doing the right thing
um
i don't and so i don't think phil graham
is going to go very far in national
politics
the
downside on that prediction is that he
has collected the biggest war chest of
any of the republican candidates he's
sitting on 20 million bucks
and in a primary season that is
extraordinarily front loaded you got
more and more primaries move right up
toward the front of the primary season
uh that kind of money counts
even more than it used to
so that there's there's a chance that
y'all are going to take a real serious
look at mr graham
he uh
not only has the personality of a
snapping turtle but he looks sort of
like one if you ever notice that he
recedes at both ends
and somebody asked me about how i got
elected in texas uh in my home state the
populist uh political tradition is alive
and well and that's the real populism
not the
false populism that so many people
mistakenly
think they know about
but even in the real populist tradition
there's always been both a left wing and
a right wing tradition and phil graham
is very good at portraying himself as a
right-wing populist a friend of the
little man
uh he's he always refers to a fellow
named vicky flatt who's a printer in
mahayana texas and
uh phil graham claims that his acid test
on anything in washington is whether or
not dickey flats money should be spent
on it
and uh you know that plays real well in
my state so
there you are
um
on the whole i'd rather have michael
huffington as president
[Applause]
good evening given the
high incidence of successful politicians
crossing over into
a more media
atmosphere gary hart that sort of thing
i was wondering
what involvement you think
your profession journalists and or
commentators should have in the
political process i mean how closely
tied should they be to who gets elected
that's a very good question um i i am a
professional centric it's a word i made
up myself um
which means that i hold people in my
profession responsible for damn near
everything that's wrong with the entire
world
i just think if we did our jobs better
the people would be beautifully well
informed make the right decisions and
nobody would ever have to worry about
anything again
but because we do such a goddamn awful
job
terrible confusion results um
i have always been
optimistic to the point of idiocy
um
one of the things that troubles me about
political commentators these days it
used to be that if you the way you got a
political column
was you were the best political reporter
on your paper
or if if there were lots of you at a
place like the new york times then you
were the best political writer of your
generation
at your paper
and
that was how you got to be a columnist
and eventually a commentator after
television came along
and uh i'm not uh claiming that uh all
was wonderful and great in those days
but i i do point out to you that the
tendency that we see more and more which
is to pluck columnists and commentators
to give them
syndicated newspaper columns and much
exposure on television as political
commentators is to pluck them right off
the front lines of particle partisan
political warfare
often right out of the white house
itself john sununu went straight from
the white house to being a syndicated
columnist and a common television
commentator
buchanan mona charon
you can go on and on it's an absolutely
extraordinary list of people who have
who had no previous experience in
journalism
uh and were given columns in very
distinguished papers and positions of
high visibility
the only one who's any good is bill
sapphire and he is the exception that
proves the rule of course there's always
one of them
i don't think that
we can make any great claims for
scientific training of journalists but i
will tell you that i think there is
genuine merit to having spent several
years of your life
working for some newspaper or wire
service where what you did essentially
every day was go out and interview all
five eyewitnesses to an automobile
accident and then try and write an
accurate story
it gives you a greater sense of the
complexity of truth
and i find that these people who come
into journalism straight from
ideological partisan warfare
have no sense
that
they have no respect for fact and no
sense that truth is complex
and i i find it a very
uh
distressing trend
and um i'll probably have to you know
consider doing something like putting
super glue in their chairs or something
[Music]
hi even if you don't have a great
anecdote about him could you at least do
your wonderful imitation of the one you
call p rot ah
h
h ross um
well of course there was the ultimate
ross perot pulled the best gotcha that
anybody has ever pulled on me
um
ross pro used to call me after i
mentioned him and his him and say funny
things
because i would say funny things and i
call him about him
and um
one time
one time i announced to an astonished
world that ross perot was in fact a
communist
indeed an agent of the kremlin and the
way we knew this was that
he had just come out in front of god and
everybody and said the trouble of texas
public schools was too much
football
so it's perfectly obvious that he was an
agent uh
for the other side
and uh he called after i printed that
and said
i've been calling a lot of things before
first time i've ever been called a
communist i think i'll have jerry
falwell pray for me
you know p-rock really does sound
exactly like a chihuahua um
and uh one day one terrible day i made a
very serious error about mr perot in my
column i was using uh him as an example
i was talking about yet another horrible
idea from the reagan era
the two-tier flat income tax and try to
explain my readers why i thought it was
a bad idea
and i said as though you see
if you make more than seventeen thousand
five hundred dollars a year you are now
in exact the same tax bracket as ross
perot
and then because my high school english
teacher always taught me to write
balanced sentences
i added comma
who makes more than a million dollars a
year i said now i've made the fatal
journalistic error i did not check um i
knew he was big rich and i figured it
was safe to claim that he made more than
a million dollars a year so i didn't
check and i put it in the paper
and the next day the guys on our
business desk called they're just
laughing their asses off and they said
islands ross perot makes a million
dollars a day
and i didn't know kuwait made that much
money so
i was sitting there thinking to myself
damn this is going to be an embarrassing
correction when the phone rang and this
operator said ross perot calling collect
for molly ivan's where you accept the
charges
[Applause]
was so discombobulated i didn't even
tell the chief some [ __ ] to call back
on his own nichola accepted the charge
in uh california and some other states
at least some of the laws are passed
directly by the people obviating the
state legislature there are some people
that think that the legislatures and the
congress are a great waste of power and
money that politicians should be removed
from the political process as much as
possible what do you feel about this
trend is the legislative branch of
government serving a useful function
well let's make sure we're talking on
the same channel here um are you
referring to the um
term limits
no no the initiative process only
initiative and referendum process
you know as an old populist those were
once great populist uh uh goals and and
ideas i'm i'm terribly disappointed um i
would
as a as a small d democrat um
would have liked
uh to see initiative and referendum in
my state until i came to california and
study the way you all do it and of
course
now concluded that
it is really a perfectly dreadful idea
um we all know that um
the trouble with politics in this
country is money
um we have a political system that is
thoroughly corrupted by money it is a
system of legalized bribery um
and um it is the way campaigns are
financed that is the root of the rock
and
happily it's fairly easy to fix i mean
again you are talking to a genuine
optimist i not only think it's fixable i
don't think it's even that hard to fix
uh but we're going to have to lean on
the dumb sons of [ __ ] a lot more than
we have been doing before they'll do
anything about it
uh and what has happened here with
initiative and referendum is of course
that money has come to poison that
process as well
the only thing in politics is you have
to dance with them what brought you
and
while that's true politicians in terms
of campaign financing what happens in
in campaigns like initiative and
referendum is that the money
buys
uh access to means of communication
at a rate that is prohibitive for often
those who speak for the real public
interest
i have been thinking more and more that
it is time for us to use the first
amendment and particularly the freedom
of speech and freedom of press parts of
the first amendment
not just as
defensive weapons as ball works against
censorship whenever sensors sleep up we
always say first amendment first
amendment you can't do that king sex um
and i think it is time to start using
the first amendment as a legal weapon
uh an offensive weapon to force open
access to the technologies of
communication
it is
thank you
well god damn there some other people
have been thinking about this too all
right i'm glad to hear that i'm glad to
hear that
george will take that up with the aclu
wasting their time suing people at
christmas
well i've been asked to keep this
succinct yeah um i'm just going to say
that the gentleman that asked about phil
graham reminded me of a comment that
came from a
new hampshire fellow
and new englanders can be charmingly
candid but when asked
about phil graham
and one of his competitors the senator
from kansas
he said well phil graham uses the word i
think this and i think that constantly
and he seems very self-centered to me so
i'm not going to vote for him but bob
dole uses we a lot and i think that's
sincere personally i think it's the
royal we how do you feel about that
i think that's so interesting uh
that you see none of us have truly
original ideas i've made a distinction
between i politicians and we politicians
for years
i find that the way they use that that
uh pronoun is very significant
and funny i didn't even know what it
said about graham
um sometimes it's a learn thing that we
um
politicians learn it but
the the ones i hear who would use it i
remember hubert humphrey always used we
were eternally giving credit to other
people
i think i think that fellow from new
hampshire is hit on something
i like that
hi molly um i wanted to know what you
might say about proposition 187 here in
california and how different factions of
texans have viewed that given the
similar issues with immigration in texas
well now of course i'm a visitor in your
state
and uh
i don't
think it's nice for guests to be tearing
down their hosts but let me just explain
something to you all uh my state went
broke big time uh in the middle of the
1980s uh the price of oil went from
thirty four dollars a barrel to under
nine dollars a barrel in the space of
four months in the mid 1980s and my
statement of one industry state was just
flat on its ass and it was not a lot of
fun
texans are actually better at going
broke than they are at having money
i thought that we
we handled going broke with some class
and some grace and some style which is
more than can ever be said for us when
we had money
um
i suspect that is because um
basically
we have an oil psychology and and uh
people with oil business are gamblers so
basically it's a crap shoot
and one of the things you know when you
if you're a crafts player is that sooner
or later you crap out and it's just part
of the game and what you do is you
scrape yourself up together another
steak and start over again and you don't
go throwing yourself out of windows or
doing anything stupid just because
you've gone broke
and i
while i was proud of the way texans
behaved during that difficult time
i know full well exactly how hard it was
and it was real rough and it was real
unpleasant
and uh because we had traditionally
behaved badly we got damn little
sympathy for the rest of the country and
i always remember the um
headline in the new republic let the
texans fry in the sun um
nobody was rushing to our aid um
and so when
we had barely barely dug out of that uh
in the 90s and uh
so when we saw california start to go
down the toilet we knew exactly how you
all felt and i must say only whether or
not there were great expressions of
sympathy from
our state it is is very painful to watch
uh a state as
big and beautiful and proud and glorious
as this one in deep economic trouble and
we know what those double-digit
unemployment figures mean and we know
what it's like when
that recession just drags on and on and
on and on and people lose her heart and
hope it is not a pleasant thing
now having said that and nobody has ever
accused texas of being a very
forward-looking or progressive place uh
usually you all are recognized for in
that area
never in our wildest and darkest moments
uh when our state was really at the
bottom
did not ever occur up to us to blame
mexicans for the problem
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
and i don't know why y'all chose to do
that i'm i i think perhaps it was your
failure to notice certain things so you
hardly ever see those illegal mexicans
running the s and outs
not often you get those illegal mexicans
shutting down your defense industries on
you
not often to be observed involved in
land flips
either what in the world
took over you people's brains
silliest damn thing i ever heard of
oh
i didn't mean to scold but i just did
want to express my opinion
hi molly i'm wondering what you think um
what kind of challenges print
journalists like you face
in
this age of broadcast journalism and the
information superhighway and
um it's a good question um
i'm
i'm generally
obviously i think the newspapers are
i've been told all my life that i was in
a dying industry and it ain't dead yet
um
i don't think it is a dying industry i
think among other things what we're
going to realize is our lives become
busier you know this busyness is sort of
the hallmark of our time
a bunch of us running around like the
white rabbit all the time
like
um
people are going to notice once again
that the most efficient way to acquire
information is to read
uh it's just a matter of saving time
there you know
a lot slower to take it in through the
year
um
i think the difference is and i i
certainly agree that a picture is worth
a thousand words um
there i don't think there is a writer on
earth that could have equaled the impact
in words
that hit us all in the stomach when we
saw the
challenger explode on television in
front of our eyes i mean it was just
i don't think a writer could have
described that as vividly any writer it
was just a a stunning thing
um
but the thing about pictures is that
they are by their very nature limited to
the surface of events
in order to understand history and
causation and structure in order to
understand why
the thing blew up
you had to go back and read the long
series in the new york times about the
o-rings the problem with the o-rings who
knew about the problem with the o-rings
who should have told about the problem
with the o-rings and so on and so on
and i think that the trouble with
relying on television
uh is that you get the news without any
understanding of why it's happening
and for that i think you still need to
rely on print
i have some hope for television because
i'm such an optimist um
i think that in the eye of history
television is just a blink of an eye
and that
obviously they'll they'll learn how to
use it better as as a tool as a medium
for getting it truth and portraying
reality
uh they're they're already doing a lot
better than they used to
the bad news is of course that there are
now economic pressures on television
journalism that tend to work against its
excellence which is most unfortunate
we have time for two more questions all
right
hi uh i'm another molly so i feel like
we have this big affinity going here um
i'm a young woman on the verge of
continuing education so in other words
without a lot of extra time on my hands
um
i'm also a writer and um
also a member of what sometimes feels
like a very small minority of feminist
folk
and i'm wondering
what kind of advice what's the best
thing that i can do
for myself as a writer to make myself
heard
bless your heart um
well
you know
one of the things that i've learned over
uh
30 years of being a feminist is that if
you go around crying sexism sexism every
time it rears its ugly head uh people
get real tired of it in fact you get
real tired of it uh if you went around
saying sex and some sexism every time
you saw it god you wouldn't have time to
do anything else with your eyes
um
i do think that uh we not only live in a
sexist society but that we are in the
middle of a very serious backlash
against the women's movement i think
it's manifesting itself in innumerable
ways politically among others
um
and
again this is where uh concentrating on
having fun is real important
um
i have never understood where the idea
that feminists were humorless came from
but
i find when i go often now to college
campuses and say that i'm a feminist
they as people assume students assume
that it means i'm a lesbian
and i'm the reason i'm confused about
that is
when i first identified myself as a
feminist in the mid-60s
everybody thought that it meant that you
believed in free love and were a real
easy
life this is not progress
um
[Applause]
my rules are real simple i mean i hear
rush limbaugh saying oh what feminizes
are these humorless terrible women and
so on it to me it's real easy if you
believe in equal pay for equal work
you're a feminist i mean i don't set the
rules real high
um
[Music]
and one of the things you have to
remember about being a feminist is that
we deal with uh
different
attack weapons than most
political groups
the traditional means of attacking
feminists are trivialization and
ridicule
it's not as though they came after you
with baseball bats and announced you as
a menace to society uh they still they
stand there and say things like well i
just don't they see there's anything
wrong when i opened the door for a woman
as though that were what reminds me more
about
um i'm a great believer in uh having fun
but uh i've never seen anything
particularly humorous about either
poverty or violence
which are the major problems of women in
this country today
there are not a lot of yucks to be found
in poverty and violence
nevertheless
i think
the eternal quandary of men and women is
fairly funny and that we should try to
remain
pretty good humored about it
um
ann richards i can tell these stories
now because she's not governor um
uh
as you know texas is always behind the
cultural curve um
and um
the women's movement didn't even arrive
there until the mid 70s so
we were at this very elegant dinner
party one time
i'm not going to do this in my c-span um
um
we're the friend of ours a lovely fellow
who shall remain nameless um
who got to talking about how driving
home from work that evening he had
passed a young lady with it on the
street with the most remarkable set of
drugs
that he our friend the lawyer had ever
witnessed in all his long years of drug
watching
and he described in great detail how
they wiggled and jiggled and bounced and
jones and indeed the whole site had been
so fascinating to him that he drove
around the block for a second gander and
again described how he how they wiggled
and jiggled him bounced in jails
and all the men at the table were
listening with great attention and the
women at the table now there are women
of a certain age here who remember this
you students are too young
uh women used to have children a
remarkable social skill
which was the ability to gaze off into
the middle distance while pretending not
to be there
remember when we did that remember we
did that yeah it was a good one
um
so all the women at the table were
gazing off in the middle distance
pretending not to be there when anne
richards said in clarion domes well
girls have you seen any good dicks
lately
[Applause]
the wife of our good friend who is very
quick on the uptakes at anne just the
other day a pair of balls like
watermelon
shut him up for the rest of the evening
you got to keep laughing or you will go
insane
even willie knows it all right are we
down the last question
and among my friends and parents without
partners we used to refer to it as
crotch watching but we never told the
guys they didn't think it was funny
what
in your opinion will be the
eventual result of congress cutting out
the federal funding for public
broadcasting
[Music]
well
um i always feel a bit like a fraud when
i try one of those prognostication
questions um
i don't think i'm much better at seeing
in the future than gene dixon is frankly
uh and i always when i see those talking
heads on on television confidently
predicting who's going to win the
presidential race two years down the
road i know that i'm listening to
another [ __ ]
um
and so i'm i'm
i wouldn't guess but my
i think there's some stuff you can see
already
uh 15
cut this year 30
next year so almost 50 percent in two
years
i assume that given the publicity and
the cure uh private money will be
flowing to pbs uh in in a compensatory
manner
but i can't see that that would last for
very long
and then of course pbs and and nbr both
get themselves in the same trap which is
the more time they have to spend begging
for money the more they drive away
listeners
which is is really a problem so i i
would expect after a few years they will
really be facing rocky times
um
but
[ __ ]
maybe the democrats will win again who
knows
here's how
[Applause]
molly ivins is a columnist for the fort
worth star telegram where she writes
primarily about texas politics
she also contributes to the nation
harpers and the atlantic magazine and
she's the author of several books
for a transcript of her comments here
please send five dollars to c-span
transcripts
in care of tape writer incorporated post
office box 885
in lincolnshire illinois
the zip code is six zero zero six nine
tonight on c-span america the last fifty
leave the site and abandon it
and we just have no way of knowing that
nothing that's been found
archaeologically so far has given us
even a clue
as to why they left
so there are still many mysteries that i
don't i don't think we're ever going to
find the answers to
and maybe perhaps that's what'll keep
the site so special in the hearts of the
people that visit it
today the c-span school bus crew visits
the little white house state historical
park in warm springs georgia and later
drives on to montgomery alabama
next a roast of labor secretary robert
reich
national economic council chair laura
tyson and health secretary donna shalala
are among those who paid tribute at this
event sponsored by the economic policy
institute
mr reich is a founding member of the
washington-based think tank
syndicated columnist molly ivins is the
mistress of ceremonies
well good evening and uh
welcome to the festivities
my name is jeff fo i'm the president of
the economic policy institute
and on behalf of our board of directors
our staff
and our landlord who's anxiously waiting
for the proceeds of this event
i want to welcome you all here
the economic policy
that's the funniest thing i'm going to
say tonight
the economic policy institute
is now in its ninth year
uh as most of you know it was created in
order to look at policies from the point
of view of people who work for a living
people who in the president's words work
hard
and pay the bills
as jesse jackson puts it people who
take the early bus
and as who our victim today
has put it is a very very anxious class
in america today
those of you who know us
also know that the economic policy
institute has been calling it the way it
sees it for the last nine years
we've published 150 books and reports
we've done conferences
uh done a lot of interviews on the media
and
pursued issues from minimum wage to
trade issues
to questions of health care the whole
gamut of things
pressing the case
every time we can that the people who go
from paycheck to paycheck in america
need at least an even break
along the way we've aggravated some
people in high places including once or
twice our guest of honor
but for those who don't know of our work
we want to welcome you to check us out i
think you'll find us interesting
but we're here tonight to have a little
fun
in the hallowed washington tradition
that is at the expense of somebody else
now shredding a reputation must be done
with a lot of care in washington uh you
have to find people who enjoy insulting
their friends and humiliating their
allies
we thought long and hard about who we
would invite to this occasion when
finally someone in the back of the room
said
democrats and labor unions
so
there we have it here we are
as you can see
the rest uh is probably a little less
than history
uh
the secretary of labor has agreed to sit
here so we can't escape
also we have tricked his uh
loving wife claire dalton to sitting
with him on the
on the dice here to bear witness to the
embarrassment
and the only question is is it going to
be his embarrassment or ours
we also have here
at the dyess the co-chairs of the dinner
to whom all defamation of character
lawsuits should be addressed
both of them are
members of the board of the economic
policy institute jerry mackinty is the
chair uh always has been actually of of
epi in his spare time he's the president
of the american federation of state
county and municipal employees uh and
pack the house again
uh the other co-chair whom i'm going to
introduce now is bernie rappaport
bernie rappaport is a human dynamo
and a great progressive uh among
the many things he's done in his life is
created uh something called the american
income life insurance company
which is an amazing corporation i had
the privilege of addressing his
insurance agents about
six months ago and
it was quite an experience
all of the energy and dynamism that
bernie brings to everything else was
reflected there and it was quite
impressive you also may note that
there's a little bit of
texas here uh going on
uh bernie is from waco texas molly ivins
is from texas cindy sadler our
development director who set all this
thing up is from texas
i don't know a lot about texas i know
that
they have a saying in texas
big hat no cattle
if it means what i think it means
bernie rappaport has a lot of cattle
and
with that i'm going to introduce him
with a story that another texan that ray
marshall couldn't be here tonight
uh told me once and and i may regret
this but i'm going to tell it anyway
it was about the two
poor ministers who were going to a very
wealthy man's house to raise some money
for their little church
and as they walked slowly up this long
driveway
they saw the tennis courts on one side
and they saw the stables for the horses
on the other and then they saw the
olympic swimming pool and then they saw
the golf course
all in this wonderful
landscape and they finally got up to the
top of the house and they decided to
rest on the porch for a minute before
ringing the bell and one said to the
other see reverend what god could have
done if only he'd had the money
well my friend a good friend of the
institute and a friend of progressive
causes everywhere bernie rappaport
[Music]
well i i have to tell you the truth the
only reason that i really am up here is
they had a bunch of labor leaders here
they had a bunch of democrats and they
wanted one rich socialist so i'm here i
just want you to understand where i come
from and um the
but the other reason the other thing is
i really am one who has
does make a lot of speeches and and and
all that kind of thing
but i am absolutely diminished tonight
one of my great heroes is john kenneth
gilbreth and i really wanted to be great
and they're not giving me much time
tonight and i want to tell you i really
i just absolutely
am your greatest admirer and i think and
you have been for many many many years
and i'm so glad to see you the other
thing i um we're here to talk about
bob wright
who is one of my favorite authors and
one of my
favorite people in the whole world
the only thing that has
kept growing in bob however
and i have to admit this
is his ego
you know some of us veer to the left and
some of us veer to the right
but not you robert you're self-centered
[Applause]
you know you're a man who
with apologies to you
falls and falls in love with himself and
he has no rivals
he has a tough job he spreads he spends
hours on the phone advising a
beleaguered president
who's battling political enemies
anxious to replace him
and then when he's done talking to lane
kirkland he still has to run the labor
department
[Music]
[Applause]
he and newt gingrich
have one thing in common
they really do they
it's not that they look alike or
anything like that but they do have one
thing in common
they have both signed book signed book
contracts
the difference is bob that
you spent all the advanced money you had
on shoes for tonight
i don't know what newt does with his
i i never will forget when when he got
that four million dollar contract you
know jim right's one of my very closest
friends and i wrote the washington post
a little letter that letter to the
editor which they didn't run
i said four million dollars not enough
for gingrich
peanut's too much for jim wright
but that's the way it is in washington
the cred president's cabinet can be
broken down into two groups
those that are tried and true
and those that may be tried
and finally finally bob
i'll close with this with you because i
have to introduce molly ivan
manny a little squirt
really thinks that he's the fountain of
wisdom and we're here to tell you
tonight that you really are i want you
to know that
the
the
[Music]
my job tonight is to introduce molly
ivins
who has made more difference in texas
than any other single personality that i
have ever known
and i really mean that those that texas
would not be texas without molly ivan's
we would be even more crooked than we
would be if it were not for ali
but i must tell you she's not a woman of
good reputation
she is a woman who has slept around and
i mean s-l-e-p-t
when she came to texas in about 1969
she came
to work for the texas observer which is
a lonely liberal newspaper in texas
which i am
the i am
the uh what is it the
sugar daddy anyways i'm the sugar diet
of this paper
but we didn't have much money in this
paper for this paper
and so molly was having to travel around
the state
and we said molly we don't have any
money for hotels and she has stayed in
everybody's home in texas and so we tell
her i want to introduce you the girl
that slept around more houses than any
other person ever in the reporting
business i give to you
texas is great molly islands
[Applause]
thank you so kindly
be you know why he's the only jewish
socialist insurance millionaire from
waco texas
all right i'm going to make a few
announcements here at the top of the
deal um
first of all don't worry about a damn
thing y'all are going to be out to see
the end of the
ncaa game
uh numero 2o uh this
roast uh on the counter we are all good
liberals will be conducted in accordance
with the finest precepts of political
correctitude
donna chilelo will be the only person
allowed to make short jokes tonight
ken galbraith and i will be the only
people allowed to make tall jokes
and
we are here uh not only on behalf of a
jim dandy outfit the economic policy
institute but also to
roast a man who fully deserves it
uh robert reich secretary of the
interior uh as you all know
oh [ __ ]
secretary labor one of those things
um
belongs on the rare and endangered
species list before they abolish it
he is one of the last
certified bonafide chicken fried
liberals on earth
which means that he actually gives a
damn about working people in this
country
[Music]
is of course at odds with the new
speaker the house newt gingrich i speak
of the draft dodging dope-smoking
deadbeat dad who divorced his dying wife
newt gingrich
[Applause]
a characterization which i assure you
meets every standard of accuracy set by
rush limbaugh
uh and as long as we have the labor
secretary here tonight i want to briefly
bring to his attention a major problem
um it's something that of course the
labor secretary could address um
the problem secretary rush is your
california mexicans
i should explain that everybody in my
home state believes that anyone who has
an hispanic surname is a surname is a
mexican we don't differentiate between
brownsville and tierra del fuego
they're all mexicans to us and
we have a lot of them in our state and
actually we kind of like them
i did not realize until i was in
california recently that they have a
completely different kind of illegal
mexican in their state
i heard it from the governor out there
they're illegal mexicans are responsible
for the ruination of the california
economy
now my state
had a ruined economy just a few years
ago
and it did not occur to us to blame it
on illegal massacres
[Applause]
texas is very seldom considered humane
and progressive so
clearly an oversight on our part but my
conclusion is just kind of different
kind of illegal mexican out there i mean
in texas we very seldom see those
illegal mexicans heading up the savings
and loans companies
[Music]
not open
god often do we see the illegal mexicans
sell it for investing public funds in
the derivatives market
rarely did we find the illegal mexican
shutting down the defense factory and
them seldom you find them involved in
those big real estate deals wherever
they keep flipping the property back and
forth
but it is clear to me because i listen
to the governor out there that they have
some different kind of illegal mexican
out there in california
people doing terrible damage and i want
you to hop right on the case just like a
duck on a junebug
got to do something about this terrible
thing
now
um
we're going to lead off our roasters
with uh tom donahue tonight
now i had been in great hopes since we
have the secretary of labor here
that we would have a real actual labor
skate and uh brother donahue appeared to
me to be a likely candidate
uh he comes out of the service employees
international union and he's been
secretary treasurer of the afl-cio
re-elected every two years since 1979 to
hell with term limits
and i was hoping we would have a real
good labor skate here you know the kind
with the white shoes and the white belt
in the gold chain what we call the full
cleveland
but no here in washington they don't
appear to come in that uh form so we're
just gonna have to make do with what we
[Applause]
[Music]
have thank you molly for a warm and
generous introduction
i
i didn't know jeff that jerry mcentee
has always been the chair of this
organization
and i would just like to suggest in this
year when term limits are so much in
vogue even with jerry
it may be time for a change
[Music]
i have
[Music]
i am delighted to join you at this
fundraiser for the
d.c shelter for the homeless and
hopeless progressives
i come before you to
not to roast
but to praise
the best secretary of labor since lynn
martin
[Applause]
i first met bob reich
some years ago i had arrived first at a
tv studio for an interview
and
he came next and when he arrived he
explained to me that he was in a hurry
he got me to agree to let him go first
and then he made me feel good about it i
knew he was destined for important
things
when he was appointed secretary of labor
the aflcio issued a statement saying we
welcome the choice and we look forward
to working with him
at the time it seemed like the right
thing to do
he seemed so smart so innocent so
guileless
little did we know
first he hijacked some of our best
people
people who were fine trade unionists who
are comfortable with words like union
working class social justice
but after they've been through the right
treatment they're never the same
they now sit around saying things like
the global village and the work of
nations and the anxious class and some
of them even say worker management
cooperation
the labor department these days looks
like mr rogers neighborhood
they all sit around they listen to one
another they make notes on what the
other person says and then they make
charts to show the secretary it's a
wonderful place
just just yesterday he took on a new
role as the sports columnist for the new
york times
commenting on newt gingrich's affection
for surfing on the third wave
and suggesting that the real difficulty
is he said for those who swim in the
turbulence as the second wave crests and
breaks
all of this from a man who described
himself to the rhodes scholarship
selection committee as an anti-athlete
that incidentally may tell you something
about why you didn't settle the baseball
strike sooner
but surfing along in yesterday's column
bob reich came face to face
with what he has described as the
greatest challenge of the resurgent
liberal
and i must say he met the challenge with
what he describes as a genuinely radical
proposal
that is in a real sense
third wave
it's called vouchers for training
it's enough to warm the heart of any old
liberal
and of milton friedman who first
suggested it in 1961
bob reich bob rash came to office you
can't clap here because i only have
three minutes very very tight schedule
bob rice came to office with impressive
credentials and a long list of exciting
ideas a minimum wage increase of at
least a buck and a half
billions of taxpayer dollars for
training
a one and a half percent payroll
allocation for training
low interest rates high incomes
high performance high productivity high
wages high profits the high five
workplace
now two years later
he hasn't lost any of the impressive
credentials he came with
and all of those exciting ideas are
still exciting
and still ideas
the good news
is that he's been able to translate
legitimate union goals
into the language of the resurgent
liberal and for that we are deeply
grateful
[Applause]
thank you so connie next up robert l
kottner bob cutler co-editor of the
american prospect uh brother cutner is a
arthur as we say in my part of the world
a journalist an economist and just
distinguished all hail and gone
[Applause]
wow
well when we uh decided uh about 10
years ago more
to uh to found a think tank for the rest
of us uh
ray marshall and jeff and
barry bluestone and i
went to bob and
bob helped us get the
economic policy institute going and then
a few years after that when we decided
to found a journal for the rest of us
bob helped get the american prospect
going and
i almost think of him as the zelig of
american liberalism
except that he really makes things
happen he's not just
there and when bob told me he was
thinking of joining the administration
uh he was upset because all the good
jobs had been taken i mean
he was saying to me you know
magaziner gets to do health care
and uh
zoe gets to be attorney general and
lanny gets to do civil rights
and derek gets to be ambassador to
finland and bob said i wanted to go to
the finland station
uh so he settled for labor secretary and
the rumor that he did it in order to get
tenure at harvard is a vicious lie i can
tell you that
bob was not of the proletarian class he
was of the symbolic analyst class
and i said to bob i'm delighted that
you're taking this job because finally
one of us and bob looked at me in that
wonderful quizzical way and he said who
is us
uh
he uh paid a number of courtesy calls on
the international presidents and on on
lane kirkland and tom donahue when he
called me up and he said you know these
guys are pretty good
and i said yeah you should meet some
organizers
i
[Music]
i was a little um
i was a little worried about bob after
the detroit jobs summit because uh
you'll recall this was a summit that was
celebrating worker manager
collaboration and bob was his marvelous
usual self except that
he's the most articulate man i know
and he could not quite manage to
pronounce a certain five-letter word
that begins with the letter u
and it reminded me molly you'll remember
this and
those of you who are older than i am
will remember this of a wonderful bit
that lenny bruce did about lyndon
johnson being coached how to say the
word negro
which was what americans were called by
polite white people in those days and
the bit goes like this
uh
mr president negro and johnson says
negro
said mr resident negro
negro
and he said neutral
so i'm imagining lenny bruce doing rice
mr secretary yoon young
high performance work no no union john
dunlop
well
bob has been uh a great labor secretary
i think beyond that he really has been
the leading liberal public intellectual
of uh of my generation and of his
generation and ken galbraith is going to
be officially handing him the torch
later this evening
i also think that at a time when public
service is degraded and degrading
bob will have left office uh with his
own dignity and that of his office uh
enhanced and i think for that we can be
all very thankful he's also been
the conscience of this administration so
i want to close by presenting a very
special object to bob this is an obscure
artifact that i found
uh i'm told this may be a rumor that
this is actually sung
to the tune of the battle hymn of the
republic and the trade unionists
occasionally sing this and i have a copy
to give the secretary i just want to
read a few lines if it goes like this
you might find this interesting mr
secretary when the union's inspiration
through the workers blood shall run
there can be no power greater anywhere
beneath the sun
yet what force on earth is weaker than
the feeble strength of one it's the
union makes us strong and bob is going
to lead us in this
[Applause]
fabulous um
donna schiller u.s secretary of health
and human services i have known donna
shalala since so
both exxon and donna were still humble
um uh all i can tell you is that uh you
may think you know the good secretary
but unless you have been on a river trip
with her you don't i'd like to introduce
the woman with whom i once caught a dead
fish
[Music]
[Applause]
big hat no cattle
i've got head start though
thanks molly i heard that you recently
went on another river trip with ann
richards
what'd you eat soggy doritos
i'm very pleased to be here tonight
i've known bob for 20 years i've served
in government with bob and i have only
one thing to say to bob
bob
you're no kato kaelin
the only reason i went up uh to cato a
couple of weeks ago was because i saw
bob pode posing for a picture with kato
kalyn i figured if cato kalin's talking
to bob
that means he got through the white
house vetting process
it's great to see you all here kitty
higgins is here
bob that was a real coup having your
chief of staff become secretary of the
cabinet it really helps the president
too
now he's got someone who can close you
out of meetings in the oval office
it's good to see all the union leaders
here
donahue bard
jerry mcintee john sweeney i've been
sitting with the carpenters yes indeed
bob all your bosses are here tonight
it's actually always great uh sharing a
podium with laura tyson but tonight she
has an unfair advantage she's married to
her gag writer
so is hillary
i'm really
glad to see john kenneth galbraith here
hey ken
maybe you and bob can pose for a picture
the scholar who created modern economic
liberalism and the scholar who killed it
all of us have something in common
tonight we're the only people in america
not watching the big basketball game
hey claire for half of us the big game
was last night
you might not know this
but there was a big debate raging at the
white house today over who to support in
tonight's game
the panetta camp
said go with arkansas out of loyalty to
the president
the icky's camp pushed hard for ucla
and california's 54 electoral votes
i just heard
that bob's labor department has broken
down the american workforce into four
distinct groups
the rich
the poor
the anxious
and the very anxious
those americans nominated by the
president and awaiting confirmation
i must say though that since bob's been
down here in dc he has moved uh somewhat
to the right
but for bob it's really not about
politics it's about getting his books on
newt's reading list
actually bob reich is one of the handful
of americans
who spend more time on tv
than watching tv
bob's a good sport earlier this year the
president bob and i were hosting a big
immunization event
but there was a real screw-up
um everybody thought that someone else
was bringing the baby that the president
was going to immunize
well the president looked at me
and he looked at bob
and then he looked at me again
and then he looked a little longer at
bob
finally bob lit out a whale
take donna mr president i've got a beard
it's a it's actually been a lot of fun
to be here um a lot of fun really to
serve in the cabinet with bob he's truly
one of the kind a real giant thank you
[Applause]
this just in arkansas 26 ucla 29.
and next up uh thomas p glenn deputy
secretary of the department of labor i
have carefully looked through his
extensive biography i find that he has
been a sub an assistant a deputy and
associate and under an executive
but he never been the actual thing
here he is still number two about to
make his career by insulting his boss
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
letters
from the american people
to their secretary of labor
the honorable
bob
baseball letters
august 6 1994 dear secretary robert
reich
my name is robert also
my age is nine and my team is the tribe
my grandpa knew bob feller and his name
is robert also
you said on abc sunday that baseball
owners and baseball players must act
like grown-ups
and if kids write to you that you will
tell them to
so please tell them to act like
grown-ups
and tell the republicans also
yours truly robert columbus ohio
a lawyer from texas
writes
dear secretary reich i was watching cnn
when you asked people to write you about
this major league baseball player strike
thing
i hear from some of my sources that
those poor pitchers
are possibly being exposed to radiation
secretary of labor you should launch a
full-scale investigation into the safety
of those radar guns that measure the
speed of pitches
while i am confident in your abilities
you may want to work with energy
secretary o'leary on this issue
in conclusion
i must apologize for forgetting your
birthday one of my cousins also has a
birthday on june 24th i wish you
continued success in your career a fan
of baseball and robert reich
lazarus p.s may please have your photo
love letters
february 26 1995.
dear sir
i love your cute little face with your
pretty blue eyes your lips are pretty
and so is your hair
please send me a picture of you and
janet reno with yours and her autograph
so i can hang it in my kitchen
i am 58 years old but still cute and
desirable
just watching you on the news i hope
you're not married
sincerely anne from delaware
13 1995 dear robert reich
you are such a darling man and have the
best looking face nose ears and lips
for heaven's sake shave that scruffy
beard and let your good looking face
through to all of us looking at you
you have a beautiful face too much to
hide in back of a beard i love you just
the same
i'm 85 years young
wish you well and come to california i'd
love to meet you
uncovered
friend
and finally
dear sir
to introduce myself i'm gary 50 years
old and a hardcore union member of the
ibew for 32 years
when president clinton first appointed
you to office they said you were a
harvard professor i said to myself what
kind of wimp have we got here now
boy was i wrong
i watched you debate old hatch from utah
on mcniel air tonight and you really
impressed me with your stats facts and
figures and calmness you literally blew
the man away
also i want to tell you that in my 32
years of participation in the american
labor movement you are the first man
with your high rank in my memory to
truly stand up for working men and women
of america
i personally want to thank you in your
stand with the labor movement you're the
biggest hero since john wayne
thanks again secretary donovan sincerely
gary from washington state
oh glenn you took the easy out um
next up laura tyson
assistant to the president for economic
policy and also chairman of the council
of economic advisors she is a very high
marketing monk
and on top of that she never hired an
illegal housekeeper
thank you very much
probably most of you expect me to be
funny tonight after all it is a roast
and my husband is well known to members
of the washington community as being a
joke writer for the president and the
vice president he does not however write
jokes for the secretary of labor who is
as i'm sure many of you know a gifted
comedian in his own right and he doesn't
write jokes for me
i've learned to play to my strengths and
even though i share the same alma mater
as molly ivan's we clearly had different
professors
so so i studied economics you know not
the dismal science um
let me uh begin by being serious for a
minute i've had the honor of working for
the economic policy institute and i have
the honor of working for the president
of the united states bill clinton
because of bob reich
we met relatively early in our academic
careers we shared similar arcane and
economically incorrect interests we
talked about such strange things as
industrial policy
american competitiveness
u.s japan trade relations
and who is us a question which bob and i
debated uh i there was an act of
readership of perhaps i don't know
twenty thousand americans who read the
hot debate between bob and me and the
american prospect the president being
one of the twenty thousand americans who
read the debate
bob was always more than an academic
he was a man with a vision with many
visions and one vision was to get his
oxford pal bill clinton elected as
president he succeeded in that vision
and when he did he made a phone call to
my house i luckily was out
my husband accepted the call he and bob
are good friends
and bob said to my husband can i borrow
your wife for a few weeks
this was for the economic transition
team and i have not been home since then
and if we are ever divorced bob reich
will be the first person mentioned as a
correspondent in the case
now bob is not an economist but he plays
an economist extremely well
bob and i share the podium
frequently to talk about the economic
statistics i stand to one side and bob
stands in the center
and bob
i i say things like
the inflation rate is modest
and
stable
the growth rate is sustained bob is a
renaissance man he says this is a
goldilocks
recovery
now in case you don't remember the
goldilocks story he goes on to say
it's not too hot
and it's not too cold
it is just
right
you can imagine who gets quoted
and who gets photographed
after every news conference
now i want to end by noting that bob
himself is a goldilocks figure in many
respects
he's not an old democrat
he's not a new democrat he's just a
plain old-fashioned liberal
he's not a protectionist he's not a free
trader
like the best of us he is a cautious
activist
he's not too rich
he's not too poor
he's part of the forgotten middle class
which he is pointing out almost ad
nauseum is going no place fast
he's not too tall
he's not too short well maybe he's a
little short
he is however one of the most effective
members of the cabinet he is however the
most important liberal intellect of his
generation and he is a great friend
thank you very much
that's just darling laura
um
next up we have john isaacson the great
whitehead hunter supremo mr isaacson uh
makes a living uh ferreting out
leadership qualities uh in other people
for money
and uh by god there's a recommendation
on top of that he has known robert rice
since
they were both small and he was best man
at the wedding
[Applause]
well i gather that bob is hard to
understand in this town
after all he's supposedly
some kind of professor from harvard
although that's not what they think up
there
and
as near as anybody can tell the only
thing he managed before he arrived down
here was a part-time secretary
so it's so hard to explain just why it
is that he's a success in this town
since most people aren't
and i thought i would try to shed a
little light on it
not too much we'd like to keep a little
mystery
but just a bit
and i thought i might do that by
explaining how it was that uh
bob met claire
oh yeah i joined a collection of very
ambitious young americans but not quite
30 years ago some of whom have become
quite well known
uh who crossed the atlantic and went off
to england to go to school
some of them have remained very obscure
and deserved it too
the um when we all arrived it was a very
uh strange place kind of large
fortress-looking old buildings bleak and
dark
and the people spoke a kind of a foreign
language and it took some time to get
clear what was going on
this wasn't true bob he got into it
immediately
he went all over the town had a
wonderful time it also wasn't true of
the president who settled in telling
arkansas stories and
got quite an audience for it
bob went out auditioning for plays
he was a good actor
actually a good playwright good
dramatist good character actor
and he got a variety of roles
and one day about three days after we'd
arrived he burst into my room and he
said i have just met a vision
now i was used by that time i'd known
him for some years i was used to rush
visions
but i had never seen one that he'd met
visions tended to be world history or
the future of the united states economy
they were rarely people
i'd also met a variety of rice
girlfriends at one time or another and
none of them had been visions either
what is more he had a plan he said to me
what our little college university
college needs is a dramatic society now
the college was 500 years old and had
not had a dramatic society up until that
time but apparently we required one
and uh
we then acquired one swiftly and
apparently we put on a play it was
called the private year and it turned
out that it had a role for a vision
in fact it seemed to be crafted for just
this particular kind of
seventeen-year-old vision and she got
the part
we put up signs all over oxford
encouraging young actors and actresses
to apply for it they all did they were
all interviewed at great length and she
did brilliantly
the play was a middling success the
romance the play within the play was a
much longer running success
part of this story has been
that this pair of dramatists have played
out
very well over the years
for the early years it was mostly
romances and fun and wit
for the middle years it tended to be
high drama
with large audiences and bad critical
reviews
in the later years claire found her feet
at northeastern and bob has probably
found his feet here
and the dramas have been less clever and
more wise
and more formidable
used to be he used himself to speak
truth to power
nowadays it seems to me he's found a way
to speak truth and acquire power
and it is one thing worth remembering
about him
that the passion has never dulled it has
gotten clearer
and the power and the truth is for the
use of good
and he understands who your constituents
are
in deep and formidable ways that few men
will put to the test
it is not a mystery why he succeeds in
this town
it is because he has genuine strength
and a clear vision
and he married one too
[Applause]
[Applause]
damn i think that was eloquent um
next up we have miss katherine higgins
uh who is not only assistant to the
president and secretary to the cabinet
but far more important for the past two
years you've been chief of staff to the
secretary of labor
and consequently knows where bodies are
buried
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
when i was asked to participate in
tonight's dinner
i thought this is every chief of staff's
dream
to get to say in public well we all tell
each other in private
but on reflection i realized
what can i say that you already haven't
heard from bob woodward and dave moranis
i knew this assignment would be a
challenge but that was before i saw the
program
how does one measure up
when you're introduced by molly ivins
one of the funniest women in america
and preceded by john
isaacson one of the secretaries and the
president's oldest friends
and followed by barney frank
surely one of the funniest men in
congress and there's certainly a lot of
stiff competition up there
well here goes
i've known the secretary for just over
two years
he made me as chief of staff
even though we'd never work together
a brave man
but then i later learned he'd been
turned down by all those that knew him
actually
i'd met him at a dinner party at senator
kennedy's one evening in the early 80s
when he was waxing eloquent on
industrial policy you'll remember
industrial policy
i listened attentively i took great
notes
he didn't notice and he didn't even
remember
but serving as chief of staff
means you get to know someone very well
all their habits
all their idiosyncrasies all the things
they like and dislike
and now that i'm no longer working
directly with the secretary maybe i can
share a few of these secrets from my
successor
first of all he loves eminem with
peanuts
and if stealing pens were a felony
he'd qualify for three strikes in your
route
when you sit next to him in a meeting
bring a spare pen
because he will always borrow yours this
is a this is a bad habit that followed
me to the white house just today
we were sitting in a meeting and he
reached over and borrowed my pen
and then keep an eye out for his little
black book
you know you're in trouble when he pulls
it out and starts going through the
latest notes he's made
these conversations always start with
i just want to go over a few things
and then you realize he never forgets
anything
but working for bob reich
is like working for a celebrity
he gets a lot of fan mail as tom glenn
has always already shared with us
people are always asking for autographs
offering their views on the economy on
corporate welfare
on the president or in congress
some check to see if he's a long lost
relative
one gentleman wrote to inquire if the
reich family had ever lived in newark
could it possibly have been your
grandfather dr henry reich
who repaired a hernia for me in 1937
different family
another elderly gentleman from
california inquired
are you related to william reich md
stanford
or bill reich berkeley
the gentleman signed his name and then
added age 81 senile
p.s excuse writing bad hands bad eyes
but you have to travel with the
secretary to really know how famous he
he is
some of you may have seen the network
accounts of a press conference the
secretary hall to announce the
statistics on injuries and deaths at the
workplace
as he was launching into his report
the department's seal which hung on the
wall behind him came crashing to the
floor
after a startled moment the secretary
resumed his presentation
and then the fire alarm went off
disrupting a news conference
and forcing the evacuation of all
present the secretary the audience the
press
talk about workplace safety
this is one press conference that got
wide coverage
a week or so later we were traveling in
california
secretary and i pulled in the hotel
garage and headed for the elevator
the secretary was approached by the
parking attendant who greeted him with
great enthusiasm
i know you
the secretary smiled knowingly
you're the guy that almost got hit by
that sign when it fell down
on another trip
we raced to make a plane and were the
last on board
the flight was full
secretary made his way with some
commotion down the aisle to one of the
few remaining seats
his staff followed and sat a few rows
behind
one of the passengers turned to the
staffer who squeezed in next to him and
said hey i recognize that guy
tell me
what's it like to work for leon panetta
by the way i'm sure you've heard about
the anxious class
but you probably didn't know that this
is a term that really refers to the
section of the plane where the right
staff
sit when they travel with the secretary
i can personally attest to how much the
secretary has grown in his job over the
last two years
in the beginning some of us gave him a
chart
to help him memorize the labor movement
aft nea cwa uaw iud p-e-d-i-u-d-s-e-i-u
i-l-g-w-u ufc w afl-cio asks me
he looked at it put his hand over his
eye
and proceeded to read it
letter
one letter at a time
like one of those eye charts that i'm
thomas used
a
f
a f s
c
me
but his vision checks out perfectly
people say to me now it must be
difficult to move from the white from
the labor department to the white house
actually it's it's really not been that
hard at all
after working with the secretary on osha
minimum wage skill standards welfare
reform re-employment school to work the
dunlop commission nafta gat the coal
strike the baseball strike the middle
class bill of rights strike replacement
on and on it's been easy to work with
the rest of the cabinet i discovered
when i went to the white house there's
no time left on the president's agenda
for anything else
[Music]
i just wish that dave moranis had
written his biography of the president
before being working with bob reich i
would have known what to expect
as moranis reports
reich is a formidable character
with his piercing blue eyes his curly
black hair his quizzical hectoring
nature
and to quote john isaacson he was a
cartoonist funny quick actor director
academic he could type at 80 words a
minute
now up to 150 i'm told
on an articulate essay on something
well i didn't have dane moranis as a
guide but i did have miss lee
one of the secretary's former teachers
and as i re-read the letter
to the secretary that she wrote two
years ago when he came to office
i just
recognized how much ms lee
was correct about her favorite pupil i
think you'll agree
our secretary of labor hasn't changed
much since he was a student in meet ms
lee's class
dear bobby
i'm writing to congratulate you on your
rise to one of
fame and power
i hope your position will bring lots of
happiness and personal satisfaction
now i know we have at least one person
in the government who possesses
integrity intellect and a sense of
history
you may or may not recall that i'm not
easily awed and i like many others and
anything but dazzled by washington
on a more personal note when you were my
student i did respect your intellect
your willingness to work and your
leadership abilities
i have not however
the things endeared you to me the most i
loved your wit your joy of living your
earnestness your curiosity your
sweetness and your sense of total
correctness
you are just really a great guy
would you believe that i can still
recall specific questions you asked me
in class
but must leave what's going to happen
when all the oil is used up
the way you tilted your head and that
funny little dance you used to break
into at all of our dances
so bobby reich to you all the best you
have it but remember to always to treat
your gifts with the same sense of
humility that you have so far
that's how great kids become great men
and i think we can all agree that
tonight in honoring our secretary of
labor we are celebrating a great kid who
became a great man
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you darling that was terrific uh
next up a fella named barney frank he's
a congressman from massachusetts
he's funny he's smart
he's gay and he's a damn fine public
servant he has a record that proves that
he cares more about the common people of
this country than he does about large
corporations
and people of great wealth and big money
uh congressman frank i would like to
apologize to you on behalf of some
people in my state for representative
dick army
i also like to point out that the dumb
son of a [ __ ] was raised in north
dakota
thank you molly but
i appreciate most of what you said but
uh that bit about being with the common
people not the corporations if you're to
wait until after my fundraiser next week
i would have appreciated it
we're running on the right so i'm going
to speak slow i'm going to speak quick
i'm going to try to do that
the problem of course is if you looked
at the schedule they have 18 people
scheduled to speak tonight and they tell
us all to hurry um they they selected
the speaker list with all the discipline
of bill clinton doing one of his
speeches and they said no to nothing and
nobody
but i don't mind because frankly
come up here and be funny about the
secretary of labor is hard enough but
with rice it's particularly hard it's
not like it was like willard wurtz or
somebody who was a real sense of you
know
the comic you could tell a lot of jokes
about some previous secretaries of labor
but he's rather more boring than most
although
i did find that he's a very good actor
we did a uh a play together uh in a
couple weeks ago it was a typical
washington carefully put together event
donna charella and i played husband and
wife a perfect washington uh
approach you think but mr rice was very
good and ever since
uh people now have been able to to get a
fix on him they think of him as the
sonny bono of the clinton cabinet
i am also honored to be here with uh
my former
faculty member ken galbraith and it's
very important to have rice and
galbraith here today because
it teaches you a lot about economics and
statistics remember that on average they
are five foot nine galbraith and rice
actually we are going to have them stand
here later and illustrate uh
income in america what's happened to
income distribution
uh on average we're doing very well
[Applause]
they said we aren't hurry and they're
explaining the joke to gal but he'll get
it on his own
he made 85 years without your pal leave
the guy alone
i know it's my diction but ken didn't
understand me when he was much younger
so this has nothing to do
with age
but as i said there's not a lot you can
say about secretary right she did
he's got a great sense of history he
arrives in washington to be the
secretary of labor
when this bunch takes over kind of like
getting to syria to open up the bene
brit office just about
at the right time um
they're not too fond of them
and they're moving further to the right
you may have noticed that newt gingrich
yesterday announced that he's going to
go even further to the right than we
have been on gays in the military newt
is opposing now the don't ask don't tell
policy and i realized what the problem
was he used to before don't ask don't
tell and then they explained to him it
does not apply to connie chung and his
mother so if he can't get
[Applause]
if he can't get the benefit of it he
figures uh the hell with it
i did like listening to the letters that
tom glenn and and kitty read i like
particularly the one where uh and
they're being very clever not giving you
the names but i thought it was very nice
that strom thurman asked about his
grandfather i thought that was a you
didn't know he had such good bipartisan
appeal across the board the one from
nancy casabaum you probably shouldn't
have read but uh
i
we probably aren't paying much attention
on the other hand i am really glad that
we have this because this is on c-span
that's why they're hurrying us along
about 18 people hurry up but um
it's very important because we have to
change people's image of washington they
read about washington and they think oh
they give such a glamorous life these
people they're down there on our money
and the labor unions are down there and
the dues are the members and what are
they doing they're out there having such
a good time etc and then they see this
dinner and it's like
the story of a man that was a drunkard
and and one day his wife come in and
says oh this is terrible you're out here
having a good time and he makes her
drink some scotch and she says this
tastes awful he said see you thought i
was enjoying myself so i want america to
know
i want america to know they've seen this
tonight you can't possibly think any of
us would rather be here than not
but
[Applause]
this man
this man controls a lot of money for
these people so that's why they are here
the only question we would ask is why
are you watching is there everything
nothing else
that's good on television
and with that
[Applause]
with that i'm going to turn this back
over to molly evans molly ivan's our
answer to robert novak
bob novak
bob novak shows washington is a very
interesting place where else does the
political community have a pet rat that
it can call all his own but
i'm now going to turn this over for the
rest of the evening we are delighted to
have the secretary here it is true
that
he will go down as the secretary of
labor in under whose regime the baseball
season was screwed up very badly
striker replacement
the stimulus package all those we got
through the house i don't know what
these people did with it over in the
senate
but we do have one thing that we'll
close together because we have had our
differences but as we
contemplate
the group that is now in power in
washington
who are on the verge of giving the
wealthiest people in this country a big
tax cut as an easter present
we all understand why we are here
together and barbara has as has been
said but an extraordinary spokesman for
the
principle that the government has a role
both in promoting the general prosperity
and in advancing compassion and he's one
of the people who is refuting the
terrible lie that those two are at odds
he shows in a very sensible and
consistent way how they reinforce each
other and that's why we're here tonight
[Applause]
[Music]
the reason they take no prisoners in
massachusetts it's because i don't have
the space for them
[Music]
uh next up sydney harmon he's a threefer
he's been in education he's been in
government he's been in industry
and it hardly gets more exciting than
that and uh
on top of that he is a full-blooded
bluebelly good guy
[Applause]
[Music]
after an hour and a half of this rubbish
i think it's time someone rose to the
defense of robert reich
i've known him for the better part of 20
years
i knew him when he taught at harvard
i would come to
that little school occasionally to
lecture and to participate in
a modest program i had
i had funded
my uh
my best recollection of its title was
technology
the universe and human development
something
quite easy to get your mind around
i recall that i was never there at
harvard for any function any purpose
when robert reich did not somehow appear
when he did not
break away
from the urgent work he was doing there
to listen to me to applaud me to embrace
me
and i knew that he and i would forever
be the closest of friends
when we served together in the carter
administration
i would come over to the federal trade
commission
to visit with uh
mike perchick who was then running it
and bob reich was the policy maven at
the ftc and i would invariably stop to
see my dear friend
and he would invariably stop his labors
to visit with me
and at the end of our visit he would
invariably embrace me
i tell you my friends there has not been
a secretary of labor since francis
perkins whom i have not known and
visited
in her or his office
and i understand so well
why the exigencies of this work
have made it impossible for bob
to receive me to
spend a precious moment or two
with a dear dear friend
but tonight tonight was wonderful it was
touching it was memorable
it will sing in my memory forever i was
in a reception line
and as i approached him i saw the
inevitable aid whisper in his ear and he
turned to me and without
pausing a moment
he snapped his finger and said
we know each other
we've met
aren't you married to congresswoman jane
harmon
for all of that
i come here to defend him with this kind
of a defense who needs a roast
[Applause]
all right team arkansas 45 ucla 50.
is this a trend
consistent next up we have morty barr
who is the president of the
communications workers of america and uh
just a personal note cwa is one of my
favorite unions you know there's unions
and there's unions
i'm sure it's coincidental but cwa is
largely full now
[Applause]
[Music]
you know for the past two years
bob has gone around the country talking
about how in his administration
the occupational safety and health act
has been
administered totally impartially
your status in life mattered not
so you probably didn't know this but
even president clinton
has been fined under osha
the last time he played golf he hit a
few too many spectators
now bob rice is one hell of a smart guy
just ask him
better yet
allow me to read a court transcript i
happen to get my hands on
it seems that bob got a speeding ticket
uh while he still lived in cambridge and
decided to go to court to contest it
and a transcript reads like this the
judge
mr reich
now that you've been sworn in
please state your name and occupation
for the record mr reich
my name is robert reich
and i am the most brilliant political
economist in the world
the judge
mr reich
don't you think that is a bit of modest
mr reich
your honor i am under oath
now bob writes the kind of books that
some say are hard to put down
but once you put it down you can't lift
it
and some criticize bob for having spent
his entire life in the classroom
but bob is the first one to point out
that argument is academic
but there are political perils to
spending your professional life in the
ivory tower
as some clinton appointees were worried
about their nanny problems
bob spent a few anxious weeks back in
1993
scurrying to account for his overdue
library books
and by the way bob that big sucking
sound you heard on your way over to
dinner tonight
wasn't the american jobs going to mexico
it was the republicans flushing the
labor department's budget down the
toilet
bob i'd love to say more about you
but the republicans rescission bill cut
70 percent of the funding for my remarks
so i'm going to have to stop now
but i just want to remind you
that stature
is measured in accomplishment
and your accomplishments as secretary of
labor will cast a long shadow
that those who follow you have to walk
in for years to come
and i am proud to know you
to work with you and honor to be among
your roasters tonight
[Applause]
hugh galbraith
john kenneth cobra
here's the paul m warburg professor of
economics at harvard university and also
the finest product ever produced by
ontario agricultural college
he has served presidents from fdr to lbj
and on beyond that
uh however in texas where we pay
attention to family he's known quite
simply as jamie's daddy
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
my friends
i come here
from the university community
from which bob reich emerged
i bring
our affectionate greetings to you both
but i come
with a serious question
from my
community
how did rob reich
given his academic labor record
ever become secretary of labor
rice
as we knew him in cambridge
had no respect
for union rules
for the rules to which all good
academicians are expected to adhere
these rules call for a strong
unrelenting commitment to leisure
is from this
it is held
that comes the time
for thought
from this thought in turn comes books
but not more than one every five or ten
years
these books should not be widely read
so red they are an indication of
a mask for
deficient scholarship
pandering to the public
according to the rules the
unintelligible
speak only to the already informed
these rules call also for a firm
avoidance
of policy recommendations
these
could be controversial
and verge on
politics here to repeat
are our union rules
and these my friends
are the rules that reich
ignored
some would say
held in contempt
he wrote
and he was read
he urged
and people were persuaded
he was even
even politically involved
and now this man of all things
is secretary of labor
where
as we often ask these
days is the voice of the af of lcio
and how do you react my liberal friends
if i can use that for
a forbidden word
you have a strikebreaker in your
presence this evening
it is fitting that i came down from
cambridge to warn you
you are warned
i'm bob
you understand
that i do this
out of affection
out of love
because i don't want you to be treated
as a strikebreaker should be treated
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
he's just so cute
uh jerry mackinty international
president of the american federation of
state county and municipal employees is
a man with a terrible conflict of
interest
every time the administration reinvents
government he loses members
nevertheless he's here to speak up and
we welcome
[Applause]
thank you very much uh molly
uh let me also announce uh
ucla 55 arkansas 51 so that you have
that score
now
it's my pleasure and and privilege to be
here tonight
with
bob reich
now
any number of speakers have come forward
and some have roasted bob reich and
some have said words of honor
about bob rice
but i think it's important that bob
understand
that this doesn't have anything to do
with him
this has to do with raising money for
the economic policy institute
bob is just a shill as we would call
that
it's important to also note
and to
to bring forward a degree
of humility to bob reich with some
people think is
absolutely necessary
but
the last time the democratic leadership
council
held a dinner
such as this
they raised
1.5 million dollars
at the last figures that we have bob
we have cleared four thousand dollars
and i
i wanted to make sure that
that you knew that
uh i was also told that i was due to
come up here
and read a letter
from
president clinton
about bob reich i'm not sure what all
this means but i never got the letter
now i don't know whether that has to do
with the president's feelings about you
right now
or whether or not that is just another
example of the clinton administration in
terms of being right on top
of the problem in the subjects
i watch the speakers too as as they came
up
tonight and
looked with awe
on kenneth galbreath
i thought that he looked like abraham
lincoln as a matter of fact
john
is it john what's your best friend's
name
john isaacs now i thought he looked like
thomas jefferson and delivered a speech
like that as well i thought that was
absolutely uh terrific
i'm glad that molly uh came up here
uh and was the emcee
i've had many
entertaining nights but this sure hasn't
been one of them
and it's been one of the longest uh as
well i recognize bob
cutner
a wonderful progressive and he told me
if i would mention
that there are cartons outside of the
american prospect
and if anybody wishes a subscription uh
there's a lady out at the desk
bob reich
not to be belittled by kutner said that
his seven books and 700 articles
uh are also out there as well if anybody
hasn't read them
and i'm sure that everybody in this
in this audience has read all of those
books and articles
when
i was first asked
uh by the clinton administration after
the president
uh had won
the election and was still out in little
rock and they they they called a number
of people i know they they called tom
donahue and
lane kirkland and folks like that
and they asked about uh bob reich
uh in terms of being the uh the
secretary of labor
and uh
i must say with all due respect i said
well who is
bob reich
and then they they went on to explain it
to me
and
they said that it is
increasingly important that we have a
secretary of labor that has the ear of
the president
now i don't know quite how he does that
and they said we shouldn't have any
short jokes but you know the size of the
president you know the size of bob and i
don't know how he ever gets to the ear
of the president
now i also
i listened to kutner talk about
union
and we all did go through this in the
american labor movement
we weighed it with baited breath
that when would be the first time
that you could actually say
that word
union i mean you had all kinds of other
descriptions for it
uh i thought the first time he said it
was at the flcio convention when we were
out in san francisco now he may have
you know uttered it earlier to his wife
or to some close member of the family
but
we never heard it
uh but i thought that was cured
i really did and then um
we all received one of these tonight uh
at our places
and it is uh the uh
words of robert reich 22nd secretary of
labor
appointed by president clinton and we go
through i don't know how many
words and paragraphs here
but i do not see
the word union
any place on this page
now we had hoped that you were cured
but uh i guess maybe it needs some
reinforcing
i would also like to call to your
attention since molly uh gave me this
introduction
that uh and i think this is incredibly
important when you're talking about the
secretary of labor and his achievements
he has been able to do a lot of things
and we're well aware of them but one of
his prime achievements is that he
streamlined the department operations
and reduced the staff by a thousand
employees now i think that's a
tremendous a tremendous tribute to the
secretary of labor to to be able to be
able to do that
uh as we all do know
uh
he is indeed an academic scholar
uh as well he has come forward with uh
so many ideas for bill clinton uh
probably not as many as bill clinton
came forward with but many many ideas uh
i particularly liked uh the way he he
grabbed on to that id and it really took
off particularly the white house liking
it when he started talking about
corporate welfare
and took that big step and the white
house was so proud of him
that he did that
sisters and brothers i agree with bob
reich almost all of the time
but we rarely see eye to eye
on anything
but indeed
being here tonight for me
is both
an honor and a privilege an honor and a
privilege to say a few words and have a
little fun
but an honor and privilege to introduce
uh the individual we're here to kind of
roast uh and toast
and so without further ado
it is my pleasure to
introduce to you indeed a man who needs
no introduction
but having him heard speak on several
occasions he sure could use a conclusion
the secretary of labor bob rice
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
i want to thank you jerry for that
really wonderful introduction i'll tell
you of all of the introductions i have
had
in washington over the past two years
that without a doubt was the most recent
it is great to be here i i i want to
tell you it is great to be here in this
room
with uh the last
liberals in america
all of us here today
what we ought to do in the future is
never get together in the same room it's
dangerous i mean think what what could
happen
uh i volunteered to be roasted tonight
to uh to help keep the flame alive as it
were
but i i must confess i did and
enjoy being cut down to size
ken galbraith is long overdue for this
sort of thing
i'll tell you only in washington can one
be roasted by friends
while being skewered by enemies
at harvard you're skewered by friends
and roasted by enemies it's a
actually a university i i want to set
the record absolutely straight and ken
almost got it right
a university is a perfect preparation
for the life of washington for the life
of politics because politics and
politics it is dog eat dog
and in a university it is precisely the
reverse
[Music]
uh
ponder for a moment our great public
servants who have come directly out of
college uh out of college teaching uh
phil gramm
uh dick armey
uh newt gingrich
and me
uh
there there's a pattern there somewhere
i
i don't know where but you have to
search for it
i i would like seriously to thank each
of you who have spoken so eloquently
uh this evening
when i hear the name jerry mackinty
three words come to mind
uh cool
calm
and collected
people say jerry has a fair amount of
clout with the president i'll tell you i
never revealed this before jerry i
thought you were going to reveal this
when you talked about it but it's really
jerry i have to thank for my job
because he
was the guy who went to the president
and said mr president
we need a secretary of labor who will
represent the little guy
the president took him very literally
but
the thought was there and and i
appreciate that but back then when i
first took this job many of you said uh
what does rice know about the labor
movement and and to be honest i really
did have a lot to learn i thought afscme
was a supermarket chain
i thought corpus and trunk were skin
diseases it's a
and that morty bars or morty's bar was a
place to go to have a couple of
boilermakers actually i
i've heard morty referred to by the way
is mr collective bargaining and i've
come to really
cherish his advice and labor management
disputes and he never hesitates to give
it and give it
and to give it and uh
in fact it was it was morty who called
me last august and said uh bob there is
a quick
and easy strike for you to settle a
baseball just get right in there and uh
make a name for the president and while
i rely
on a lot of
people in organized labor for advice
i want to say there was no one i count
on more
than tom donahue
and uh it was tom donahue who i called
two years ago before an interview with
the new york times and and i said tom i
need
uh i need your your sound
economic advice in fact i need you i
need a sound bite really uh on labor's
role in the new workplace and and he
said well bob the jury's still out
uh i didn't
i didn't realize that he meant the jury
was out on me i i thought that
that was the bite that you were talking
about
and he was the one actually
this is not well known and if you could
keep this in this room
i would appreciate it tom dunn if
donahue was the one who told me that i
had to support nafta
uh at least that's what i thought he
said i
with that new york accent it's it's
sometimes hard to hear you tom i
when you said you don't have to i you
don't have to
you don't have to
speaking of baseball actually
uh adonis shalala and i have been
competing uh for the same position on
the cabinets off the softball team
shortstop yes that's right
uh the president took the two of us to a
baseball diamond uh and decided that he
uh needed to use replacement players
that's when the whole
strategy
began actually donna came from uh
wisconsin to dc where her greatest
achievement
and people don't really know this was in
coming up with the tough new state
slogan in wisconsin eat cheese or die
you see it on the license plates out
there now it's a it's a powerful it's
really a very it's a brings tears to
people's eyes and
and now that she's secretary of hhs her
public health slogan is eat cheese and
die
same thrust but a slightly different
message
let me say something about ken galbrais
the absolutely brilliant
economist
let me give you an example of the kind
of advice
that ken has given president clinton
uh
in the interest of streamlining the
white house workforce
ken recommended uh several months ago
when we were going through remember the
reinvention effort he recommended the
president replace
eight 20-year-olds with two 80-year-olds
it was imaginative and it was one kind
of thing that the reinvention task force
caught on to ken and i
it was much cheaper that way
you know ken galbraith is the person who
coined the phrase
conventional wisdom
uh ken is the first person to ever use
the phrase
conventional wisdom
conventional wisdom
at least that's what everyone says
is the
phrase
now to the congressman from
massachusetts i i have no trouble
pronouncing his name
barney
uh
oh how i missed kitty higgins until
tonight that is
i like to think that i have not lost
a chief of staff but i have gained a
white house
that's how we talk about it at the labor
department
uh
now is if as if one person from the
white house was not uh
enough for this kind of event
you guys had to roll out two
laura tyson
one of the few others associated with
the economic policy institute who
managed to land a full-time job and
we're all very excited about that laura
allen alan greenspan and laura tyson the
the sunny and share of macroeconomics
it's
uh but but there is hope for alan
greenspan look uh look at what happened
to sonny you can you can ascend the
ladder
and thanks to
i want to say to the man who
to this day
is the most famous american to graduate
from the oxford class of 1970
a household name you you know him john
isaacson
you know there is a plaque
at university college oxford that reads
john isaacson slept here
it was the only thing he did there i was
there at the time
sid harmon sid harmon is a a real
a real renaissance man sid where are you
you're still here
sin is left
uh
but i don't you do you know you know the
connection between sid and uh and and
the speaker i mean how could anyone find
a better speaker harman kardon
you know about harman kardon speakers
right now in this town
right now in washington it's easy to
find a better speaker i mean you
and bob cutner
when are you going to get a real job bob
i can't stand i'll tell you these these
academician author professor commentator
types get out in the real world work
like the rest of us
find a job for crying out loud
you know for years before i got real
work uh cutner and i made a living
blurbing on each other
bob would write a book i'd blurb on it
uh he i'd write a book he blurb on mine
uh
uh
so who are you blurbing on now bob now
that you don't have me to blurb out
anymore huh
oh bye and speaking of blurbing
the queen of blurbs our hostess molly
ivins
[Applause]
the rosie the riveter of american
humorists here here with us dry
urbane
sophisticated wry
words that have never been used to
describe molly and they never will
a tom glenn is he still here tom put up
your hand
deputy
secretary of labor a man whose motto in
life this is actually true
i'm not making this up the motto is
quote and he told me when he came in
quote don't write when you can speak
don't speak when you cannot
don't nod when you can lift an eyebrow
and don't lift an eyebrow unless you are
completely alone
uh a true boston politician it's uh
[Applause]
i would like to actually pause just here
for a moment and introduce my wife
claire dalton claire
[Applause]
and claire i would like to thank you for
taking the time to write and disguise
and send all of those sweet love letters
that tom read when he was here
as you know i need a lift like that
every once in a while our boys adam and
sam
uh accuse me of not being up to pop
culture well whose kids don't you may
not have seen this
but they were so proud recently and
donna schiller referred to this uh when
a picture of me showed up in the
washington post uh following the
gridiron dinner not too long ago and i
was there with cato caleb reed with the
work that his institute had been doing
[Applause]
i wanted to be very frank and forthright
about it i
the
the we posed for a picture anyway he was
he was big about it the cato institute
the heritage foundation american
enterprise institute uh these are some
of the groups that epi was founded to
counter balance and and uh they're
called think tanks
americans uh really are in awe
of the fact that there are people in
washington believe it or not who are
paid to sit around and think deep
thoughts
uh there are actually four of them
uh think tanks that is i
uh but epi is the exception i was
proud nine years ago was at jeff
uh to play a role in helping to found
the epi
and during the reagan and the bush years
it was a halfway house uh for
wayward economists um
and now it's a halfway house for wayward
economists it's a
it's come a long way since those days
the real reason i have to tell you that
i helped found epi
was because i was looking for someone to
publish my work
uh you know jeff you never did publish
any of my
work in fact i believe i'm the only one
of the founders who hasn't had a piece
published by epi
uh but that is okay i i don't need you
guys anymore uh
i've got the government printing office
now sorry
but i i do have to commend jeff because
he spends a good part of his life
defending the epi against those who
accuse it of being a front group
for organized labor
we're shocked absolutely
shocked
when charges like that are made i i i
i was just handed a note epi has asked
me to thank those who helped make this
evening such a success the afl-cio seiu
carpenters ufcw machinist nea aft
painters steel workers transport workers
uaw firefighters cwa apps me a
p-d-u-m-w-a
act two uh gciu a a bakery workers iue
transportation trade iud and uh ilgw
you don't have to
look too hard to find a union label
around here union union label around
here
uh seriously though the epi has been a
shining light
in some very dark times
and continues to do outstanding work it
is hard to believe
how remarkably fast this organization
has grown
it started nine years ago as a dream
and now has become a major player on the
american policy scene
you can all be proud
of the work you do on behalf of
america's working people
and that's what you're all about
epi that's what this administration is
about
i am proud jeff to have been associated
with the epi
until tonight that is
my association is finished forever
and i but i do look being i look forward
to being back on your board
uh not too soon
it is a tribute to the work that the epi
does
that all of you
would have been out
on a night like this when the ncaa
championship is on television so with
that i will end
so that some of you can get home in time
for at least the end of the game
thanks for the shish kebab
a little
a little momento
or an evening that you probably rather
forget
oh that's great
great stuff
thank you bob uh and thank you all i
want to thank our roasters
the co-chairs of our dinner jerry
mackinty and bernie rappaport and
molly ivins for just a wonderful job
and thank you all very much for coming
drive safely
especially those who haven't paid for
their tickets yet good night
the senate is currently in a recess and
now reflections of 1945 and a history of
the past 50 years
this event was held in early may in new
york city organized by the nation
institute
it's part of a public forum known as the
town hall which brings together people
of varied backgrounds for discussions of
political and social policy
the program runs about two and a half
hours and begins with haywood burns
president of the publication the nation
good evening friends
welcome to our town meeting
45 at 50.
sponsored by town hall
and the nation institute
i'm haywood burns president of the
nation institute which
i'm fond of saying is the intentionally
not prof not-for-profit arm
of the unintentionally not-for-profit
nation magazine
this is a wonderful evening for us to
gather
for some it's
may day
for some it's
you can applaud
for some it's law day and
not on coincidentally for jennifer and
me it's our wedding anniversary so
after the colon it says the anniversary
of almost everything
to lead us through this evening
i'd like to bring on
at this point
our publisher and editorial director
victor navaski
who will present our emcee for the
evening thank you very much enjoy the
evening
thank you
i'm going to introduce your uh your host
your master of ceremonies before i do i
want to thank katrina vandenhuvel and
her staff at the nation
uh in general but also particularly for
the issue that i hope all of you have on
uh 45 and 50. and then we also have to
thank frieda kirshway and izzy stone and
the people responsible for the insert in
the issue that katrina and the nation
staff discovered
now
uh studs turkle hey studs you can come
and stand next to me when i introduce
you because
uh
i want you to
i want you to hear what i say so
i'll hear what he said getting dead
that's right
but
but no kibbutzing studs when i do this
see turkle it's it's not just that
with the help of his editor and
publisher andre schiffer and they they
know exactly what to write about and
when to write about it and to get other
people to talk about it
studs as you know has done books on hard
times in division street and on race and
on the good war
keep talking i like your style
okay
and it's not just that he
uh
was a disc jockey and he's a movie star
an eight man out and that i don't know
if you know about his educational
pedigree but he
he got a degree in philosophy and then
he got a law degree
what impressed me about studs the first
time i met him was i had a book that
came out and i went across
you know you go on these shows and no
one has ever read it and then you come
to chicago
and
there's this guy turkle he's got the
book there and it's all underlined in
yellow
and and he opens the picture he says
listen to this and then he takes some
sentence that you are slightly ashamed
of when you put it down and he makes it
sound like shakespeare
and he says how did you ever
think of that and how did you discuss
now look what he says on page 132 and
then he's got that and then he puts the
two of them together and before you know
you get excited about you find meanings
you didn't know were there
and i came back and i said to calvin
trillin who who had
known who had had a similar experience i
said you know how does how does that
what does that mean he said whatever it
means if the guggenheim foundation was
smart instead of giving people a grant
they would send them to chicago to be on
the stud storkel show and you'd have a
nation of
of successful writers
now
i i just uh finally i want to say that
that the mainstream press once again has
missed the story
everybody in this country is talking
about the evils of talk radio
and of course the story is not that
gordon liddy ought to be kicked off the
air or rush limbaugh or to be kicked off
the air but that stud turkles talk radio
ought to be in every living room in
america
studs
i like the way vic novoski talks
i was thinking before anything to
introduce the distinguished guest
panelists and speakers and reflectors
here
more at length later but
marvin miller
first
director of the professional baseball
players association marvin miller
and might add at this moment the most
successful labor organizer in the
country more of that a nun
cather pollock whose column you know
subject to debate
now you do know her
more at least later
christopher hitchens
who sardonic incisive style you're aware
of
molly ivan's
one and only
theta texas
lone star darling
cornell west
scholarship and funkiness at the same
time
and robert j lefton
who speaks of the numbing of america and
i was thinking we gather here tonight
and i can look out there and i know
you're all of a certain age
most of you
and so you remember what happened 50
years ago
and what happens today and so i say
welcome to may 1st
1945
the year that was
welcome to may 1st 1995 the year that is
and during that half century funny
things happen on the way to this forum
and among those funny things and
remarkable things
happened a week ago from tonight 40 50
years ago may 8 1945
v
e day
and so is the surrender the end of nazi
germany each of you has a memory i know
that it's personal as well as national
mine was in chicago
seven o'clock that night i said to my
host my wife and i were visiting some
people could you turn on cbs
seven o'clock that night
and it was called the program on a note
of triumph by norman corwin
who was the bard of the golden age of
radio
and with the most accelerating hour in
the history of american television radio
i should say
and it was a note of hope as well as
triumph
and it was a remarkable moment
and then three months after that almost
to the day
august 6
1945 a mushroom cloud appears over the
city of hiroshima
and three days over that gratuitously it
appears
gratuitously
it appears over the city of nagasaki
now the cheering for the first was far
more accelerated in the end of imperial
japan and the end of the war as a whole
because something else happened
and the great many people including
myself i'm ashamed to say cheered the
war's over but there was that prophetic
minority among whom many of you were
here tonight i'm sure
who said something is crazy
with this particular discovery
that kills women and kids
and albert einstein the man most
responsible for that in the greek tragic
sense his equation plus the fact that he
saw franklin d roosevelt the only guy
could convince him to set up what
amounted to los alamos and the other two
cities
overseas was albert einstein he never
dreamed we dropped on a human being
and he said
yeah i love to quote einstein nobody
dares contradict you
and he said
i paraphrased badly
everything the world has changed from
that moment on
except one thing the way we think unless
we think in fresh fresh terms were
infrared you may remember a documentary
in the 50s albert einstein walking down
the stairs his secretary of many years
what was her name miss
his secretary
she was not jewish and knew no yiddish
but you heard him say what she thought
was as he moaned hearing with hiroshima
oh way
and
there's einstein
45
1945 the boys come home
and the girls that is rosie the riveter
and their friends are told go back where
you came from the kitchen
and but the seeds of the 60s were
planted then
the gi bill of rights and suddenly
something happens
willie and joe
unlike their parents lived in a suburb
until then the suburbs were where the
rich people lived only and now
there's levittown
and this park forest and they are told
they are middle class
and so 50 years from now everybody is
middle class
20 g's a year or 200 000
and none other
1945 in england something happened
winston churchill the tories were
resoundingly suddenly astonishingly
defeated by the labor party
and england's most
remarkable mp and ireland bev and the
welshman who in debate could cut winston
churchill to pieces
he conceived the idea of national health
insurance
in 1945
uaw stood toe-to-toe with general motors
and now in 1995 uaw's knees buckle
at caterpillars
and so we have scab hood and flower
today in many quarters
in the old days no matter how rotten
things were scabs came in from the back
gate in the dead of night
now they posed before cameras smiling
during a professional football players
strike which is remarkable in itself
two scab teams played one was dallas of
course
and the other may have been denver there
were a horrendous game and on tv we saw
three young yahoos bare-chested in the
cold winter weather with a sign we love
our scabs and i was rooting for
pneumonia
but
at the same time something quite
unique and remarkable has happened
the last place in the world of labor
you'd expect it among major league
baseball players
and if ever there were players
established celebrated stars or rookies
holding the fort
say in a sense solidarity forever it was
the baseball player association and they
won the third strike in a row not one
cross the line real or imaginary
and there was one guy most responsible
the players were great the veteran
players some of them but the one guy
most responsible is one of three men red
barber the preeminent baseball
broadcaster said is responsible for the
changes in baseball the first of the
three
revolutionaries was babe ruth
whose bunionesque exploits made us
forget the crooked world series of 1919
the second was of course jackie robinson
who enriched the color of baseball and
the third was marvin miller who in
effect freed ball players from what
amounted to involuntary servitude
and so when marvin miller was spoken
about by the owners in that first year
at training camps they said to the young
players who never met a union guy watch
out for that guy
he's like a teamster thug in the
pre-carry days and so the kids expected
a guy with a big fat cigar a pinky ring
in shades and they see a guy who looks
like dashiell hammett
and so
i echo jim bowden
the colorful baseball player now turned
writer who said when they told me the
owner said marvin miller is bad news i
knew then he's my man here's our man
marvin miller
[Applause]
thank you for a very kind introduction
studs
uh
i'm going to try to get started rapidly
because
this is definitely not
one of those softball piece of cake
assignments
supposed to make some observations
preferably cogent
observations about major events of a
half century ago
comment on the
mass media's treatment of such subjects
draw some lessons from them
and do it all within a sound bite of 10
to 15 minutes
[Music]
i'm going to
try to make at least a preliminary
small dent in that assignment
if i move if i segue from one thing to
another more rapidly than i should and
less smoothly than i should i hope
you'll forgive me
it's all in the interest of of trying to
get this in in the allotted time
for those of us
who are old enough
to recall 1945
i think it's likely that the clearest
recollections are
those that studs has uh listed
the surrender of germany on may 8th of
that year
three months later
the
atomic bombing of hiroshima
then nagasaki
and finally the end of world war ii
i'm
without knowing for sure
i'm reasonably certain that
observations on these subjects are going
to be made by
one or more of my distinguished
colleagues
so i just want to present one thought
on this first
use of atomic power
as a weapon
because as with
too many
important events
i believe that the mass media
and traditional historical analysis
have utterly failed to educate us
as to their significance
and their impact on ensuing world events
in this case
the relationship between
atomic bombing
and the development of the cold war
the scrambling of international
relationships
several subsequent deadly wars
profound changes in the relative
economic status
of many nations including our own
and much much more
there were other happenings toward the
end of 1945 after the war
and early 1946
which i remember with some clarity
perhaps because of my involvement with
labor management matters at the time
i was working for the war labor board
and i am referring
to the outbreak of a very large number
of strikes
unprecedented in american history before
or since
strikes at major corporations
and in some cases entire industries
between the end of 1945 and early 1946
there were complete shutdowns
at general motors ford
general electric
westinghouse
the entire basic steel industry
most of aluminum
iron ore mining rubber
agricultural equipment manufacture
shipbuilding
food and tobacco plants textiles
petroleum refining
copper leads zinc mines and mills and
much much more
these strikes of course involved
millions of american workers
including many
returning gis
gis returning from the war
and these strikes were pictured
and portrayed
by the press
and the rest of the media
as unions gone wild
as a forerunner of revolution
some
even hinted or more than hinted that
this was a communist plot
to destabilize the american economy
and almost nowhere
did you find any information
which would put these events into a
reasonable context
these industries were almost completely
unorganized
until the mid 1930s
until the formation of the cio
congress of industrial organizations
and the organizing drives
following that formation
the early struggles were for recognition
simply the right of unions to exist and
to represent workers
and those were largely successful
but there still had been no real
progress on wages hours or working
conditions
which were still really at depression
levels
when the war broke out
the national war labor board was created
to adjudicate disputes
president roosevelt extracted no strike
pledges
from the cio as well as the american
federation of labor
wages and benefits were
quote stabilized
which means they were allowed to move
only
in the most modest way throughout the
entire war period
but the pressures
to keep the economy stabilized
had not been applied fairly
or evenly
for example executive compensation was
supposed to have been stabilized in the
same manner as wages
well
this was the
if not the birth the growth of stock
options
and other creative perks
which made
stabilization of salaries a joke
president roosevelt's proposal for
profit limits
got short shrift by the congress
limiting wages was fine but limiting
profits was socialism
an excess profits tax after much delay
was passed
but that too was a joke it had so many
loopholes
cost plus contracts with a vogue
bringing profiteering
and record profits
and all this while workers wages and
benefits
artificially held down by government
fire
throughout the war at a level scarcely
above the depression level
and this was the fuel
which
powered the post-war strikes this and
nothing else
and my point is that
most of the american people who
did not have
connection to unions or these industries
who were dependent upon the media for
information
never really got the picture
of of
what this was an attempt
to bring
to correct the inequities that had
developed
over not just the war period
but
the preceding period of depression
instead
of
of having
explanations as to what the context was
we got
misinformed misimpressive
creating a climate
for the following year
when some of the most repressive
anti-labor legislation was passed by the
congress in 1947
which is still on the books
and which is certainly not an
unimportant factor
in the subsequent decline of the
effectiveness of the labor movement
very quickly uh
just a few remarks about a more current
matter
50 years ago
there was no union in baseball
or in fact anywhere in sports
an individual in 1946
did attempt to organize major league
players
but was unsuccessful
but unionism did come to major league
baseball
and
changed the institution
in a most profound manner
but
one thing has not changed
and that's the consistently poor quality
of reporting labor management disputes
whether in 1945 or 1995
whether in traditional industries
or in professional sports
the baseball dispute obviously requires
more time than
when we have left for me to discuss it
but i'd like to try to make just a few
salient points
not really found anywhere
in the press or the other media
the union organized baseball in nineteen
sixty six
now the picture we get
is that the union has really damaged the
game it has damaged the owners
and let me just give you a few basic
facts
in 1966 when the union was formed
attendance paid attendance in the
mid-1960s
hit a high of 22 million
in 1993
the last full year we have
attendance was 70 million
in 1966 the gross revenue of all the
major league clubs combined
was a little under 50 million dollars a
year
1993 it was 1 billion
900 million
in 1966 the number of major league
franchises was 20.
it's now 28
and growing there'll be two more
in two years
there's been a forty percent increase
in these three decades
forty percent increase in franchises
means a forty percent increase in jobs
40 percent more players 40 percent more
coaches more trainers
more club presidents more scouts
and all of this in a period when the
giants of american industry
were declining
the ibm's the general motors the fords
what used to be united states steel
alcoa
and many others
today employ
far fewer people than in the 1960s
they have far fewer industrial plants
so that in this period of decline in
employment
baseball has been an expanding industry
the value of its franchises can be
gleaned from the following
they expanded by two franchises in
nineteen ninety three
so-called small markets one in tampa st
petersburg in the
uh
i'm sorry one in miami and one in denver
the cost of those franchises was 95
million dollars each
two years later in 1995 they expanded
two more franchises remember this is
supposed to be years of recession in
baseball according to the owners
in those two years the price of the
franchise went from 95 million to 155
million
and still they stood in line
begging for these franchises
to put it in proper perspective let me
just mention that
in the 1960s
when the new york mets
major market
were a an expansion franchise
the cost was two million
six hundred thousand dollars
this is the hardly the picture
of a declining industry
with all of this growth and prosperity
the central demand in this dispute
was the owner's demand for a salary cap
the salary cap without getting into a
lot of detail simply meant
a mechanism to force salaries down
below
the market value below what owners pay
voluntarily
i think that
there are comic aspects which none of
the sports writers did
excuse me did justice to
i don't know how many of you know this
but
there are roughly 1 000
players with major league contracts in
the united states and canada
and
the union
unlike most situations
has input only into
the minimum salary
the union and the owners negotiate a
minimum salary in the major leagues
and that affects roughly one to two
rookies per club each year
in addition
approximately two dozen players
have the right when they're in dispute
about their salaries have the right to
go to salary arbitration
and professional impartial arbitrators
selected by both sides
paid for by both sides
determine the salaries of those roughly
two dozen people
aside from that
all of the 1 000 major league contracts
are determined
as a result of individual negotiation
between an owner and or his
representative
and a player and or his agent
the union has nothing to do with it
the union doesn't even know
what deals are made
until after
the owner
puts his signature on a contract and a
player puts his signature and a copy is
sent to the league office and a copy is
sent to the union
so that in a framework in which the
owner
makes the determination as to whether he
wants to pay a particular salary or let
the player go in other words like the
rest of the real world
the owners complain that the salaries
are too high and the salaries are
killing them
and that's really the comic aspect to
this this whole dispute
which they admit was about
holding down salaries
is occurs in an industry where the
owners
determine
salaries in much the same fashion
as a non-union employer
that is do i want to pay this individual
this salary or do i want to let them go
to work for a competitor
we've all heard of
psychotic
serial murderers who
sometimes write letters to the police
saying stop me before i kill again
we've got serial spenders here
who want somebody to stop them before
they spend again
the the reporting on this dispute uh uh
has just been miserable
you know the union has been on the
defensive the entire way
the owners set out on a course that were
obviously
was obviously designed to prevent an
agreement
the owners were finally found guilty
not once but three times
by the national labor relations board of
refusal a bargain
the union was accused of refusal a
bargain and found innocent
and still the press treats it at best as
a plague on both your houses
but
mostly
the players have ruined baseball by a
stoppage
the union of course has had a really
radical position all along
what it said from the beginning is that
there would be no strike
if the owners would when they had a
condition
if the owners would comply with the law
that was the condition that the union
set
and you would never guess this from
reading the sports pages or listening to
radio talk sports shows or the sports
magazines or the television commentary
or anybody
and what's more the union carried
through on it
once the court issued an injunction
requiring the owners to comply with the
law
the union ended the strike
period
this has been
without question a very principled
struggle
for future generations of players
reporters will tell you about the greedy
players
the greedy players who give up millions
of dollars for a principal
hardly the definition of greed
and of course the writers finally take
the position now that it's over
that the players should apologize
the players
should go to the fans
and ask for forgiveness
these people are just unreal
there seems to be no understanding
of what they have witnessed
and consequently fans and the public at
large
have little in the way of clues
as to what has transpired
i want to close by reading a quote
which is in contrast to all of this
this is a quote
which appeared in the press
concerning an earlier dispute
in baseball
when the player's
unity and principled action
was as effective and
impressive then as now
was made at a press conference
and it was
of course not a quotation from any of
the media
it's not a quotation from anybody from
the union
a statement was made
by charles o'connor
the owner's attorney
and chief negotiator
for the owners at that time
he said and i quote
this might sound strange coming from my
side of the table
but let's not forget
that first of all
baseball is part of the entertainment
business
and second
what these players have just gone
through
is a part of their career
that i believe
they should be every bit as proud of as
anything they accomplished on the field
they have just taken part
in one of the most important parts of
our society
the right of self-negotiation
the union movement
and the collective bargaining process
i hope
that is viewed
as a major accomplishment
and all i can add to that is amen
thank you
[Applause]
i guess what's so interesting
fascinating about marvin miller's
reflections
is that sports writing
like political writing in fact it is
political writing
mainstream writing is analyzed the way
it is
chicago for example a friend of ours a
sports writer whom we both admired
marvin and i
now works for the tree he works for the
tribune which owns the chicago cubs
and his reportage right now is so
different than it was once before it
ain't even funny and i was thinking of
the people he did not mention
the sports writers who did not betray
not simply the union but the
the honesty of the game itself
were women
sports writers
and one of the reasons they are doing
what they're doing is probably because
there is a baseball players union
and so who better to talk about women in
the world today and work and the role
they play
who better well of course you know
catholic politics subject to debate
well that's it kathy the washington post
said if you want stuff that's going on
in the general left analysis
ask cath apollo
catholic
thank you
[Music]
i seem to be quite firmly pigeonholed
here but
we'll see about that
for the last several years culminating
of course in tonight's event
we've been living through periods
thickly strewn with anniversaries and
commemorations
last year it was the normandy invasion
the other day i turned on the radio and
heard assorted callers reminiscing
sometimes with tears about the death of
roosevelt
i find all this celebrating a strange
way of going about trying to understand
history because as we all learned when
ronald reagan went to bitburg to lay a
wreath on the graves of men who had
served in the ss
the script is written in advance it
revolves around themes like
reconciliation the decency of the little
guy
the virtues of patriotism and
self-sacrifice the glorification of
assorted leaders and nostalgia for what
is inevitably called a simpler time
understanding history which tends to get
in the way of nostalgia or any kind of
celebration doesn't have a whole lot to
do with any of this
that's one reason perhaps why we're
gathered here to talk about 1945 and not
about the fall of saigon which is also
having an anniversary this year but
which is hard to fit into the nostalgia
program at least
at least for americans
although in another 30 years who knows
after all we have lived to see the
holocaust routinely depicted as a
triumph of the human spirit and an
opportunity for personal growth so
so
who knows what testimonials will adorn
the milai massacre and the carpet
bombing of cambodia by the time their
50th birthdays roll around
if i were a historian i would now
proceed to lay out a detailed analysis
of world war ii its causes and its
aftermath since i'm not since in fact
like many of us up here tonight i wasn't
even alive in 1945
i'll focus instead on the present
and after all the present is really what
anniversaries and commemorations are
mostly about anyway so i ask
what do people miss in the world of
today that causes them to look back at
1945.
my answer comes to me in a flood of
cliches men in hats and women in baggy
flowered cotton dresses
families gathered by the radio for
wholesome entertainment or a message
from a leader whose sex life was not in
the news although today it might well be
a sense of collective purpose behind the
scrimping and saving and making do the
notion of the good war fought against an
evil enemy and for on the whole
honorable purposes that we did after all
win
a feeling of energy bustle purpose
seriousness danger but not danger like
in europe or asia where the fighting and
the mass murder and the wholesale
destruction of cities was and where even
50 years later a commemorative event
like tonight's is hard to imagine a
sense of hope of trust in big shaggy
ideas like democracy socialism the
people progress government science
if you overlook the part about millions
and millions of people dying most of
them civilians the war era can look
pretty exciting so exciting indeed that
even those left out of the official
history are now energetically reading
themselves back in
i wish i had a dollar for everyone who
suggested that i talk tonight about
rosie the riveter as the precursor of
today's working women
gays and lesbians now discern the early
seeds of their contemporary liberation
in the army's freewheeling culture of
barracks and bars
black soldiers were told help liberate
the death camps affecting the symbolic
brotherhood of blacks and jews that has
proved so problematic today
it's identity politics with a hat a
flower dress and a happy face
and after the war the peace but not the
real actual historical piece that
included suburbanization firing rosie
the riveter giving her job to a man
the continuing of racial segregation
mccarthyism the smashing of labor
militancy and the start of the cold war
no in 1954 in 1945 the peace was all
hope the fulfillment at home of the new
deal that had been put on hold for the
duration of the war and in the world
abroad the hopes embodied in the u n
charter now we've seen that these hopes
were not in fact fulfilled and unless
you believe that the course of national
world history would have been radically
altered had fdr lived out his fourth
term the only reason can be that these
hopes were illusions
they failed to take into account the
real nature of the circumstances
confronting the post-war world so the
nostalgia for 1945 turns out to be like
most nostalgia not the longing for an
actual past which as i've suggested was
rather problematic but for the illusions
it was still possible back in that past
to maintain
when we miss 1945 what we miss is the
dream of a hopeful future the dream of
modernism
from this disappointment flows much that
is wrong with the political landscape
today from the quest for a strong
idealizable president
to the various family values crusades
from the communitarians to the so-called
pro-life movement to the far-right
proponents of the mad idea that private
charity can replace government programs
for the poor
all of these seek in their different
ways to reconstitute the vanished
hierarchically ordered family and
community although the liberal variants
of this creed don't exactly put it like
that in this reading of history 1945
emerges as almost the last good time to
be followed by the fragmenting of ethnic
communities and extended families in the
suburbs in the 50s the campus in
anti-war rebellions of the 1960s the
women's revolt in the 70s and the
temporary triumph of the right in the
1980s
isn't it time though to acknowledge that
it's good sometime to get rid of one's
illusions that sometimes people stop
believing in something because they
realize it isn't true
and if so it's good to stop believing in
it
we hear
we hear a great deal today about the
evils usually held to be fermented by
the left of today's demands for equality
respect and recognition by blacks women
and other smaller social subgroups why
we here can't we all just be plain
americans and here flashes through my
mind another wartime cliche
the platoon of countless old movies with
his italian it's southern farm boy it's
german and it's jew
the answer to the question of course is
that we are not all just plain americans
there is a complex racial hierarchy and
a gender hierarchy and many other
hierarchies as well
why is it bad and divisive and
impermissible and rude to acknowledge
this openly and to make politics on the
basis of this truth
take another example
suspicion of and reluctance to bend to
authority figures
on the whole this seems to me an
excellent idea
and one moreover with a distinguished
ancestry in the western civilization it
supposedly threatens put not thy trust
in princes that's the bible
power corrupts that's lord acton
wasn't the search for a secular savior a
strong man on a white horse what got
germany and italy into trouble back in
the thirties
distrust of political leaders of experts
of men and women of the clergy of the
military of the police i'm not
advocating paranoia but on the whole a
healthy skepticism toward the
institutions of society and the people
who embody them seem to me quite
justified by events
we hear a lot of moaning these days
about how sad it is for example that
america quote unquote no longer can find
heroes among sports figures while of
course it is unfortunate that so many
athletes beat their wives take drugs
sleep with teenage girls with and
without their permission place illegal
bets and so forth was it better before
when these things went on but the public
didn't know
and and when ignorance and the perpetual
wish of america to americans to remain
children for life persuaded millions
that being able to hit or throw a ball
made a man a moral exemplar
aren't we better off not looking to
sports figures for moral guidance
what
what some call cynicism to be combated
with sermons in psychological denial and
various forms of religious and secular
revivalism can also be called realism
and egalitarianism
and the extension of the one-person
one-vote principle to everyday life
would we want to put wife beating and
incest and rape and child abuse and the
other horrors of domestic life back with
those hats and baggy dresses in the
closet that in 1945 was still firmly
closed
no
with all due respect i think we have to
say that the world symbolized by 1945 is
over now both as actual fact and as a
hope
those big shaggy ideas democracy
socialism progress leaders science
family did not solve our problems then
and cannot do so now
in a way this is too bad the way it's
too bad that smoking causes lung cancer
another piece of bad news of which 1945
was blissfully unaware
but
but in another more important sense it's
a very good thing because the death of
those false hopes means we can start
looking around for some hopes better
grounded in reality and in the
circumstances of our own time
it is after all where like it or not we
have to live
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
who said
who said feminists can't be funny
incidentally i don't know why the lights
aren't on for the audience this is a
town meeting after all the idea of that
and i think light should be on you as
well as on us since you're part of it so
i'll be claudius and hamlet lights
no lights he didn't do it
i'll be himself let there be light
nothing could we have like some no i
think it would be a hell of a good idea
because then you're part of it because
that's what this is about
that's the ticket
more
that's it it should be lit more you we
should see your faces as well as you
seeing ours fair is fair after all
i was thinking about the nation itself
and hearing cather
polite and hearing marvin miller i think
people are right for the nation and the
style of writing the substance as well
as the impulse
and there's been a review of
of edmund wilson this morning in the new
york times man of letters indeed he was
there's another kind of man of letters
and that's
chris hitchens
you see a man who has his own style his
own way and the world is as oyster in a
sense writes about concentration camps
or lumber camps when it comes to
environment any subject at hand and here
then christopher hitchens of the nation
ladies and gentlemen brothers and
sisters comrades and friends
welcome to international workers day so
we should not forget
i i didn't actually put mr turkle up to
the edmond wilson suggestion at all all
possible jesus on the stage earlier was
on quite another topic but i'm glad
he did make that comparison because um
it releases me from the promise that i
had made earlier which was that i would
be both short and funny
um
in the name of evan wilson i now cast
this pledge aside
i trust that you've both all of you got
comfortable seats and um
ready to settle down no intention of
being brief
felt feeling rather lugubrious in fact
as well
james boswell very long book
um brilliant biography of dr johnson
probably the founding of modern
biography
james boswell as well as being a very
good biographer and remembered for that
great portrait of old sam that terrible
old tory uh blowhard johnson
not the first out of that name
was in addition to that
a tremendous journalist and very curious
man and observer he would go to things
he would he would always show up he
showed up at the bedside of the
philosopher david hume
as a lot of people did because they were
sure that hume would abandon
his
flinty integrity as the
death watch impended they were sure he
would beg for a priest he would ask for
forgiveness
and he didn't and he kept on not doing
it and boswell kept on pressing him are
you sure you're absolutely convinced you
don't want to do this and
hume said i think imperishably um no i'm
no more worried about what will happen
after i'm
dead and gone then i was concerned with
what occurred before i was alive when i
consider that
i can i've always considered that and
consider it still to be one of the great
statements of stoicism
ever made
however
however under the lash of uh comrades
nevadsky and turtle and others i have
been forced to do born as i was in 1949
a little bit of back to the future in my
own behalf and yours comrades and the
fact is this i've caused some inquiries
to be made i've looked up some old stuff
talked to some surviving relatives and
um
the the the thing is the thing of it is
that
on this day 50 years ago this precise
day
my parents were on their honeymoon
okay you try it
i see some of you are trying there's a
very vertiginous thought to me
that this would be so
and
i'm going to share with you some of what
i think emerges from this
matching without which after all one
would not be here
my
father commanded i'm a navy brat my
father my late father commander eric
hitchens had had in a way a good war
his cruiser uh hms jamaica put the last
torpedo into the scharnhorst the
flagship then of the nazi battle fleet
in the in the um narrow seas
on the day after christmas um 1940
a better day's work than i could ever
claimed to have done myself
but but a tough and a tough day's work
for the old man who had throughout the
1930s consistently supported
the line of uh baldwin
chamberlain
mussolini and franco and who found
himself you see because it's my belief
that the ironies of history occur most
pungently to those who don't believe in
them
and after doing in the scharnhorst my
father was put on the task of running
convoys to
momansk and archangel at a time when the
entire coastline of of northern
europe all the way up over the hump of
norwayskin it was completely controlled
by the nazi war machine and there was no
air cover for anyone who wanted to sail
a ship
all the way up and over to moments
and i like to picture my father as he
didn't like to picture himself as
finally after all the trouble he'd taken
in the service of king and empire acting
as a gun runner to stalin
[Applause]
these are the breaks
for him may 1st 1945 was a kind of mixed
blessing sort of a day
but it was a day off work and i think a
very much needed one
for my mother representing the side of
the family that had emigrated a little
earlier from the that bit
on the german
polish ukrainian
border which had been didn't know
they knew that they weren't hearing
anything from the relatives anymore
um it was exactly about 50 years ago
that they worked out what had happened
to all the members of the family they
hadn't
been hearing from and it was a very a
very bitter day in the day of complete
silence and not not in fact a day i
think on which she
said anything at all these were a couple
whose lives had been
wasted really wasted in the
in the terrible waste of the opportunity
of the end of the first world war wasted
by those who had
written the the pact of versailles who
devastated eastern and central europe
again in the name of it
who'd plunged the world into depression
and into slump which wasted the youth of
both my parents
had uh encouraged or been complicit in
the rise of fascism and brought them out
of slump and depression only
by means of a war economy and another
war and wasted the rest of their youth
and that was for
the lucky ones and then replaced that
regime and that succession of
establishment triumphs with the post-war
austerity people whose whose bitterness
therefore was very very felt very
evident
and who had no target upon which they
could direct it because after all they
had always done is they believed loyally
and decently what they were supposed to
do and had kept the
national pact and the social pact in her
in an honorable way and had been
betrayed for it
um
that sort of moment of bitterness and
futility
is i suppose what would now be described
in the new york times as the beginning
of the healing process
[Music]
is my opinion that the healing process
in this case probably began in 1942
when the red army managed to encircle
the vermont of the cursed salient and
stalingrad box it in
and destroy it
and turn it back and break the spine
of hitler's reich i think that's where
the healing process began
and i remember an old austrian friend of
mine now dad else fisher who was one of
the broadcasters at stalingrad he
he defected he joined the other side he
broadcast in german to the advancing
troops and said don't believe your
leader don't believe a word he says to
you everything he's told you is a lie
he's ruined your country he's destroyed
german and austrian culture
he's destroyed even the uh
the fabric of uh of goethe and sheila
and marx and beethoven and all the
glories of your
civilization don't believe him and now
he's led you into a death trap and if
you don't surrender or come over to our
side none of you will escape i said and
you've been dropping leaflets on us
telling us to surrender
in stalingrad it's a brilliantly written
leaflet probably the best i've ever read
and it says
we should tell you now these leaflets of
yours
turn into ash at 10 000 feet over
stalingrad give up now turn your guns on
your officers
go home don't believe them don't believe
them
but
it wasn't to be
the war had to be fought to the very end
and so as it ended and ended
in that frigid and ghastly manner the
three episodes which i'd like to draw
your attention that are part of the
history of may 1945.
in may 1945
the british government released such
japanese soldiers
as it had under its captivity in saigon
and it reenlisted them under the british
flag in order to put down the vietnam
government which had established a
national government in vietnam
and under this anglo-japanese imperial
condominium uh proclaimed that it would
form a holding provisional government
until the french could come home
and reclaim their rightful territory in
india china
um
that was done with the full permission
of the beloved fdr and the soon to be
even more beloved harry truman
i think it's an episode that ought to be
somewhat better known and better
remembered than it is think of how much
trouble
we might have saved ladies and gentlemen
brothers and sisters comrades and
friends if the vietnamese had got their
long deserved and hard fought for
independence in 1945 think of the shame
also
of all of those who've been involved
particularly in the democratic party
ever since
in denying them that right and using
american blood to shed
vietnamese but i think of the
uneffaceable shame of that
second but slightly more encouraging
that happened it happens to me when i
get into a cab in washington very often
um washington's my hometown
sometimes there's one of those old black
drivers with a hat back on his head and
often a bit of a cigar he doesn't care
about the regulations but what he can
and can't do in his cap
sat well back in the seat he hears my
voice and he gauges the gear when he
hears where i want to go he doesn't say
anything for a bit but i know what's
coming he says um
you from england i say well that matter
of fact yes i am i don't know how you
can possibly tell
and then there's another long pause you
say i was there once and i've had this
conversation a lot of times very often
this was the first time these guys had
ever been abroad very often it's the
first time and the last time they ever
went abroad and they remember man did it
rain
and we had to drink our beer before it
got cold
and boy the food but they said they
remember another thing which is the
first time they'd ever been in a society
that wasn't segregated
a white society that wasn't segregated
this was a time when german prisoners of
war were given a better time than they
were
and they remember it in a in a way that
touches me very very much and i always
say at the end well it was very nice of
you to come over you didn't have to do
that and appreciate it
very much appreciate it george orwell
noticed a mass observation survey at
that point among british um
public house owners
because it was fear that there were so
many british men overseas and the
american soldiers were so well paid
and so much better dressed that there
might be animosity towards them so they
took surveys one of the
old ladies who ran a pub near an
american air base was asking do you have
any trouble with the americans no no i
love the americans love the yanks love
them
always pleased to see them what no
trouble at all i mean no complaints of
any kind no not very nice boys always
fast to buy a drink very nice with the
girls and all that well you absolutely
sure you haven't got any well he said i
will say this but i don't want to be
quoted so i like the americans very much
i'm not sure i care for some of the
white ones they brought over with them
orwell was george orwell was one of the
few to notice this um finding
anyway in in my father's hometown of
portsmouth and navy town there was there
was a big riot the the locals all turned
out of the pubs when the military police
came around to try and drag the
black soldiers back from the bar to the
to the segregated camp and said leave
them alone there you know you're no
better than they are and it was a great
moment in in portsmouth
history and um it it's it's a i don't
know call me sentimental if you will but
um one of the guys who was involved in
all that was mega evers who was when he
went back uh to the united states
thought i'm going to keep my uniform and
keep my medals i'm going to stay in
their face about this
i don't see why i should go back to
segregated sharecropping after all this
stuff and didn't
um and paid the full price for it but
we're in his dead and i like to recall
this little moment anyway
and then another thing happened which is
the hitler's chief of intelligence
reinhardt galen
the man who had run the entire nazi
intelligence system throughout occupied
europe for five years was hired by the
cia to run american intelligence from
then on
i don't know what you think but what i
think is that when reinhard galen was
hired as head of american intelligence
from straight out of berlin and straight
out of the occupation of biola russia
and ukraine and latvia i think something
very bad entered the american system
that no one's really ever been able to
face up to or ask about since something
really bad that we still haven't combed
out or even confronted
and cather mentioned um
the great moment of ich binen bitburger
spoken in the in what gore vidal called
the bright autumn of his senescence by
[Applause]
by the president but and many people
wanted to say well that was uh come on
mouthing off you never know
not completely all there not true at all
the next stop on reagan's european tour
after bitburg was madrid where he made a
speech in which he said
i know there's been a lot of controversy
about the united states and spain in
their time
indeed some americans once came here to
fight in the civil war he said but the
thing is that reagan they were on the
wrong side
in other words a conscious choice
a conscious and deliberate remark uh
showing that the sympathy for fascism
not accidental not anecdotal not a slip
of the tongue but something bred in the
bone
and
i think
also worth
recalling now those three instances i
gave and believe me i could go on and
don't be sure that i won't um
i'm not the only i'm not the only three
of trinity or trio but i think they may
be
they may be i'm going to select them
anyway if only out of consideration for
you all uh the critical the crucial
three because
they they they invite the question that
is in fact inseparable from meetings
like this
and deliberations of this sort which is
which side are you on anyway we have the
civil and human rights
side represented
by what was expressed by the population
of britain despite its leadership in the
in the resistance to nazism and the the
way that they embraced people like mega
evers as guests
when they had really you know one meal a
day
i like to remember that
the origins of the vietnam war
in other words the inheritance the
deliberate inheritance by the united
states of of british and french
colonialism
the desire by roosevelt this ridiculous
hero who's praised uphill and down dale
by sentimental democrats every time you
open a paper or turn a page these days
this old
crook and criminal who wanted and
devoted his life to the inheritance
of degraded european imperialism by the
united states and made it his objective
and got it in saigon in 1945
and simultaneously the inheritance of
fascism the ghost in the machine
taking on that that inheritance inviting
these unwanted guests no part of any new
deal
into the homeland that's what you have
to
remember
and choose between and choose among
because the curtain was raised on all
this a lot earlier than anyone
thought or was told
now also in 1945
in fact this month
a great friend of mine
was released at the age of 13 from
bergen-belsen concentration camp his
name is israel
he's professor of chemistry at the
hebrew university in jerusalem now
a great man
arguably a very great man i'm glad he
has some sympathizers here
founder of the israeli league for human
and civil rights though he wouldn't care
by the way if nobody uh had heard about
him or kept him
founder of the israeli league for human
and civil rights uh
uh unbelievably courageous and decent
person i sometimes call him up and say
how are things going in your neck of the
woods israel he says well
i can tell you there are some
encouraging signs of polarization
i like to make this one of my mottos i
like to try and start every day like i
don't know about you every day i look at
the new york times and see are they
still saying all the news that's fit to
print on the front page are they still
doing that so i okay that i'm still
pissed off with them
every day i also think maybe there'll be
some encouraging signs of polarization
all the same
because in the new york times every day
you find the word consensus is always
used as a plus word
unity is always used as a plus word
everything divisive very bad word
bipartisan very good partisan are not so
good cretinism
[ __ ] nonsense
the building of a false consensus and
the burying of history and the burying
of dialectic every day before your eyes
in the name of the ideology of
objectivity
who here remembers uh hearing ronald
reagan seeing him called a great
communicator in print in a news story
hands up anybody
quite a few
who remembers hearing him call a liar in
a news story
well
that ronald reagan is a great
communicator as a value judgment
that ronald reagan was a liar as an
objective statement of fact
that's why you read the one in the news
story and not the other
and that's the ideology of objectivity
right there for you
so you need the corrective and we may
need it
we may need it sooner than we think
the stench
in 1945 all across europe including the
town in which i was brought up
portsmouth where i could still see it
when i was a small boy
the bomb sites and the rubble in the
wreckage but
not all of it because the stench of 1945
all the way across europe was the stench
of disinfectant being sprayed on rubble
you can't dig any more there's no
there's no point in it there's only
putrefaction and misery underneath you
you can't keep digging if you don't
disinfect it i would say that the stench
of disinfectant sprayed on rubble
the rubble is on top of human remains is
the particular tang
stench
odor of fascism
and we used to in our movement in our
pages and so on say we'd give the title
anti-fascist
to the older comrades to those who'd
suffered and been through it and so on
we never thought i think many of us that
how soon we might have to earn
this great title of honor for ourselves
though we were warned you remember the
end of bertel brett's play arturo ue
when the leader steps forward to the
front of the stage after hitler's body
has turned to carrion after all at last
and says well
this is the thing
that nearly had us mastered but do not
think that that is all you men for
though
we rose up and we beat the bastard the
[ __ ] that bore him is on heat again
and i think the stench of uh rubble and
carrion and disinfectant from oklahoma
is kind of a warning and this time it's
not digging out at the end it's digging
out at the beginning
of a battle with reaction
with the gala knights
and their descendants
and with those who wanted to turn our
our yours my democratic republic
into an empire kkk is kinder kesha
and kusha too
these rebels as they call themselves
these anti-establishment figures are
nothing of the kind they say they're
against the government their lone
pioneers and frontiersmen who are they
where does gordon liddy come from if he
isn't a pimp of the state
an incubus from the national security
system
where does oliver north come from who
dares say this man is a rebel or a
dissident he's an outgrowth of the
government i know sir
i promised you nothing less
what's anti-government
about these extruded forces
of the state
they will when the time comes if it does
come we should take care to discuss it
soberly but if the time should come when
push came to shove these are the people
who would be the fry corps these are the
people who would take orders these are
the people who would be the disciplined
and docile forces
of a government that would of course
always regard them as
deniable and we have been
warned
so i'll save um
much but not uh all of what i was going
to say
say let's be um let's be prepared not to
be hysterical about this let's be let's
be artistic let's be ironic after all
when picasso was visited in his studio
in occupied paris by a gestapo officer
who was told to make nice with him and
there was a canvas of a sketch of
guernica on the wall
the gestapo critic rocked on his heels
in front of it and said that's very good
um
did you do that casa said no you did um
[Music]
we we don't have to be crude we don't
have to be crude we don't have to be
rough but we ought to be
ready to earn the title of anti-fascists
for ourselves and we ought
not to be scared of the fighting words
the alleged
fighting words of others of the of the
scum of the earth of the the fat [ __ ]
like rush limbaugh and the pimps and
pensioners of the state
like oliver north and gordon liddy we
should rather be getting ready with some
fighting words and some fighting
gestures of our own thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
as this
as this meeting
goes along
the nation looks better and better
that is the journal of the nation
when we think of the state of texas
immediately images are revoked
of lbj
john connelly
the air shots texan john wayne
and senator phil graham the finest might
of the 12th century
and that is one face of texas the one
we're most familiar with but there's
another texas been there all along
of maury maverick
of john henry fox
of jay frank dobie
of jimmy hightower who
in meeting have ever met rush limbaugh
could cut him into a thousand little
pieces
that's the texas of molly ivan's
and molly
how can you talk about molly without
talking about humor in politics when she
covers the texas legislature texas liege
it's a metaphor for the country and when
she edited
that muckraking journal worked for the
texas observer with there but the but
the best thing of molly recently she
wrote the forward to a book about russia
and his lies put out by the new press by
the way of andrei shifrin if i get a
plug in there
well molly
said she was attacked by rush limbo
it's like being
gummed by a newt
that is it doesn't hurt but you're busy
wiping the slime off your ankle
here then how could you not like molly
ivan
um i was born
the day we dropped the bomb on nagasaki
um which has always
provided a peculiar anniversary
in my life
um and for all my life world war ii has
been um
the title of studs book it's the it was
the good war
it was the war when we were right it was
the war worth fighting it was the war
when there were real heroes
i'm vietnam generation
and
what
world war ii came to symbolize in my
life was
the difference between ours and theirs
um
ours was pretty shitty
and we didn't win it and we didn't fight
it and we didn't have any fight like our
daddies we didn't fight it like audie
murphy
and uh we didn't have any good choices
there were no good choices
for us in those years
and when
one looks with the or tries to look with
a rather longer eye of history
the difference between those two wars
which certainly defined my young
adulthood
um i think perhaps in retrospect despite
a lot of pain
maybe we'll just call vietnam the
hottest 10 years of the cold war
perhaps because the piece was badly made
at the end of world war ii the good war
um
perhaps for other reasons that those
elders and i can address better
um the good war was followed by
a long long cold war
and
i don't know about you all but um that
has been the reality of
all of my life in america
and
i am
one of those people who suspects that
the only reason anybody ever thinks that
there were good old days is because they
were bad men because they have real bad
memories
[Music]
so i like to look forward and if you
would ask me a few years ago
what i anticipated in this country at
the end of the cold war
i'm not been i am optimistic to the
point of idiocy
uh
but i didn't think i was being
unrealistic to think that at the end of
the cold war
we could
dismantle at least some of this enormous
military apparatus that we could
demand dismantle some of this enormous
national security apparatus with which
we've been saddled which deforms
our government and our political culture
and uh it's not that i thought it would
be the land of milk and honey but i was
kind of thinking maybe you know after
the goddamn cold war is over
uh and we get to you know quit cussing
comics maybe we'll actually have a
discussion about
what we can do
to create liberty and justice for all
uh
i certainly would have been surprised if
you told me that uh at the end of the
cold war we'd sit around and have a
debate about whether or not we should
have government
um
i guess it's part of that back to basics
movement
um
as you know many of our fellow citizens
and public office holders are just bound
to determine that government's no damn
good and um
i think it's kind of interesting that
we're sitting here having this debate um
it may be that government is no damn
good but then neither is the alternative
i mean of course we live in a hopelessly
regulated society when you come to a
stop sign you got to stop
you want to go fishing you got to get a
license you want to go shoot ducks you
can only shoot three ducks
on the whole is better than a lot of
dead bodies at the intersection no
fishing no ducks
[Applause]
i live of course in an interstate where
there are a great many right-wingers
far more excitable than
brother newt and others and brother rush
and they do feel that their liberties
are being infringed and that the
government has become evil now their
chief example which is what happened in
waco to the branch davidians
there's a pretty impressive hunk of
evidence frankly
but i will tell you as somebody who was
there is somebody who wrote at the time
who somebody has said ever since uh that
what the government did in waco 2 the
branch davidians was unconscionable
that it was not part of a government
conspiracy it was as any realist would
know even from a distance as usual it
was a giant screw-up
um
it was just a screw-up from beginning to
end
and law enforcement didn't do one single
damn thing right that whole 52 days
but it wasn't because they were evil
uh mostly there were guys with waco pd
and mclennan county sheriff's department
texas rangers highway patrol atf fbi and
they're sitting around having tear force
for 51 days
scratching and spitting and getting hot
in the sun
and more and more pissed off about these
bozos
uh and they screwed up they screwed it
up at the beginning and they screwed it
up at the end and there it is uh and
when um
when
i hear my more excitable
fellow texans
talk about the
conspiracy and the government taking
over their lives and every day they lose
more liberty and you say what are you
talking about here
well god damn every we're just
surrounded by regulations i mean if you
want to drive you have to get a driver's
license if you want to get married you
have to get a marriage license
if you want to build a house you have to
get a building permit and then after you
get it built it has to pass the
electrical inspectors
you know
look
that's
not the government taking your way of
free that's government it's not taking
away your freedom it's inconveniencing
you
this is not tyranny this is a pain in
the ass
[Applause]
um
i do know that those of uh those of you
who are nostalgic for the good old days
will be reassured since we seem to be
headed back there quite rapidly under
republican leadership
um i read right after newt i speak of
course of the um
draft dodging dope smoking deadbeat dad
who divorced his dying wife newt
gingrich um
a characterization which meets every
standard of accuracy set by rush
limbaugh
um
the draft dodge and dope speaking dope
spoken deadbeat dad who divorced his
dying wife
uh said right after election that he was
going to root out
every single last vestige of the great
society root and branch it was right
there on the front page of the new york
city times so it must be true
and i thought that was a fairly
impressive goal and now i notice that uh
he's talking about repealing the new
deal
you're going back further we're going to
get rid of the new deal
and then their latest thing is talking
about victorian values
[Music]
now as kathy pilots so brilliantly noted
these people are doing their best to
replicate victorian social conditions of
course they would want victorian values
to go along with them
um
at the rate they're going we're soon
going to be discussing caveman values
headed backward with a vengeance here
uh return to the good old days um
but
since i don't think that there ever was
a good old days it seems to me that we
might start talking seriously with some
of our fellow citizens
about buckling down
i suppose if i were
a thought as rude as rush
uh i would say to many of my fellow
texans uh
who are mistaking uh
inconvenience for tyranny
jesus why don't you people grow up
thank you
[Music]
maybe there's hope for the lone star
state after all
molly ivans
what i like about cornell west is a
combination of many things
scholarly and funky at the same time
you see he's been called by a number of
harvard prof school he attended one of
the finest my the finest spines they've
ever encountered
and when he writes race matters it does
indeed in a very clear way because they
will defuse
his church upbringing with the world
outside the sacred and the secular
sacred and profane together
and what i like about him too is he and
i both had asthma together as kids
he says somewhere that he was drawn to
harvard because teddy roosevelt was a
small boy at asthma i had asthma too and
much closer to the corner west never
would be to teddy roosevelt any day in
the week
in any event in cornell west race does
matter but more than that the human
species and the chance the resiliency
that they have of getting together
matters equally as well both related
here then cornell west
james said that american civilization
was a hotel civilization fusion of
market and home
home that so-called haven in a heartless
world was shot through with patriarchy
leaving scars and bruises and wounds
the market that heartless
practice
in a hellish condition in a dog-eat-dog
world
that makes it very difficult to take
history
seriously
hegel said history was a slaughterhouse
the flow of blood sweat and tears
gibbons said it's the human register of
crimes and follies and misfortunes
and the blues says it's about
scars and wounds and bruises
the problem of evil undeserved unmerited
and unjustified suffering
most
americans like to run away because they
came to this land of liberty and
opportunity to get hold at arm's length
such suffering and sorrow
and sadness
and our great artists remind us be it
herman melville
elizabeth bishop or william faulkner
tony morris and the john cole train that
there's no escape
from this sense of history
so to reflect in 1995 for me it's
the view 1995 as the year in which the
age of europe comes to a close
began in 1492
which columbus encounters indigenous
peoples
imperial expansion
those nations between the euro mountains
and atlantic ocean that would attempt to
shape the world in their image the
europeanization
of
the world
with breakthroughs in oceanic
transportation and military technology
and
new ways of urbanization
later on industrialization the
constitution of new institutions called
nation states new ideologies like
nationalism given a disintegration of
the old empires that particular slice
in the history of the human adventure
1492
to 1945 1492 expulsion of jews and
muslims from spain
1945
indescribable
levels of evil seen in concentration
camps mushroom clouds over hiroshima
nagasaki
for the first time
this hotel civilization moves to the
center of the historical stage called
america
american empire
lost less than half a million and that
other empire the soviet empire had lost
20
million in that total war mass war first
time in the history of the human
adventure called world war ii
there was a text written in 1945 by a 77
year old freedom fighter called w.e.b du
bois
and the name of that book it's a book
that's rarely read these days it was
called color and democracy peace and
colonies
he said i'm glad that we were able to
hold back the vicious nazism in the
heart of so-called civilized europe
but there was a construct put forward in
1684 in the heart of europe during the
early moments of the age of europe
namely a construct called race has no
scientific content whatsoever but
constructs have consequences
it's linked to white supremacy and
european supremacy
it written 42 years earlier the problem
of the 20th century is the problem of
the color line if you're concerned about
the expansion of democracy
he knew in 1945 it was not simply jim
and jane crowe still at work in america
but european colonialism and imperialism
was still culturally suffocating and
politically subjugating and economically
subordinating brothers and sisters in
asia
and in africa
in other parts of the world
and would the next 50 years
in such a barbaric century with such
levels of bestiality and butchery
and brutality on such a large scale
would we be able to witness
the expansion of democracy and by
expansion of democracy all the boys had
in mind was the
the ability of everyday people to live
lives of decency and dignity meaning
having had some say
over the condition of their existence
the voices heard at the highest level of
the decision-making processes in those
institutions that guide and regulate
their lives
and yet this american empire that now
moves to the center
you recall the question raised by the
great old f o matheson in 1945
would america be able to move from a
moment of perceived innocence
to corruption without a mediating stage
of maturity
and when we look back it looks as if
matheson had a point
would it be able to deal with
the problems that europe was unable to
come to terms with degraded others
pushing working movements
backs to the wall
dealing with the vicious male supremacy
and homophobia
ecological abuse
what have we witnessed in the last 50
years well on the one hand it's true
mass levels of technological innovation
tremendous social movements able to gain
some limited assets to resources
some power and wealth
but for the most part
the deeply conservative character of
american civilization still in place and
that character being twofold one
economic growth by means of corporate
priorities
which corporate elites and bank elites
not simply having disproportionate
amount of power and influence
but at the same time
such power and influence rarely being
part of a public discussion such that we
could question and interrogate it in any
concrete way
so that even in america in 1995
debating about whether government ought
to exist and yet one percent of
population still own 48 of total net
financial wealth and finally the new
york times allows it on the front page
but no serious dialogue
see
no serious dialogue
economic growth by means of corporate
priorities on the one hand and on the
other hand the very very deep seated
forms of xenophobia
positively charged whiteness negativity
based blackness
male privilege
female degradation
straight privilege
devaluation of gay brothers lesbian
sisters
is it possible in 1995
to build on a sense of history so that
we could look
the sadness and sorrow and suffering in
the face and try to sustain some
resistance and
and critique
and struggle
that's why for me i
as powerful as the right appears
it's nothing new
at all
it's part of a long long
pattern of a gangsterized society
crush the foe
by any means
gunfighter nation vis-a-vis indigenous
peoples and brown peoples you see
244 years of child slavery 87 years of
jim crow
a few decades in the sun
and now black faces on welfare reform
affirmative action taxation
as a way of coding the deep-seated white
supremacy
still
at work
there's a sense in which
the michigan militia is simply more
honest
that's all
they're more honest they're being
explicit
about what is so often going on in coded
language
and what then is the left to do in light
of this history well it very much
very much resembles what the boys tried
to do in 1945
one
he tried to keep alive a tradition of
struggle in which
a condition of truth is to allow that
suffering to speak and simply tell the
truth to the powers that be and try to
internet energize and galvanize persons
to convince them that it's still worth
fighting for not simply talking about
organizing mobilizing on the ground
not downplaying white supremacy because
it seems to be a difficult issue
a sidelining male supremacy because we
have to appeal to the middle
a peripheralizing
homophobia because it seems as if the
mass population
are so deeply shaped by it no it's a
matter of trying to be a truth teller
and a witness bear
radically against the odds and that has
been true for the left from the very
beginning from tom payne to brother
martin luther king jr radically against
the grain with a sense of history a
sense of engagement
and a sense of hope
i do in fact believe in hope
but i am not an optimist
it's impossible to be a person of
african descent in america and be an
optimist it's impossible to be a human
being in the 20th century and be a
serious optimist given the levels of
barbarity but we can be prisoners of
hope that is something else
because a prisoner of hope looks at
the butchery
the barbarity
it makes a leap of faith beyond it a
leap in faith in the possibility of
ordinary people everyday people
organizing and mobilizing
sustained by a vision
guided by a sharp and subtle analysis of
wealth and power and resources
and then
engaging in courageous praxis knowing
that
the good society to which
toward which you fight will not be
created tomorrow
but at least your work will leave some
witness for collective memories of those
who come behind 50 years later and say
here were a cloud of witnesses who did
keep track of the social misery and
socially induced forms of suffering so
that maybe
the early decades of this post-european
age
that will have something to
be keith to those who come after but
it's always
a maybe it depends on what we do
[Applause]
cornell west
you know it's a funny thing
how certain books make the best seller
list especially those that put down the
intelligence of most people the dumbing
of america type books
and that finally came with closing the
american mind question is whose mind was
closed
out leading to the ultimate obscenity
belt curve of course
and then you start thinking about
someone else who really thinks through
and speaks of the numbing
of a country
the numbing
toward feeling
not compassion i don't mean that taught
feeling toward oneself
and i can't even better the analyst the
one who gets into the core bites the
core of the apple better than bob lipton
in that
following hiroshima
he wrote the book
death in life that the
national book award
the life of a hibakusha a survivor
at the same time book about nazi doctors
a pioneer in a whole new field called
psycho history
but his most recent book perhaps is the
one hopeful book not that the others
aren't because you understand that's a
note of hope attached to it remember
there was a there was a
a farm worker jesse de la cruz who said
we have a saying among the chicano farm
workers
esperanza it's a bad mixture of spanish
i have esperanza al utmo
hope dies last
and in a sense this is what bob lipton
writes about in the new book he has
called the protein self
the resilience and that's what cornell
west was touching on all the others were
too the resilience of human at a time of
fragmentation here then robert j lipton
thanks very much studs
i think
they kind of save that the heavy for
last
it's been a long evening it's not quite
over
but there's still a little more to say
it's sometimes disconcerting to be
identified with horrors as stud said
with nazi doctors with hiroshima with
vietnam with chinese thought reform you
name it and people sometimes say to me
okay
how do you study immerse yourself in all
these horrors and still stay sane if
indeed one can make that assumption
and my answer is with considerable truth
i draw bird cartoons
and in one such cartoon which i'm going
to mention now which i'd like to
consider my existential classic
a young enthusiastic small bird looks up
with great enthusiasm and says all of a
sudden i had this wonderful feeling
i am me
and an older
larger more jaundice and skeptical bird
looks down and says you were wrong
i have the sense of our evening and
certainly my remarks uh as resembling
the answer that jean-luc goddard once
gave when somebody asked him whether his
films had a beginning a middle and an
end he thought for a moment and said
yes they do but not necessarily in that
order
i i was very pleased that studs uh
mentioned my my recent book the protein
self and its expression of hope it's
interesting that i think people got
angriest at me for expressing hope a lot
of reviewers can't stand the idea of
hope in this culture but i agree with
cornell uh
there's no room for optimism and there's
an absolute necessity for hope
indeed the very confrontation of these
horrors is an act of hope because one
always looks into the abyss in order to
see beyond it
let me start with a personal memory um
my wife and i arrived in hiroshima in
with our infant then infant son in early
april of 1962 it was a lovely spring day
uh
and we learned something very quickly
that i've never forgotten and may have
been the most important thing that i
learned there in the entire six months
that we stayed there and that was very
simply that
here was one of the most draconian
tragic and horrible events
and significant events
of human history
and 17 years later
nobody had studied it
there had been little forays people had
been interviewed people had expressed
their experiences but nobody
had attempted a systematic
research enterprise
into
what had happened to people in that city
to those killed into those who were
survived those who could survive
of course
that finding said something about the
world's feeling toward hiroshima and it
has a lot to do with uh why we're all
here tonight in our confrontation with
commemoration
we move from individual memory to
collective memory to something like
national memory and there's where we get
very stuck in relation to hiroshima
it's
part of what can be called the american
raw nerve
the enormous sensitivity to anything
that happens in relationship to
hiroshima and therefore an almost
automatic response of avoidance so that
the nerve won't be touched so that we
won't feel the pain
but
collective witness
any witness requires precisely that we
feel the pain precisely that we open
ourselves
to suffering
and take it in and reconstruct it i
remember a very powerful brief
conversation i had with a friend of mine
who's an auschwitz survivor at the time
i was beginning my work on nazi doctors
and uh i was anxious and and the work
was unpleasant and i kind of complained
to my friend i said look you know i
didn't expect that i'd have these
terrible nightmares and i'd be behind
bars and my wife and my children would
be there too and that's even worse
and this auschwitz survivor looked at me
without
either condemnation or pity and he said
to me
good now you can do the study
it's that quality of
witness that we so resist in relation to
hiroshima and that is so much required
what i learned put in a few sentences
during that six-month study of survivors
of hiroshima go something like this
from that split second that moment in
time
that people were exposed to that bomb
those who survived they
underwent a lifelong immersion in death
it could be understood in several stages
the first stage had to do with the sea
of death around them and grotesque death
and dying and the second stage had to do
with equally grotesque
symptoms they could observe in others
and themselves uh within months weeks
sometimes hours after the bomb had
fallen and these were of course the uh
bizarre symptoms of acute radiation
bleeding from all the bodily orifices
bleeding into the skin gastrointestinal
symptoms weakness and frequently death
third stage had to do with
the appearance not within days weeks or
months but years decades later
of the chronic radiation effects
increases in leukemia and finally in all
the major forms of cancer
and the knowledge the recognition over
time that these conditions could be
transmitted to subsequent generations
in fact when we went back to hiroshima
uh fairly recently in the last few years
and talked to people there one of them
said to me something i'll never forget
he said well it looks as though the
second generation
seems to be okay but we don't know about
the third generation
in other words the potential
effects of radiation
are endless and so is the fear and
finally then there developed the
identity the self-image of the hibaksha
explosion affected person
which i came to associate with the
identity of the dead a person who felt
himself herself almost as if dead and
without fully the right to live or to
live in a vivid fashion though many have
struggled and really experienced a uh a
personal form of renewal
well this is the fundamental experience
of the atomic bombing this is exactly
what we have consistently and
systematically avoided in this country
and precisely what has been the failure
of the american collective witness in
relationship to hiroshima america is of
course not unique in this way
no country ever completely confronts its
own past least of all
when that past involves massive killing
and dying but we have an added dimension
as americans we have an absolute need to
see ourselves as not only a decent
people but a blessed people
and that raw nerve has to do with the
contradiction
between
what we did in hiroshima
and our sense of ourselves as decent
human beings
so when greg mitchell and i undertook
the recent book that we've just finished
and the book is called hiroshima in
america it's an attempt to witness what
has happened to this country
as a result of using the weapon the
impact of the bomb on us
we used as a subtitle
50 years of denial
and i must say that uh greg mitchell
who's in the audience with us tonight
has been a wonderful and warm friend and
colleague and fellow explorer of these
issues all through the struggle i
thought of greg
as we were listening to marvin miller
and his description of the baseball
players and the strike because uh greg
and i would
intermittently relieve our discussions
of hiroshima with
lively
lively statements about what had
happened the evening before in baseball
and suddenly it was all over there was a
strike and there was nothing for us to
talk about but hiroshima so in a way i
think we suffered more from the baseball
strike than anybody else
in our book just putting things very
briefly
we begin
not with the decision to use the weapon
that we come to that but rather with the
announcement by harry truman of the use
of the weapon the militarization
so to speak of an attack on an
undefended essentially civilian city and
we develop the evolution of what we call
the official narrative the official
american explanation of hiroshima which
remarkably although
misleading distorting and false in just
about every way
still in many areas prevails and that is
that
the bomb was only used reluctantly after
considerable reflection
it was necessary to end the war and it
saved large numbers a quarter million
and a half million over a million lives
and therefore it was a virtuous act to
drop the weapon you see that the bomb
instead of becoming a lethal genocidal
instrument
is
transformed into a life enhancing device
and that was the official narrative and
it happens that one of the arch
defenders of the official narrative
because there were people who questioned
it courageous thoughtful people
like john hersey uh or
dwight mcdonald or norman cousins and
others
it was none other than james conant then
president of harvard and considered
america's leading intellectual a
renaissance man and he was that
who mobilized the forces of the official
narrative
initiated the article by stimson
published in harper's magazine in 1947
which restated
the official narrative all the things i
just said and left out all the elements
that questioned exactly those
assumptions
so that the need for americans to fend
off guilt and to justify the event
has been almost as damaging
to our society into the world as the
event itself in terms of the decision to
use the weapon what's so interesting is
that in the seventies uh and before that
there evolved all kinds of very
important evidence that throw into
question the necessity of using the uh
atomic bomb on hiroshima there was never
any question about the uh lack of
necessity of using it on nagasaki and uh
it was
this new information this evidence that
so many were afraid of in relation to
the smithsonian scandal
in our own probing of the motivation for
using the weapon without getting into
the conflict between the traditionalists
who say it was used and the war and save
lives and i do think harry truman wanted
to do that and the revision so-called
revisionists who say it was used to
confront the soviet union that's
certainly true as well but looking at
the matter more psychologically you find
that truman was indeed very actively in
the decision and he used it for two
reasons that have not been stated before
one was he was drawn into the power
surge of the weapon itself there was a
transformation of american emotions
right after the test of the weapon on
july 16th at alamogordo and stimson
describes this in his then secretary of
war describes it in his diary said we
all underwent a change in psychology i
did too the change was the tragic
experience of being drawn to the weapons
power
what i call the psychology of nuclearism
and we haven't really recovered from
that yet and the second major reason for
truman's opting to use the weapon along
with his advisers was he was afraid not
to
he was afraid not to
there was at the time the idea of a new
weapon it was a dreadful war uh if you
have a weapon and you don't use it you
can be criticized more than that there
was open discussion among the leaders
and advisers of the horrors of a
continuous congressional investigation
if the weapon weren't used and four
billion dollars which was an enormous
sum at the time had been spent on this
secret enterprise so uh a second major
reason was truman was afraid not to use
it well think of the absurdity and
danger of creating a situation where one
is drawn into one the power surge of a
weapon like this and afraid not to use
it and indeed such a situation uh is all
too possible and we came close to
experiencing it more than once in the
post-war world
we take up also in our study the
contending groups in american society
which led to the smithsonian controversy
whether they're presidents the bomb
pioneers uh various uh the pilots and
crewmen and the scientists and the media
and each is struggling with some way of
surviving hiroshima the psychology of
giving meaning
to this event that had something to do
with one's life
and the tragedy here that's been so
confusing to americans is that here was
this
war against fascism a war against evil
and fascism was evil a crusade against
fascism which ended with evil acts of
our own
we have to take in both of those sets of
truths but they're antithetical and
unacceptable to many americans hence
again that raw nerve and it's also a
narrow form of american nationalism that
has to and this has been a central issue
for the smithsonian even underneath the
veterans who in some way were front men
is the uh nationalistic right wing from
congress
having the need
to assert american virtue and glory
and the truths about the weapon
are inconsistent with those narrow
nationalistic distortions
finally in our study we take up the
legacy the the psychological moral and
political legacy of hiroshima it's been
touched on by other speakers and it's
enormous
more than we've realized it's the
beginning of our nuclear entrapment
to defend the weapons that we used when
has to make more and bigger and better
weapons
otherwise one is always in this process
fending off the guilt and reasserting
the justification it also developed
moral inversion i described it in terms
of the weapon becoming life enhancing
but then think of another harvard
professor joseph nye writing a book
called nuclear ethics in which he
carefully and logically using all sorts
of philosophical references makes the
case for the ethics of using nuclear
weapons under certain conditions
it begins with hiroshima a moral
inversion we could go on as we do in our
book issues of desecration and national
self-betrayal
just look at the experiments with
plutonium which began about the time of
hiroshima some of them before
the intentional release of radiation
into american communities without
anybody's knowledge this is a concrete
expression of national self-betrayal in
relation to our weapons which took hold
of our society and became the central
objects and the central dynamic of
american society and we haven't yet
stepped out of that dynamic
then also there is the issue of
apocalyptic concealment of the creation
of a society of secrecy and concealment
that we're very familiar with which
began with the mother of all cover-ups
the cover-up of hiroshima and if you
want to understand vietnam or watergate
or iran contra and the various
subsequent cover-ups take a look at the
cover-up of hiroshima and that of course
is uh
accompanied by elaborate numbing
an evolution of a numb society in which
we're supposed to follow the experts
it's only those in the charmed circle of
the nuclear priests who ostensibly have
the knowledge to lead us into this
nuclear weapons dominated world but the
numbing spreads to other places and to
other places and to the loss of
compassion for suffering and for feeling
uh toward our fellow human beings and
finally there is the futurelessness
which i've been trying to write about
for decades the
sense we all have in some part of our
mind that everything may suddenly end
and the double life we live as we go
about our ordinary everyday pursuits
while knowing that that apocalyptic
outcome is indeed a possibility
but in doing all this
there is in our work and in this
confrontation and in this evening
tonight really a quest for renewal
commemoration seeks renewal
in a psychological sense one can say
that by taking in mass death
we reassert the value of life and our
commitment to the human future
in a political sense
by confronting our own genocidal acts
we can become more sensitive to and
perhaps reverse the scandalous failure
on our part and that of the rest of the
world notably the leading western powers
to take
active steps to stop the genocides
in bosnia and rwanda
again much of that
much of that begins with hiroshima and
ethically by rejecting these grotesque
moral inversions
uh in favor of difficult but liberating
moral truths
we open our minds and our beings to
better directions and indeed to the
direction that i call a species
mentality uh the sense of commonality of
the peoples of the world which is almost
forced upon us thrust upon us
by the very threat that we share in
common indeed by our shared fate in
relationship to that human future
let me close with a line of poetry which
has to be the favorite line of poetry
for a person who does the things that i
do it's a line from that great american
lyric poet theater rutger who said very
simply
in a dark time the eye begins to see
how about how about a salute to all six
of our distinguished guests
and now since you're going to take part
with questions could we have
oh please could we have the full house
lights on
the full house lights
a model
the full house lights it's a town
meeting
people got to see the faces of people
jesus in any event
before that this is not mandatory
but six panelists may have a question
very brief panel discussion to ask one
another perhaps i say it doesn't matter
but if you do anybody here have
something he she'd like to address to
the others
i see a shaking of the heads because
they really want to hear from you
so okay we have the mike here have mike
here and let's get this straight
questions not dissertations
okay but first of all is randy coffin in
the house
randy coffin
mr william sloane coffin a word perhaps
from you about an event that's taking
place right now
could you get the mic randy
you got a mic
yeah there's a microphone where's the
mic right there
can you get there
okay randy coffin
they're worried about william sloane
coffin and
dan ellsberg and bishop hunthouse and
but she'll tell you about that
there is a small group of us who have
been fasting
in front of the isaiah wall across from
the united nations
um dan has been fasting now since the
17th the beginning of the npt hearings
at the un
bill and i and several others have been
at the wall
on the sidewalk across uh for the last
week and we'll stay there until
the end of the hearings um
the 12th
and continuing the fast we would love
to have your support your encouragement
your bodies
uh your letters uh to your
own representatives wherever you are
from
the abolition of nuclear weapons
is such an obvious extension
of everything that we've heard here
tonight
there's only one safe thing to do
only one logical thing to do and only
one virtuous thing to do
we have to abolish the weapons
so please join us thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
okay
the mic is open
it's right down here
it's a walk can anybody make it
they're a couple okay
so questions addressed to any member of
the panel
and you don't have to because we have a
big surprise in the moment
that we that you will enjoy very much
indeed
here's a question
yes sir
address to anybody yeah well first i
like to say molly uh
the land of milk and honey is looking
more like the land of bread and water
every day
the quiet desperation of the american
people has never been more acute than
now
working class middle class professional
class the poor
they're generically all the same the
have not class
it's just a matter of degree
martin luther king king stated the cause
of the people should be human rights
the landed gentry has successfully
convinced the american people
that human rights is the problem of
other nations
should human rights be taken up again as
the banner of the american people
against the ruling class
was it aimed at anybody of chris
definitely yours
i mean human rights is is a useful
banner but i think once we unpack what
we're actually talking about here what
it seems to me we're we're trying to get
at
uh on a material level the these
decrepit educational systems the
inadequate health care the unavailable
child care no jobs with a decent wage
for the significant numbers of persons
and that has to do with the relation of
management labor it has to do with the
globalization of our economy that's been
able unable to do that across the board
and on the cultural level it has to do
with the relative erosion of the
nurturing and caring systems
uh which is a distinctive feature of a
civilization indicate inability of large
numbers of persons to gain assets the
bonds of affection and networks of
support so we have to be able to talk
about the struggle for human rights in
these very
uh uh accessible and concrete terms so
that people can
give an account for
the low quantity of jobs with a decent
wage and the low quality of life for
most of us
and as i mentioned before you know you
get one percent of the population
uh at the very top doing very well 20 of
the population population living in a
world very very different than the rest
of the population
and that is deep balkanization and
polarization in terms of lived
experience not even talking about how
people organize and mobilize so the
question becomes how do we flesh out
what we mean by human rights i think
that the next major issue in american
society is going to be a focus on the
the the quality of life for america's
children because it's one of the last
issues that actually holds a variety of
sectors of americans together because
most americans are deeply concerned
about the levels of
rootlessness and deracination the
escalating levels of suicide and
homicide and the
sense of drift and
among young people
be those young people in chocolate
cities or vanilla suburbs
i see about six seven people very brief
questions and the call for brief replies
responses
as well as being the fiftieth year of
nearly everything it's also the
hundredth anniversary of the birth of
lewis mumford a writer i've come to
revere and respect after studying his
work for many years i'm just curious if
any of the panelists would like to
comment on the possibilities of organic
regionalism as articulated in mumford in
the 20s and has allied concepts of the
garden city ebenezer howard and patrick
getty's i can't think of an idea that is
more seminal to the continuation of a
decent future for humanity thank you
address to anybody in particular or who
wants to tackle that
i'll partly tackle it by not entirely
tackling it uh what i want to say about
lewis mumford uh is that he was one of
the first and the most consistent to
recognize the madness of nuclear weapons
of course he did other great things that
you were suggesting
and he wrote a classical essay which in
in four words i guess says it all
gentlemen you are mad
a quick word if i may his widow sophia
mumford
in in a book i put out recently
anyway sophia mumford speaks of her
husband uh repeating
recollecting what bob lipton just said
he was
mobilized by a lot of his fellow
scholars at the time when he spoke about
the madness of vietnam at the very
beginning so being a scholar quote
unquote in itself
does not mean a learned person
in any event yes sir
another ring
ring lardner jr
the best of all screenwriters ever
a number of speakers
spoke of hope and optimism
and i must say
that my most distinct recollections of
1945
that relatively pure year before the
reaction started to set in
is
of optimism
of
hopes
that
the united nations could somehow lead to
world government
that the mere fact of nuclear weapons
could make war so unthinkable that there
could never be any
that
the
defeat of nationalism and race
that the war represented might mean
a diminution of nationalism and race
feelings uh antagonisms in the future
now
catholic said that some of these things
we believe then were illusions
and
perhaps never could have been fulfilled
but i want to ask
of her or any other members of the panel
whether the fact
that
these things have not happened
that
what we saw then as a triumph of of
reason
over fascism which seemed to make
impossible the idea of
we have now christian fundamentalists
muslim phantom monoliths jewish
fundamentalists
uh it seemed unthinkable
to me then
that we could go backward
in that direction
so i'm asking
whether this
means
in the mind of our speakers that
there is just no hope
no such thing as progress
because that is the main lesson
that i seem to have learned over these
50 years
any comment on that molly
um
i uh quite agree with what uh cornell
said anybody with a lack of sense who'd
been optimists after the 20th century uh
clearly down there in the sense god gave
gravel
uh i regard my optimism as a congenital
defect
and there's nothing i can do about it
short of prefrontal lobotomy
if you look even longer at history
i think you will find that all people in
all places at all times have believed
that the world was going to hell in a
hand basket
and it may be that we're going to hell
in a hand basket right this very minute
but
they're only a few minor reasons like
nuclear weapons
to assume that it's any more true now
than it ever has been
it may be that we're in some
mankind has arrived at some
point in history where
there's this absolute race between our
destructive and our constructive side
and to see
you know and you can't tell which is
going to win out
i think
the reason to be optimistic or perhaps
more correctly stated hopeful
is not
on the evidence but because it's a
better way to live
kathy
did you want to say something well yeah
i i i guess hit the mic
oh that was beautifully said but is it
true is it better to live i mean can you
say i should be hopeful because i'll
feel better i mean
um
i used to think that i used to think you
know well hope is the radical position
um and i used to quote
a sort of particularly repulsive um
veritable direct line in which he says
uh hope cannot be said either to exist
or not to exist but when many people
pass by
a road is made and that's all very well
but the question is sort of where's that
road leading
um i mean the thing about thinking for
example that nuclear weapons would make
war so horrible that no one would engage
in it
is that's really a silly idea i mean you
might just as well say having to fight
with um swords is it you have to be
right up there killing a person so no
one will ever do that you know but a
nuclear weapon you just drop it and
forget you know file and forget but
people like to kill people that's the
horrible thing
um i mean that has to be in there
somehow it can't just be that everybody
has these wonderful intentions and yet
the bad thing always happens whoops we
did it again you know if only jfk had
lived he would have taken us out of
vietnam you know that's a very
superficial analysis of history and um
you know maybe some other time we'll all
meet and have another analysis of
history but i think it you know
you have to really know what is going on
for example when christopher talked
about the way that the foundations of
american imperialism were really laid in
world war ii that isn't you know if you
really think that then you can't think
all these great things were about to
happen you would know they weren't going
to happen but i think people didn't put
it together
at the time it's only later as
is so often the case
i don't you know
can i just say can i say a word but
brother studs can i just say a quick
word
about this issue because i mean i think
that um
we have to bring art in on this
when we look at this visual century and
you take a check off seriously with no
optimism
no hope capital h whatsoever
but he says endure compassionately
endure lovingly keep the humane
connection even in a moment in which
form the dehumanization seem to be
predominant and hegemonic
or a kafka
no possibilities no options writing as a
form of prayer as a way of keeping some
transcendence but a transcendence that
is so imminent given the depths of the
suffering
that's what i mean by hope or a cold
train in terms of art as spiritual
wrestling but the spiritual wrestling
presupposes some agency you're not
passive as you wrestle you see
and for me that's what i mean by by hope
now again you know
the risk of being
rather parochial i can try to drag in
some of this christian mythology and
narrative in right the sense of being
powerless the good being powerless
right
forces of good being dead as it were
on a cross
and yet some struggle
in the form of love love in the form of
resistance resistance against powers
that be ruling elite and roman empire
that put this particular palestinian jew
and mediterranean peasant to death now
no matter how thick we take that or how
thin we take that that is a particular
affirmation of human agency against the
odds and i say to myself if four mothers
and forefathers
and slavery could have some sense of
agency and certainly
we in the latter part of 20th century no
matter how difficult this situation is
should be able to come up with some form
of affirmation of agency against the
arts
before before we hit me i noticed a
distinguished as a distinguished visitor
seated up front he's been a professor at
a number of universities and he's had
difficulty with something because of his
recognized approach to life if you may
perhaps have something to say
sir
yes sir
just tomorrow this is uh
sir
however
i just want to know
i would like to put this in the form
of an answer
and you as students can put it in the
form of a question
louder
in the first place i would like to know
from our baseball authority i want to
know who gets the money of 95 million
dollars for a franchise
that was just one question not
necessarily informative nor do we
decline any intentions which might elude
us or even give us some substantial
thought to whatever the commitment might
be
so i say that in order for us to to
establish this continuity we must reject
in the form of the the obstacles which
seems to uh elude our attention
what was the question what was the
question
nevertheless i do want to thank you and
i want you to know
that it is better
to receive
than to give
i mean a lot of people say it's better
to give you want to give give give give
you finally give but you say but you
never get tired of receiving
therefore i say don't earn more than you
could spend
but spend more than you earn
and die in debt
now if you owe a lot of money you're
going to live long
i mean the people you owe to are going
to make sure you live long
but if you die at 75 and you owe 300 000
to amortize that loan at 30 000 a year
with a crude interest would take you 18
years to pay it off so you actually live
to be
93
because you would have
used the money that if you did live you
would have expended that money so i say
what we should do in order to re release
the affluent plateau
we should borrow
borrow
start with your friends
borrow from your friends and when they
ain't got any more money make new
friends
that's what made our country so strong
our forefathers borrowed they borrowed
and bowed and never paid it back
our fathers borrowed we ain't gonna pay
it back
we borrowed we're not gonna pay it back
therefore i say it was our forefathers
that gave us this great debt
our forefathers if we only had two
fathers instead of four fathers we'd
have half the goddamn debt
and i just want to say
the latest thing is that toricelli
who seems to have a pet thief of cuba it
was he that said
for years castro has refused to remove
his country from our military
base at guantanamo
and when that happens i am sure the
civilians will not only gather in the
fort but bring over these obstacles and
make it necessary for all of you people
here you fools don't understand that
these are the
town halls if we had more halls we would
be able to put people who are no longer
circumstance take that picture
okay
i just want to thank the nation i want
to thank paul
paul muni uh no
paul newman for the contribution to the
nation institute i want to thank studs
who came all the way from chicago a
place where valentine is a wonderful day
and i also want you to know i want to
thank haitian who was a wonderful guy of
course the english part of our fathers
you got to remember there
you son of a [ __ ] no what i want to say
is that we in this nation not a nation
but we in this land we have come over
here
as
poles
lit bucks christianas english turks we
came over here killed the indians and
took their land and we listened to a
constitution which was founded by our
forefathers
who were slave holders a criminal act
remember
what was the question
i want to thank you and it's really fun
to be here i want to thank you all for
being here because without you these
people would not be here
okay
i assume you realize that was none of
the professor erwin corey
what a question
yes sir by the way we i realized that
quite if you want to ask we may have to
cut it after two and then we'll have
what we call a beehive you can still
gather around ask people questions if
you want to let's say two more hope you
don't because we do have a surprise
visitor
who has something quite remarkable to
offer
yes sir okay um i was born in 1954 so i
missed the first decade immediately
after the war but as a history teacher
i've studied quite extensively and i
have this dreadful thought that the two
holocaust the holocaust against the jews
and the nuclear holocaust which followed
were related in that once we liberated
the concentration camps saw the horror
that was done and then there were these
people who wanted to play with a bomb
knew it would have horrible results but
said look so many terrible things have
already happened in this war why not one
more and we'll test our weapon and get
it over with
from everything i've studied america
seemed to be in its glory from 1945 to
49 being the world's only nuclear power
and felt so miserable when that ended
that they executed an innocent jewish
couple the rosenbergs who i think we
have definitive proof now that they were
innocent
and
that brought on the whole era of
mccarthyism and everything so anyway i'm
addressing my question to dr west and
also to
mr turkle or
dr lifton who were around at that time
thank you
i do confess to having been around at
that time and i'm not sure that makes me
an authority but uh i guess it counts
for something
that you're right i i think it's very
important to
try to grasp the many threads that
relate
the nazi genocide in europe to the
american atomic bombings of japan
the very initiation of the atomic
weaponry of course was in response to
the fear that the germans with a more
advanced nuclear physics
development would make the weapon first
and
more than that the totalization of
warfare which didn't begin with world
war ii but reached a new dimension in
world war ii
uh led very readily to
relationship between nazi mass murder
and
the american atomic bombings atomic
bombings also as you know were a direct
continuation of the saturation bombings
of germany and then even more of japan
so that we were already in the habit we
being great britain in the united states
in the habit of bombing civilians as
part of a war policy uh the atomic
bombings being a quantum leap from that
nonetheless a continuity having said all
that we don't stop at that point that's
important for our historical analysis it
doesn't mean that the whole game is over
and there's nothing we can do now
there is the possibility for agency at
every moment
the weapons don't just proliferate
automatically or the genocidal impulses
don't just happen
they are people making decisions
uh and taking evil actions and we can
have a say about them and if we don't we
we're colluding in that process so one
shouldn't mistake
the historical analysis of very
draconian events
for some absolute determination of the
future
history remains open and it depends what
we
do now i know i know you all have
people standing have good questions to
ask and you're going to hate me for this
but
why don't you ask that as we after we
adjourn
ask those you want to because i would
like to bring on forgive me for this but
we'd like to
let's do it right after the deal
you want to do all right quickly
yes if i may
i have a brief quote which was written
the dateline is saturday july 15
1944
it's utterly impossible for me to build
my life
on a foundation of chaos
suffering and death
i see the world being slowly transformed
into a wilderness
i hear the approaching thunder that one
day will destroy us too
i feel the suffering of millions and yet
when i look up at the sky
i somehow feel that everything will
change for the better that this cruelty
too shall end that peace and tranquility
will return once more it's a wonder i
haven't abandoned all my ideals they
seem so absurd and impractical
yet i cling to them because i still
believe
in spite of everything that people are
truly good at heart
ma'am i want to be useful
or bring enjoyment to all people
even those i've never met i want to go
on living even after my death
and she did and it's anne frank of
course
that's it no that's it for now thank you
we'll have the questions right after
right now
i'd like to bring on
one of the most perceptive wittiest
journalists in america funeral directors
know all about her
the american way of death remember was
one of her books she's written a great
money
none of them jessica decker mitford in a
new light
as a performer
thank you very much
thank you
wonderful to be here this great audience
thank you so much for coming
i first want to call on the person who's
responsible for the absurd business that
you're about to hear in a moment or two
kathy goldbach who may be known to some
of you but she has made her mark on me
she's absolutely transformed my life in
the most ridiculous passion with these
absurd deck tones that she's got and
it's my great pleasure now to call upon
kathy goldmark the creator of this whole
thing and the deck tones
[Applause]
[Music]
okay we're gonna need everybody here
tonight to be a deck tone so when i hold
up this sign
you will all yell
[Applause]
very good okay now you're ready you're
all rehearsed
[Music]
joan was quizzical started metaphysical
science in the home
all alone at night with a test tube
maxwell edison majoring in medicine
called her on the phone
will you come with me to the pictures
uh oh
as she's getting ready to go
and always comes at the door
bend back maxwell's silver hammer came
down upon
[Music]
made sure that she was dead
back in school again maxwell plays the
fool again teacher gets annoyed
wishing to avoid an unpleasant c
e
she tells max to stay when the class has
gone away so he waits behind
writing 50 times i must not be sir
uh oh
[Music]
[Music]
her head
bang bang maxwell's silver hammer made
sure that she was dead
me
[Music]
bc31 said we caught a dirty one maxwell
stands alone
painting
testimonial pictures
rose and valerie screaming from the
galleries say he must go free
the judge does not agree and he tells
themselves
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
he was dead
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you very much
barbra streisand
who is aretha franklin jessica mitford
and this by the way is a good way to
adjourn with a song and thank you very
much indeed
thank you
[Applause]
that's it it worked out all right
good evening yeah
you were terrific when you come to town
we'll do a program and you're coming out
of town with the book i don't know maybe
we'll yeah
this event was held as part of a new
york city forum known as the town hall
which brings together people of varied
backgrounds for discussions of political
and social policy
these reflections on 1945 will run again
tonight beginning at quarter past
midnight eastern time on c-span
c-span's washington journal